SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING OF THE.
EDUCATION FINANCE.
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR THE BUDGET
WILL START WITH ISSUE NUMBER
ONE.
THE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING AS WE DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM TO DO THE VOTE ONLY ITEMS
SO.
WE HAVE THE CTC FOLKS COMMAND.
THIS IS ISSUE NUMBER ONE.
THE GOVERNOR'S CTC BUDGET
PROPOSALS.
INCLUDING.
THE MORNING GOOD MORNING. WAYS I
GUESS THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS IT'S.
GOOD TO SEE YOU THIS MORNING.
SO I'M JUST GOING TO START BY
WITH A QUICK REMINDER OF THE CDC
THE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING IS A SPECIAL
FUNDACION SEE.
WE HAVE THREE CORE FUNCTIONS THE
FIRST IS A SET STANDARDS.
BUT THE PREPARATION OF THE
EDUCATION WORKFORCE AND ISSUE
CREDENTIALS TO INDIVIDUALS WHO
EARN THEM. A SECOND BUT USE THE
PROCESSING OF COASTED OVER TO IT
AND FIFTY THOUSAND DIFFERENT
CREDENTIAL DOCUMENTS EVERY YEAR.
THIRD IS TO OPERATE A TEACHER
DISCIPLINE SYSTEM FOR ANY
EDUCATOR WHO SAID.
.
RECOMMENDED TO US FOR REVIEW
BASED ON MISCONDUCT.
AYE WE'RE OVERSEEN BY A NINETEEN
MEMBER COMMISSION OF THE TO MEET
SIX TIMES A YEAR. FOLLOWING
SEVERAL YEARS OF DECLINE HAN
CREDENTIALS MEMBERS AND AND
REVENUES WE'VE SEEN IN THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS ADAPTEC AND THAT
HAS BEEN HEALTHY FOR THE AGENCY
AND ITS BUDGET.
IN THE LAST FEW YEARS WE'VE DONE
SOME MAJOR HOW PROJECTS WE'VE
OVER HOLDER ACCREDITATION SYSTEM
WEARING IT FROM A PAPER BASED.
SYSTEM FOCUSED ON COMPLIANCE TO
A PERFORMANCE BASED SYSTEM WHERE
WE LOOK AT A NUMBER.
QUALITY INDICATORS TO DETERMINE
WHETHER PREPARATION IS HITTING
THE MARK. WE'VE BUILT A TEACHING
PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENT OR
REBUILD IF YOU WILL THE
COMMISSION'S TEACHING
PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENT HAND
BUILT. OUR FIRST ADMINISTRATOR
PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENT OVER THE
LAST TWO YEARS BOTH OF THOSE
SYSTEMS ARE READY FOR
IMPLEMENTATION THIS FALL ON
THAT'S BEEN A VERY EXCITING SET
OF REFORMS. THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAVE GIVE US FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS TO DO THAT WORK TOOK US
TWO YEARS TO COMPLETE THAT
DEVELOPMENT AND GET THEM READY.
COMMISSION HAS DETERMINED THAT
FOR THE ADMINISTRATOR
PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENT BASED ON
HOW COMPLEX THAT SYSTEM IS AND
HOW NEW IT IS FOR ADMINISTRATOR
PREPARATION. THAT NEXT YEAR
WOULD BE A NON CONSEQUENTIAL
YEAR FOR A CANDIDATE SO THEY
WOULD HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPERIENCE IT. THEIR PREPARATION
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO AKE SURE IT'S
FULLY INSTALLED BEFORE WE BEGIN
COUNTING THE SCORES FOR A
LICENSE IN NINETEEN TWENTY.
ABOUT THE SYSTEM ITSELF WILL BE
FULLY IMPLEMENTED IN EVERY OTHER
RESPECT NEXT YEAR.
OUR CREDENTIAL APPLICATIONS ARE
UP.
THANKFULLY WE'VE SEEN SEVEN AND
THREE PERCENT INCREASES OVER THE
LAST TWO YEARS EXPECT THAT THIS
YEAR WILL SEE SOMETHING IN THAT
RANGE AS WELL. OR DISCIPLINE
CASES ARE ALSO UP BY ABOUT TEN
PERCENT OVER THE LAST FIVE
YEARS.
ON THAT THOSE THINGS FOLLOWING
PARALLEL HAS POTENTIAL
APPLICATIONS GO UPSET OR
DISCIPLINE CASES.
WE ARE ALSO WORKING HARD TO
ASSIST THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IS
THEY BRING DOWN A BACKLOG OF
CASES THAT HAVE BEEN REFERRED TO
THEM OF FOR APPEAL.
NETWORK IS BEGINNING TO ALSO
SHOW SOME PROGRESS
SO THAT'S A QUICK OVERVIEW OF
WHAT WE ARE AND WHAT WE'VE BEEN
DOING THE LAST FEW YEARS OF LIKE
TO TURN IT OVER TO FINANCE TO
TALK ABOUT. THE PROPOSALS FOR
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET.
I THINK.
THANK YOU.
THAT MORNING KIMBERLY LEAHY WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
TEACHER CREDENTIALS FUND.
ABOUT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TEST
DEVELOPMENT AND ADMINISTRATION
ACCOUNT FUNDS AND THREE HUNDRED
EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS
REIMBURSEMENT FOR A TOTAL
OPERATING BUDGET OF JUST OVER
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
COMMISSION IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN.
THIS FUNDING SUPPORTS ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE AUTHORIZED
POSITIONS.
IN ADDITION ONE HUNDRED MILLION
ONE TIME PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT. GENERAL FUND IS INCLUDED
FOR TWO NEW TEACHER WORKFORCE
INVESTMENTS WHICH WILL BE
COVERED IN GREATER DETAIL LATER.
FOR THE COMMISSION STATE
OPERATIONS BUDGET THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROVIDES ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION ONE TIME TEACHERS CREDIT
TEACHER CREDENTIALS FUND.
TO CONVERT MICROFICHE CREDENTIAL
RECORDS TO A DIGITAL FORMAT.
THE MICROFICHE CREDENTIAL
RECORDS INCLUDE ALL CREDENTIALS
ISSUED PRIOR TO NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINE AND LIFETIME CREDENTIALS
WHICH DO NOT REQUIRE RENEWAL.
THIS CONVERSION WOULD PROVIDE
THE COMMISSION AND EASY TO
SEARCH DIGITAL REPOSITORY OF ALL
CREDENTIAL RECORDS AND ALLOW THE
COMMISSION TO RETIRE THE
EXISTING OUTDATED. MICROFICHE
SYSTEM.
ONE POINT THREE MILLION ONE TIME
TEST DEVELOPMENT ADMINISTRATION
SUSAN ACCOUNT TO CONDUCT A FULL
FIELD ADMINISTRATION OF THE
NEWLY DEVELOPED CALIFORNIA
ADMINISTRATOR PERFORMANCE
ASSESSMENT.
WHICH WILL BE NON CONSEQUENTIAL
FOR TEST TAKERS.
THIS NON CONSEQUENTIAL
ADMINISTRATION WILL ALLOW
PREPARATION PROGRAMS
TO VERIFY THAT THE PROGRAMS ARE
LYING TO THE NEW ASSESSMENT.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY IT WOULD
ALLOW THE COMMISSION TO
ACCURATELY AND RELIABLY SET THE
ASSESSMENTS PASSING SCORES
WITHOUT IMPOSING NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES ON THE TEST TAKERS.
THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS ONE TIME TEACHER'S
CREDENTIAL FUND IS PROVIDED TO
AUTOMATE TEACHER MRS SIMON
MONITORING.
THE COMMISSION BEGAN MONITORING
TEACHER MRS SIMONS IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY TWO.
THE ACTIVITY IS PAPER DEPENDENT
AND VERY LABOR INTENSIVE FOR
BOTH THE COMMISSION AND LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES.
THE NEW THE NEW PROCESS WOULD BE
BASED ON A DATA MATCH OF WORSE
AND TEACHER ASSIGNMENT DATA FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
WITH CREDENTIAL DATA FROM THE
COMMISSION TO PRODUCE A DIGITAL
DATA SET OF MISS ASSIGNMENTS.
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES WOULD
THEN BE GIVEN AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ASSESS TO EXCUSE ME TO ACCESS.
THE DATA SET TO VERIFY.
THE A MISS ASSIGNMENTS WHETHER
THEY ARE CORRECT OR TWO.
PROVIDE DATA AS TO WHY THEY ARE
APPROPRIATELY ASSIGN TEACHERS.
THE CORRECT DATA SAID WOULD THEN
BE USED TO PRODUCE A REPORT FOR
THE LEGISLATURE.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
PROVIDES TWO POSITIONS AND THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY EIGHT THOUSAND
DOLLARS TEACHER CREDENTIALS
FUND.
SUPPORT THE ADMINISTRATION OF
THE TICKER TEACHER WORKFORCE
INVESTMENTS
FROM PREVIOUS YEARS THE CURRENT
YEAR AND THOSE INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
OF THIS AMOUNT ONE HUNDRED IS
AVAILABLE TWO YEARS TO SUPPORT
TEMPORARY HEALTH.
IN ADDITION THE ADMINISTRATION
THROUGH A SPRING FINANCE LETTER
REQUEST THAT THE COMMISSION'S
REIMBURSEMENTS BE INCREASED BY
ONE HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR A GRANT. FROM THE
SAN DIEGO.
FROM DISNEY STATE SAN DIEGO
UNIVERSITY FOUNDATION TO CONVENE
FIELD EXPERTS TO REVIEW THE
OUTCOMES OF THE CALIFORNIA
ADMINISTRATOR.
LAUP AND JENNIFER KUHN LET'S
ANALYST'S OFFICE SAID BUT TO BE
ASSESSED DID YOU WANT TO. TALK
ABOUT THE STATE OUTSIDE OF THE
OVERALL TEACHERS PROPOSALS RIGHT
X. WE KIND OF ARE BLENDING THE
TWO TOGETHER.
I I WAS GOING TO I THINK FINANCE
JUST EXPLAINED ALL OF THE
PROPOSALS BEFORE C. T. FEED I
WAS GOING TO HIGHLIGHT OUR
REACTIONS TO THE THREE THAT ARE
ON PAGE THIRTEEN OF YOUR AGENDA
PERFECT AND THEN JUST TALK AT
THE AND ABOUT TEACHER MISCONDUCT
CASES WHAT DO. SO THROUGH AFFORD
TO START OF OBLIQUELY AND SO I
WAS STUDENT TAKE THEM IN THE
ORDER THEY APPEAR HERE IN YOUR
AGENDA SO ON THE FIRST ISSUE
THAT'S RELATED. TO AUTOMATING
THE TEACHER MONITORING
ACTIVITIES WE HAVE NO CONCERNS
WE DID EXAMINE WHETHER THE STATE
COULD DO IT THROUGH EXISTING
MEANS OUR DO IT MORE CHEAPLY BUT
CONCLUDED THAT IT COULDN'T.
THE INFORMATION BEING COLLECTED
WE THINK IS IMPORTANT ITS BASIC
TEACHER ASSIGNMENT DATA DOES THE
TEACHER HAVE WHAT THEY NEED TO
BE WORKING IN OUR AREA. AND TO
BE ABLE TO DO IT AND I AYE A
SMALL AMOUNT OF ONE TIME MONEY
TO BE ABLE TO AUTOMATE THAT FOR
EVERY SCHOOL EVERY YEAR I WOULD
HOPE YOU WOULD HELP DISTRICTS
UNDERSTAND OF TEACHER SHORTAGES
EXIST IF THEY'RE PERSISTING. AND
THEN AT LEAST SPUR A
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW TO
RESPOND.
THE ONE POINT THREE MILLION FOR
THAT US ADMINISTRATOR
PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENT HAVE
CONCERNS WITH.
SO I'M YOU HEARD THAT A COUPLE
OF YEARS AGO AND FIFTEEN SIXTEEN
ACTUALLY THREE YEARS AGO THE
STATE PROVIDED TWO MILLION TO
DEVELOP THE API. THIS
ADMINISTRATOR PERFORMANCE
ASSESSMENT
AND SEE TO SEE THE LOTS OF GOOD
THINGS ABOUT FUNDING THEY WENT
OUT AND THEY DEVELOP THE EXAM
THEY CONDUCTED FIELD TASKS FOR A
HUNDRED AND TEN CANDIDATES AND
SIX AND SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN. TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY CANDIDATES AND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AGAIN THE
TEST WAS ORIGINALLY UNDER THE
ORIGINAL BUDGET REQUEST TO BE
DEVELOPED AT THE END OF SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN BUT THEY WENT AHEAD
AND DID A SECOND FIELDS HIGHEST.
IN SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN.
THEY ALSO USE A PORTION OF THE
MONEY TO SUPPORT THE PROGRAMS
YOU HAVE TO ADMINISTER THE
TUSTIN TO SUPPORT TRAININGOF
THOSE WHO SCORED THE TOSS.
SO WE'RE CONCERNED THAT NOW THE
REQUEST IS FOR ONE POINT THREE
MILLION TO DO ANOTHER FIELD TASK
BUT THIS FIELD TESTS WOULD BE OF
EVERY CANADA.
AND SO TYPICALLY WE DON'T DO
THREE FEEL TASKS AND WE DON'T DO
A FIELD TEST FOR EVERY CANDIDATE
WHO'S TAKING ON.
SO BEFORE YOU A SORT OF JUST AND
BUT BEFORE YOU REALLY NEED TO
DECIDE ON THIS WE WOULD JUST
SUGGEST THAT.
DID YOU SEE PROVIDER A CLEARER
EXPLANATION FOR WHY AN
ADDITIONAL YEAR IS NEEDED WHEN
IT COMES TO TRAINING OF THE
EXISTING PROGRAMS TO BE FAMILIAR
WITH THE EXAM THE FAB FIVE YEARS
NOW TO AT LEAST BE FAMILIAR THAT
IT'S COMING. THEY'VE ALL EVERY
TRAINING PROGRAM HAS BEEN
THROUGH AT LEAST ONE TRAINING.
OUT SECTION TO LEARN WHAT THE
EXAM IS ALL ABOUT HOW TO
ADMINISTER IT.
ON THE THIRD ISSUE THE ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION FOR THAT POTENTIAL
RECORDS JUST I'M MOMENTS OF
BACKGROUND SO STARTING IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE CTC STARTED
DIGITIZING ANY NEWER CREDENTIAL
APPLICATION SO THE STATE HAS
DIGITAL RECORDS FOR EVERY
TEACHER HIS MINUTE APPLICATIONS
FROM NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE. ON.
FOR THOSE TEACHER RECORDS THAT
ARE BEFORE NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE
THEY HAVE MOST OF THE RECORDS ON
MICROFICHE WHICH WE ALL
UNDERSTAND IS OUTDATED
TECHNOLOGY IN SOME CASES THEY
HAVE THEM ON PAPER.
THE MOST OF THESE TEACHERS HAVE
RETIRED IF THEY HOVER RETIRED
THEY WILL SHORTLY HEAR.
I'M SO SPENDING ONE AND A HALF
MILLION TO TAKE OLD RECORDS AND
TO DIGITIZE THEM OUT WE
CONCLUDED WAS JUST ARE NOT COST
EFFECTIVE SO WE DID ANALYSIS OF
HOW MANY REQUESTS THEY HAVE
RIGHT NOW TO GO BACK WITH THESE.
OLDER RECORDS MAKE IT ROUGHLY
FOUR HUNDRED A YEAR.
WHICH OUT OF HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF TEACHERS AS A VERY
SMALL NUMBER OF REQUESTS.
AND WE THINK AGAIN THAT THOSE
WILL GO DOWN BUT WE JUST RAN AN
ESTIMATE WHAT IF THEY WERE TO
GET SOMETHING LIKE FOUR HUNDRED
REQUESTS A YEAR FOR THE NEXT
TWENTY YEARS AND TELL THESE
INDIVIDUALS ARE RETIRED NO
LONGER LIVING CLEARLY OUT OF THE
PROFESSION.
AND THAT ONE AND A HALF MILLION
DOLLARS IT WOULD TAKE ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER RECORD TO
DIGITIZE A WHICH IS ABOUT TEN
TIMES MORE THAN THEY SPEND RITE
NOW JUST GOING TO THE RECORD
LOOKING AT IT AND ANSWERING THE
QUESTION. SO WE THINK THAT COULD
JUST KEEP STORING THEM ANSWER
THE QUESTIONS AS THEY ARISE AND
IN A FEW YEARS THEY CAN START
RESPONSE AND WHAT THE RECORDS
OUT EXCESS THAT ARE NO LONGER
NEEDED.
THE LAST ISSUE BEFORE YOU HAS IS
NOT A SPECIFIC EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
REQUEST BUT DEALS WITH AN
ONGOING ISSUE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE REGARDING THE STATE
PROCESSING OF TEACHER MISCONDUCT
CASES.
IN TWENTY ELEVEN.
THERE WAS CONCERN REYES WITH
THE PROCESSING OF THESE CASES
THERE WAS A LARGE INCREASE IN
THE NUMBER OF CASES SUBMITTED
FROM THE FIELD TO CTC.
AND THEN BECAUSE OF THE
INCREASED IN OUR ACTUAL CASES
THERE WERE AS AN INCREASE IN
THOSE CASES THAT WERE APPEALED.
SO WHEN CTC MAKES A DECISION FOR
EXAMPLE TO REVOKE A LICENSE MORE
A CASES WERE BEING APPEALED AND
WHEN THAT HAPPENS THE CASE OF
SHIFTED TO THE HP.
SO.
.
THE LEGISLATURE AND FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN THERE WERE LOTS OF MORE
CASES COMING TO THE AGE SHE THE
NUMBER OF APPEAL DECISIONS
ALMOST TRIPLED FROM ELEVEN
TWELVE TO FOURTEEN FIFTEEN GOING
FROM SIX HUNDRED CASES APPEALED.
TO ALMOST TWO HUNDRED CASES
APPEALED TO THE STATE PROVIDED
SOME MONEY THEY INCREASE THE
CREDENTIAL FEEL THAT EVERY
TEACHER PAYS WHEN THE FILER
CREDENTIAL FROM SEVENTY DOLLARS
TWO HUNDRED. IT WAS ESTIMATED TO
GENERATE FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
AND THE FORMALLY WAS EFFECTIVELY
GIVEN TO THE AG TO DO MORE
PROCESSING OF THESE CREDENTIALS
SO THAT IT WOULD HAPPEN. AN
EXPEDITED FASHION.
HAVING SAID THAT SINCE FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN THE NUMBER OF OPEN CASES
OVER THAT AT THE AG HAS
INCREASED SO IT WAS TWO HUNDRED
AND SIXTY OPEN CASES AND FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN IT'S NOW UP TO THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN OPEN CASES
AS OF SEPTEMBER TWENTY.
SEVENTEEN.
SO STE LEGISLATURE'S BEEN
CONCERNED NOT ONLY GAVE MORE
MONEY BUT STARTED HAVING BOTH
CTC AND AG SUMMIT SOME BETTER
RECORDS OF WHAT THEY WERE DOING
TO LEGISLATURE SO WE HAVE BETTER
INFORMATION WITH AG IS DOING.
IT GAVE US A REPEAL REPORT JUST
A FEW MONTHS AGO FEBRUARY.
SO WE KNOW FROM THAT REPORT THAT
THE AGING NOW IS DEDICATING MORE
STAFF TIME TO PROCESSING THIS
CREDENTIALS IT WENT UP TWELVE
PERCENT.
BUT WE ESTIMATE THAT EVEN WITH
AMOUNTS OF PROCESS IN THAT'S
OCCURRING RIGHT NOW THE AG WILL
USE THREE MILLION OF THE TUNNEL
AND THAT YOU'VE PROVIDED FOR.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE BACKLOG
HAS GONE DOWN IN THE LAST
QUARTER COMPARED TO THE PREVIOUS
ONE ABOUT TEN PERCENT.
BUT PART OF THAT IS BECAUSE
SETTLEMENTS HAVE GONE OUT
NOTABLY AND ONE OF THE REASONS
SETTLEMENTS ARE GOING UP IS
BECAUSE AN LJ RECENTLY AN
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE DECIDED
TO DISMISS THE CASE BECAUSE THE
EVIDENCE WAS SO OLD.
SO WE ALSO KNOW THAT THESE CASES
ARE TAKING AN EXTRAORDINARY LONG
LEE LONG TIME TO PROCESS
SO CTC ON AVERAGE TAKES FOUR
HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN DAYS TO
PROCESS THE CASE IF IT'S
APPEALED IT GOES TO THE AGENCY.
AND THEY'RE TAKING SIX HUNDRED
AND THIRTY FIVE DAYS.
THE PROCESS THE CASE SO IT'S
TAKING MORE THAN A THOUGHT I'M
SORRY SIX HUNDRED AND THIRTY
ONE.
STICKING MORE THAN A THOUSAND IS
TO PROCESS A
IT'S ALMOST THREE YEARS.
SO WE'VE BEEN SUGGESTING.
.
THIS AS A VERY LONG TIME IN MOST
CASES OBVIOUSLY I'M SORRY NOT
OBVIOUSLY BUT IN MOST CASES
TEACHERS AND ABSTAINED IN THE
CLASSROOM Y. THIS STATE REVIEW
IS OCCURRING. EVEN IF AND I'LL
ADD A LICENSES ULTIMATELY
REVOKED.
AND FOR THOSE WHO GET TO KEEP
THEIR LICENSE THEY'RE STILL
INCONVENIENCED BY A PROCESS THAT
SEEKING ALMOST THREE YEARS.
FOR THEM TO BE PART OF THIS
LEGAL PROCESS.
SO WE RECOMMEND TO CONTINUE
MONITORING IT CAN SEND YOU SEE
ENOUGH IMPROVEMENT OCCURS IF
IMPROVEMENT DOESN'T OCCUR YOU
MIGHT LIKE FUNDAMENTALLY RETHINK
HOW THE STATE PROCESSES CASES TO
SEE IF THE STATE'S ADDING VALUE.
WHAT VALUE COULD EXPEDITE THIS
PROCESS?
I HAD A MINIMUM YOU MIGHT WANT
TO PUT IN A STATUTORY TIME FRAME
MAYBE RATHER THAN THREE YEARS
YOU THINK IT SHOULD BE DONE IN
SIX MONTHS. BUT SOMETHING A YEAR
FROM NOW IF YOU HAVEN'T SEEN
SUBSTANTIAL IMPROVEMENT THAT YOU
MIGHT WANT TO CONSIDER.
MAYBE JUST IF YOU CAN RESPOND TO
THE LAST ONE IS OURS.
THAT THE.
THE NEED FOR THAT.
DIGITIZING. THAT SMALL UMBER OF.
RELATIVE SMALL NUMBER OF
INCREASE EACH YEAR. WHY THAT'S
POINTED SO WE HAVE?
?
WE HAVE ELECTRIFY FOR IN OUR
BUILDING THAT IS THE SIZE OF A
PROBLEM NINETEEN SEVENTY
MAINFRAME COMPUTER COULD TAKE UP
A SMALL ROOM BY ITSELF AND
THAT'S OUR STORAGE UNIT. FOR ALL
OF THE MICROFICHE THAT HAVE ALL
OF OUR CREDENTIAL RECORDS ARE
ABOUT ONE POINT THREE MILLION
RECORDS AND IT.
AND.
ESSENTIALLY WE THINK THE MOST
EFFICIENT THING TO DO WAS TO
CREATE A DIGITIZED DATABASE FOR
THAT THAT IS.
ACCESSIBLE WE'VE HAD EIGHT
REQUESTS IN THE LAST TWO YEARS
FOR RECORDS THAT AS EARLY AS
NINETEEN THIRTY.
IT FROM AS A AS A CUSTODIAN IF
YOU WILL OF THE PUBLIC RECORD
AMONG COMFORTABLE WITH WITH
DESTROYING RECORDS RIGHT NOW I
THINK IT'S INCUMBENT UPON US TO
KEEP. THEM INTACT AND AND
STORED.
OF THEY DO DETERIORATE OVER
TIME.
AND THAT BECOMES A PROBLEM FOR
STORAGE AND APPROPRIATE KINDS OF
STORAGE IT SEEMS TO JUST MAKE
BETTER SENSE TO CREATE ONE
RECORD OF DIGITIZED.
.
CREDENTIALS THAT CAN BE SEARCHED
AND UTILIZED FOR. FOR THE FUTURE
AND THAT'S
THAT'S ESSENTIALLY WHAT WE'RE
ASKING FOR THAT I HOPE I'M
ASKING ANSWERING THE QUESTION
THAT YOU'VE ASKED MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
FURTHER QUESTIONS MR MEDINA.
.
LA JOH.
DISTRICTS CAN CHOOSE TO NOT HAVE
THE TEACHER IN THE CLASSROOM IS
THAT CORRECT.
WHEN WHEN THEY'RE.
GET PUT IN THE PROCESS OF.
BEING DISCIPLINE.
I'M STATE LOOKED LIKE IT'S LIKE
I'D LIKE TO I WOULD AYE FASTER
GENERAL COUNSEL VANESSA WHITNALL
TO JOIN US AT THE TABLE SHE
MANAGES THIS WORK FOR THE
COMMISSION SO.
GOOD MORNING VANESSA WHAT NOW
GENERAL COUNSEL FOR THE
COMMISSION.
AND IN RESPONSE TO YOUR QUESTION
YES DISTRICTS CAN REMOVE A
TEACHER FROM THE CLASSROOM.
HOWEVER THEY ARE SUBJECT TO
EMPLOYMENT LAWS IN TERMS OF HOW
TO DO THAT MISSKELLEY PROCESS.
THE COMMISSION ON PROFESSIONAL
COMPETENCE HEARING FIX SATRAPS
SO IT DOES TAKE DISTRICTS.
A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF TIME TO GO
THROUGH THE DISMISSAL PROCESS
BUT THEY DO HAVE THE PAID
ADMINISTRATIVE LEAVE OPTION. SO
THAT FUTURE COULD BE NOT IN THE
CLASSROOM GOING THROUGH THE
DISCIPLINE PROCESS.
AND BEING PAID BY THE DISTRICT
WHEN. CORRECT CORRECT THE NOT
BEING IN THE CLASSROOM CORRECT
BUT THE ON THE PAYROLL OF THE OF
THE.
.
OF THE DISTRICT.
YEAH.
AND I HAD ANOTHER QUESTION.
AS FAR AS THE.
.
THE REQUEST FOR CREDENTIALS
GOING BACK TO NINETEEN THIRTY.
WHAT WHY WOULD WHO WOULD ASK FOR
THAT?
WELL IT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
.
AND THE AND I'M NOT AND I'M NOT
ENTIRELY SURE WHO WOULD ASK FOR
IT I DID HAVE A COMMISSIONER
RECENTLY HOWEVER. MENTION THAT
AND THIS IS A COMPLETE ANECDOTE
BUT.
SHE'S LIVING IN A HOUSE THAT
WAS PREVIOUSLY.
INHABITED BY THE FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMAN WHO WAS APPOINTED
AS AN ADMINISTRATOR FOR A SCHOOL
IN CALIFORNIA.
SHE WORKS AT A CHARTER SCHOOL
AND SHE'S SHE'S THINKING THAT
THIS WOULD BE A GREAT HISTORIAN
PROJECT FOR STUDENTS AND. THE
ABILITY TO COME IN ACCESS THE
WOMAN'S CREDENTIAL.
IS SOMETHING THAT SHE WAS
ASKING ME ABOUT SO THAT WE COULD
IMAGINE THAT THERE ARE THERE'S
HISTORICAL INTEREST IN AND THERE
MAY BE RELATIVES WHO WERE
INTERESTED IN THAT YOU KNOW THE
HISTORY OF THEIR FAMILY AND AND
ANY CREDENTIALS THAT MAY HAVE
BEEN ISSUED. SO THAT INTEREST OF
COURSE IS A CONVENIENCE
THAT WE PROVIDE IT'S NOT A
NECESSITY FOR LICENSURE.
BUT WE HAVE SEEN INCREASED.
REQUESTS FOR RECORDS THERE WITH
BETTER HOUSED IN IN THE LIKE
TREAT HER RIGHT NOW IN PART
BECAUSE WE HAVE A TEACHER
SHORTAGE IN THERE'S GREAT
RECRUITMENT AND PEOPLE WHO ARE
RETIRED YOU CAN COME BACK A
SUBSTITUTE TEACHERS ETCETERA.
ARE REQUESTING THEIR DOCUMENTS
TODAY HAVE THEM UPDATED I'M NOT
SURE ANY OF THEM WERE BORN IN
NINETEEN THIRTY BUT I WOULDN'T
WANT TO MAKE.
HUNDRED PERCENT BACK ON THAT.
WELL AYE AYE WAS CREDENTIALED IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE I THINK
I'M.
I WILL BE ASKING FOR MY
CREDENTIALS ANYMORE IT BUT I WAS
A HISTORY TEACHER AND I SEE THE
VALUE OF RECORDS
IT JUST SEEMS TO ME. THAT IF
IT'S GOING TO BE TEN TIMES AS
MUCH
TO DIGITIZE.
THAT I QUESTION THE.
THE EXPENDITURE.
OKAY THANK YOU WE'RE GONNA HOLD
THESE ISSUES OPEN AND PROCEED
NOW TO. ISSUE NUMBER TWO THE
PROPOSALS ON TEACHER WORKFORCE.
AND SUCH AN AFRICAN AGAIN ON THE
LEDGE ANALYST'S OFFICE AND THAT
WE HAVE.
BUT I'LL GO AHEAD AND JUST GET
STARTED WAY I'M IS BEING PASSED
OUT IT'S CALLED THE DRESS IN THE
SPECIAL ED TEACHER SHORTAGE.
THE GOVERNOR HAS TO PROPOSALS
IN THIS AREA BUT JUST AS A BIT
OF CONTEXT THERE'S TWO KINDS OF
SPECIAL ED.
EMPLOYEES THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
TALKING ABOUT TEACHERS AND
SPECIALISTS
TO BE A SPECIAL ED TEACHER IN
CALIFORNIA YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
SPECIALIZED CREDENTIAL THERE ARE
A VARIETY OF TYPES OF
CREDENTIALS. YOU ACTUALLY NOT
ONLY NEED A SPECIAL AND
CREDENTIAL YOU NEED THE RIGHT
SPECIALIZED CREDENTIAL TO TEACH
THE SPECIFIC KINDS OF STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES THAT ARE IN
YOUR CLASSROOM.
AND THEN THERE ARE SPECIALISTS
THESE ARE OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPISTS SPEECH THERAPISTS
PSYCHOLOGIST THAT PROVIDE
WRAPAROUND SUPPORT FOR STUDENTS.
PAGE TWO OF THE HANDOUT THERE'S
BEEN LONG STANDING SHORTAGES
BOTH.
IN ALL OF THESE SPECIAL IN
THESE TWO SPECIAL EDUCATION
CATEGORIES IT'S HAPPENED FOR
DECADES IT'S HAPPENED ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
EVEN WITHIN SPECIAL ED THOUGH
THERE ARE MORE ACUTE AREAS SO
WITHIN TEACHERS THOSE TEACHERS
WHO SERVES STUDENTS WITH
MODERATE AND SEVERE DISABILITIES
SUCH THE MOST CRITICAL SHORTAGE
AREA. AND OF SPECIALISTS
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPISTS AND
SPEECH AND LANGUAGE THERAPISTS
ARE THE MOST CUTE.
AREAS AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THESE NUMBERS HERE ON PAGE TWO
FORTY PERCENT OF THE DO TEACHERS
AND A RECENT YARDS AND THAT HAVE
THE RIGHT CREDENTIAL FOR SERVING
STUDENTS WITH MODERATE AND
SEVERE DISABILITIES. ALMOST A
QUARTER OF OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPIST IN AND HAVE THEM WORK
WERE CONTRACTED OUT SO THEY THEY
WERE LICENSE BUT THEY HAD TO BE
CONTRACTED OUT BY A THIRD PARTY
A SCHOOL DISTRICT COULDN'T FIND
SOMEBODY TO HIRE ON STAFF.
SO WE HAD AN ANALYST IN OUR
OFFICE SPANS SEVERAL MONTHS OVER
THE COURSE OF LAST YEAR GOING
OUT AND TALKING WITH SOAP
ADMINISTRATORS AND.
DISTRICT ADMINISTRATORS SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHERS STUDENTS AND
ASKING WHY THE SHORTAGE IT
HAPPENS EVERYWHERE BUT IT
HAPPENS IN CALIFORNIA IS VERY
ACUTE AS HAPPENED FOR DECADES.
IF WE DON'T WANT TO SHORTAGE IN
CALIFORNIA FOR SORT OF ONE OF
LEAD THE WAY TO GET RID OF THIS
IN THE NATION WHAT WHAT IT TAKES
TO LET'S UNDERSTAND THE CAUSES
OF THE SHORTAGE. AND WHAT WE
HEARD MOST FREQUENTLY WAS PAID
THAT SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHERS
HAVE CERTAIN RESPONSIBILITIES
LIKE DEVELOPING IEP IS
COORDINATING ALL THE SPECIALISTS
THAT WORK WITH THE STUDENT. IN
SOME CASES RESPONDING TO
LITIGATION WHEN PARENTS ARE
UPSIDE.
AND IN MOST IT DOWN MOST
DISTRICTS SPECIAL ED TEACHERS
ARE PAID ROUGHLY THE SAME IF NOT
THE SAME.
VERY DIFFERENT THAN OTHER
PROFESSIONS WHERE IN MOST CASES
RESPONSIBILITIES AND
COMPENSATION ARE LINKED.
WE ALSO HEARD THOUGH THAT THERE
ARE FEW STATE LEVEL THINGS THAT
ARE DIRECTLY EITHER CONTRIBUTING
ARE EXACERBATING THE SHORTAGE.
IN CALIFORNIA IT TAKES FIVE
YEARS TO GET BOTH A TEACHING
CREDENTIAL AND A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE MANY OTHER STATES ALLOW
STUDENTS TO DO THIS ON A MORE
EXPEDITED FASHION WHERE THEY GET
THE SPECIAL A CREDENTIAL. AND A
BACHELOR IN EDUCATION AND FOR
FOUR AND A HALF YEARS.
CALIFORNIA ALSO HAS A VERY
NARROW CREDENTIALS SO YOU HAVE
TO THE RATE CREDENTIAL FOR THE
SPECIFIC STUDENTS IN OUR
CLASSROOM.
AND MANY GRADUATE LEVEL
PREPARATION PROGRAMS LIKE AND
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY PROGRAM ARE
IMPACTED SO FAR MORE DEMANDS
THAN FUNDED SLOTS.
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL WE HEARD MORE
ISOLATED STORIES SO IN CERTAIN
DISTRICTS THEIR HR DEPARTMENTS
JUST WEREN'T WORKING AS THEY
SHOULD SO IT WOULD TAKE MAYBE
SIX MONTHS TO MAKE A HIGHER AND
BY THAT TIME ALL THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT HAD THE PROPER CREDENTIAL
HAD BEEN HIRED BY OTHER
DISTRICTS.
AND IN SOME CASES THE ONGOING
SUPPORT TO FOR THAT PARTICULAR
GOD.
SO THE GOVERNOR I'M JUST GOING
TO GO OVER THIS QUICKLY I THINK
FINANCE WILL TALK ABOUT THEM.
AT LENGTH BUT FACTOR OR IN MORE
DETAIL BUT THERE'S TWO PROPOSALS
TOGETHER THEY TOTAL A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS BOTH ONE TIME.
ONE IS FOR TEACHER RESIDENCY AND
ONE IS JUST A DISCRETIONARY
LOCAL GRANT YOU COULD APPLY FOR
THE FIFTY MILLION GET TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER CANDIDATE.
AND BE ABLE TO DO WHAT YOU
WANTED TO DO THROUGH A LOCAL
PLAN.
SO ON PAGE FIVE WE HAVE OUR
REACTION TO THOSE TWO PROPOSALS
WE THINK IT'S GREAT THAT THE
GOVERNOR IS CREATING A
CONVERSATION ABOUT SPECIAL ED
STAFFING SHORTAGES.
I'M IS HELPFUL AYE BUT WE HAVE
CONCERNS WITH BOTH THEY'RE BOTH
ONE TIME BUT THE KINDS OF THINGS
I JUST MENTIONED BY AND LARGE
NOT NOT ALL OF THEM BUT MANY ARE
ONGOING IN NATURE.
DOESN'T ADDRESS COMPENSATION
EVEN THOUGH WE HEARD OVER AND
OVER AGAIN NOTS THE CORE ISSUE.
NEITHER ADDRESSES STATE LEVEL
ISSUES LIKE CREDENTIALING AND
EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS.
NEITHER DRESSES LOOK AT SPECIFIC
LOCAL LEVEL ISSUES THAT
DISTRICTS THOSE DISTRICTS THAT
HAVE HR ISSUES THAT HAVE
PROBLEMS PROVIDING HELPFUL
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT ONGOING
SUPPORT. NEITHER DEALS WITH
IMPACTION UNCERTAIN SPECIALIST
PROGRAMS.
IN ADDITION WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
SPECIFIC PROPOSALS THEY HAVE
UNIQUE PROBLEMS WE WOULD SUGGEST
THE FIRST US ON TEACHER
RESIDENCY IF YOU HAVE A SHORTAGE
IT COULD PRODUCE SLIGHTLY MORE
BETTER TRAINED COULD PRODUCE
BETTER TRAIN TEACHERS BUT NOT
NECESSARILY MORE TEACHERS THEY
MIGHT BE PRODUCED. JUSTIN
ANOTHER AVENUE THROUGH ANOTHER
TEACHER PREPARATION PROGRAM.
IT'S ALSO VERY EXPENSIVE TO
PRODUCE JUST A FEW TEACHERS AND
SOME DISTRICTS RD USED OUR LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA TO
SUPPORT THESE PROGRAMS.
UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THIS
YEAR THERE'S ALSO SUBSTANTIAL
MONEY GOING AND SALAS YOUR FIVE
SUCH THAT IF MORE DISTRICTS
WANTED TO DO IT THEY COULD DO IT
THERE'S ALSO SUBSTANTIAL MONEY
UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL ON
ONE TIME DISCRETIONARY GRANTS IN
HIS IS A ONE TIME DISCUSSION ARE
PROPOSAL'S OF. DISTRICTS WANTED
TO DO MORE RESIDENCY SLOTS FOR
SHORT TERM.
ON A SHORT TERM BASIS THEY COULD
DO THAT.
THEN ON THE LOCAL SOLUTIONS
GRANT THE KINDS OF ISSUES WE
FOUND IN THE FIELD ARE DIFFICULT
ISSUES SUCH THAT IF YOU WERE
GOING TO GIVE ONE TIME MONEY AT
THE STATE LEVEL IT WOULD BE GET
IT WOULD BE FOR DISTRICTS TO DO
THE DIFFICULT THINGS.
BUT UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL THEY CAN DO WHAT THEY
WANNA DO THEY WANNA BE DIRECTED
BY THE STATE TO DO THE DIFFICULT
THINGS.
SO ON PAGE SIX WE SUGGEST TAKING
A DIFFERENT APPROACH REJECTING
THE ONE TIME.
PLANS AND THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
ON THE TABLE AND.
DOING A FEW OTHER THINGS.
THE FIRST IS THAT THE STATE
COULD REPEAL AND STATE LAW RIGHT
NOW IT'S SUCH A DEFAULT SALARY
POLICY IN THE DEFAULT IS THAT
THERE'S A UNIFORM SALARY
SCHEDULE.
AND WITH THE STATE COULD REPEAL
THIS AND JUST BE SILENT ON THE
ISSUE. THIS MEANS THAT DISTRICTS
COULD.
COLLABORATIVELY WORK WITH THE
UNION TO TRY TO EXPLORE MAY BE
CREATIVE ANDOUR ORDINARY WAYS
TO ADDRESS COMPENSATION FOR
SPECIAL ED TEACHERS. THE STATE
JUST WANNA BE CREATING A DEFAULT
TO DO THE OPPOSITE THAT IT WOULD
BE CREATING A LITTLE BIT MORE
ROOM FOR FLEXIBILITY FOR THOSE
DISTRICTS WHO MIGHT WANT TO
ENGAGE IN THOSE KINDS OF
CONVERSATIONS.
WE ALSO RECOMMEND THAT RATHER
THAN HAVING TO SPECIAL ED
CREDENTIALS MILD MODERATE AND
MODERATE SEVERE HAVING ONE. THAT
WOULD TRAIN INDIVIDUALS TO DEAL
WITH A PANOPLY OF SPECIAL A
CHALLENGES THAT MIGHT ARISE IN
THE CLASSROOM RECOGNIZING THAT
ONCE THIS TEACHER GETS ON THE
JOB THEY WILL CONTINUE TO NEED
ONGOING SUPPORT THEY'LL BE
INDIVIDUAL CHILDREN WHERE
THEY'RE GOING TO NEED SOME
ASSISTANCE ON HOW TO HANDLE
THAT.
BUT THAT A PROGRAM COULD HELP
TEACHERS DEAL WITH A RANGE OF
DISABILITIES.
I'M ON PAGE SEVEN WE HAVE A FEW
MORE RECOMMENDATIONS THE STATE
ALSO COULD FACILITATE CREATING
THESE FOR YOUR PROGRAMS WHERE
INDIVIDUALS GET THEIR BACHELORS
OF EDUCATION. AS WELL AS THAT
SPECIAL THATCREDENTIAL IN A
BLENDED FASHION.
THIS IS AN AREA WHERE ONE TIME
MONEY COULD ACTUALLY HAVE LONG
STANDING BENEFIT SO THE STATE
PROVIDES A SMALL AMOUNTS OF
INSIDE OF MONEY FIRST YES YOU
AND OTHER TEACHER PREP PROGRAMS
TO CREATE THE PROGRAMS AND THEN
THEY GO ON EXISTING FOR A LONG
TIME. AND INDIVIDUALS ARE
PRODUCED MARK QUICKLY FOR THE
WORK FORCE.
AND LASTLY FOR THIS.
SPECIALIST PROGRAMS THAT ARE
IMPACTED WE RECOMMEND PROVIDING
SPECIAL ENROLLMENT GROWTH
FUNDING JUST FOR THOSE
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY AND SPEECH
AND LANGUAGE PROGRAMS.
AND IF YOU DON'T FIVE PERCENT
INCREASES IN ENROLLMENT A YEAR
FOR THE NEXT FEW YEARS IT COST.
X. HONORS LET ME FIVE THOUSAND
ROUGHLY TO SUPPORT THAT LEVEL OF
INVOLVEMENT.
TIMES.
AND THAT'S I I'D WITH FEW
DIFFERENT IDEAS THAT YOU MIGHT
WANNA CONSIDER AS YOU THINK
ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
OKAY. THANK YOU.
DO YOU.
GOOD MORNING KIMBERLY LEAHY WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
ONE HUNDRED MILLION ONE TIME
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND FOR TWO NEW TEACHER
WORKFORCE INVESTMENT INITIATIVES
THAT FOCUS ON THE RECRUITMENT
PREPARATION. AND RETENTION OF
SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHERS.
THERE HAS BEEN A PERENNIAL
SHORTAGE IN THE NUMBER OF FULLY
CREDENTIALED SPECIAL EDUCATION
TEACHERS FOR DECADES THIS IS NOT
A NEW ISSUE.
MOST CONCERNING THOUGH THE
NUMBER OF SPECIAL EDUCATION
TEACHERS PROVIDING INSTRUCTION
WITH A SUB STANDARD CREDENTIAL
CONTINUES TO RISE.
RECENT NUMBERS FROM THE
COMMISSION INDICATE THAT MORE
THAN HALF OF NEW SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHERS CREDENTIALED
IN THE LAST YEAR. RANJHA
PREPARED AND ARE WORKING ON
TEMPORARY PERMITS OR WAIVERS.
AND RESPONSE TO THIS NEED. AND
BECAUSE TWO THIRDS OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED
AS HAVING POOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
PERFORMANCE
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
PROVIDES FIFTY MILLION ONE TIME
PROPOSITION NINE NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND FOR THE TEACHER
RESIDENTS TO GRANT PROGRAM.
TO PROVIDE ONE TIME COMPETITIVE
GRANTS TO LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES TO DEVELOP NEW OR
EXPAND EXISTING TEACHER
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS.
RESIDENCIES WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
RECRUIT AND SUPPORT THE
PREPARATION OF NEW SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHERS.
RESEARCH SUGGESTS THAT RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS RESULT IN HIGHER
RETENTION RATES OF NEWLY
CREDENTIALED TEACHERS AT FIVE
YEARS THAN TRADITIONAL PATHWAYS.
THE GRANT PROGRAM WOULD BE
ADMINISTERED BY THE COMMISSION
THE FUNDS WOULD BE AVAILABLE FOR
FIVE YEARS. ELEAZAR RECEIVE A
GRANT AWARD WOULD RECEIVE UP TO
TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
PARTICIPATING TEACHER CANDIDATE
I WOULD NEED TO PROVIDE A LOCAL
GRANT FOR A LOCAL MATCH.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
PROVIDES FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
ONE TIME PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND TO PROVIDE
COMPETITIVE GRANTS TO LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES.
TO DEVELOPMENT EMPLOYMENT.
NEW OR EXPAND EXISTING.
LOCALLY IDENTIFIED
TRANSFORMATIONAL SOLUTIONS THAT
ADDRESS A LOCAL NEED FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHERS.
THE FOCUS WILL BE ON GENERATING
NEWLY CREDENTIALED SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHERS.
THE GRANT WOULD BE ADMINISTERED
BY THE COMMISSION THE FUNDS
WOULD BE AVAILABLE FOR UP TO
FIVE YEARS. ELEAZAR RECEIVE A
GRANT WOULD BE REQUIRED RECEIVE
UP TO TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER PARTICIPATING TEACHER
CANDIDATE I WOULD NEED TO
PROVIDE A LOCAL MATCH.
THESE FUNDS COULD BE USED FOR
EXAMPLE ON PROGRAMS SUCH AS GROW
YOUR OWN PROGRAMS.
ONE I DID THAT IN NATIONALLY IS
BEING.
IMPLEMENTED AND HEARING
CALIFORNIA. IS BY.
I BELIEVE THERE'S ONE DISTRICT
THAT I'VE HEARD OF THAT IS DOING
THIS A GROW YOUR OWN PROGRAM
WHERE THEY'RE RECRUITING THEIR
HIGH SCHOOL. GRADUATES TO ENTER
INTO OF A TEACHER PREP OR AT A
FOUR YEAR DEGREE AND THEN A
TEACHER PREP PROGRAM AND THEN
RETURN TO THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
WHERE THEY JUST GRADUATED FROM
FOUR YEARS EARLIER. AND I TEACH
AT THAT DISTRICT PLEASE CARP
PEOPLE WHO ARE ENGAGED IN THEIR
COMMUNITY AND ARE LIKELY TO STAY
ON LONGER AND HAVE MORE
COMMITMENT AND PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN RECRUITED FROM OUT OF STATE
OR FROM OTHER REGIONS.
AND.
BECAUSE WE HAVE JUST RECENTLY
INVESTED.
SPOKE QUITE A BIT OF A.
TATE FUNDING INTO CREATING THE
FOUR YEAR A TEACHER PREPARATION
INTEGRATED PROGRAMS THESE NEW
CANDIDATES COULD ACTUALLY
COMPLETE THEIR. OF PREPARATION
TO TEACH IN FOUR YEARS.
I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
NOT YET.
BERMAN OF EDUCATION.
BUT BROWN ON BEHALF OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TOM TRUCKS AT ALL
JUST AT THAT A COUPLE OF OF
COMMENTS TO THAT WHICH IS THAT
WE WE DO STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL. TO
PROVIDE THE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR I RECRUITING AND
RETAINING SPECIAL EDUCATION
TEACHERS WHAT CERTAINLY ISN'T
GOING TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM WE DO
SO WE DO REALIZE. FUND THAT.
PROVIDING THIS IMMEDIATE IN AND
JACKSON AND THE PIPELINE IS
REALLY IMPORTANT AND SO WE'VE
ALSO BEEN WORKING WITH THE
COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING AND RE ENVISIONING
SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHER
CREDENTIALS. AND AS SUCH WERE
SUPPORTIVE OF FUNDING TO ENSURE
SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHERS HAVE
THE NECESSARY SUPPORTS IN THEM
MENTORSHIPS TO ENSURE THE HIGH
QUALITY PROVISIONS OF SPECIAL
EDUCATION AND RELATED SERVICES
SO WE FULLY SUPPORT THAT
GOVERNOR'S. UP PROPOSAL I'M
AGAINST PROVIDE A QUICK UPDATE
ON THE A FVE MILLION DOLLARS
THAT WAS PROVIDED IN IN THE
CURRENT YEAR BUDGET FOR. US.
HELP ADDRESS THE BILINGUAL
TEACHER SHORTAGES WELLS'S WE
LOOK AT THESE PROGRAMS PROVIDING
SUPPORT WHERE WE DO HAVE AREAS
FUND SO THAT THE I'M A GRANT
AWARDS WE HAD FIFTEEN
APPLICATIONS FOR THOSE OF FUNDS.
AND WE AWARDED AND SIX HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
EIGHT COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AROUND THE STE AT AROUND THE
STATE. WITH THE INTENT AROUND
HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT WE
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF BILINGUAL
TEACHERS PROVIDE SUPPORT AND
MEMBERSHIP AND MENTORSHIP FOR A
BILINGUAL TEACHERS. AND ALSO
INCREASE THE PIPELINE AND SO
WHERE THOSE.
AT EIGHT AGENCIES HAVE UNTIL AT
JUNE THIRTIETH OF TWENTY TWENTY
TO SPEND THOSE FUNDS AND
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS
OKAY THANK YOU I SKIPPED USE AYE
THAT'S OKAY. NOT FROM. US EIGHTY
PERCENT OF THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
IN THE STATE A REPORTING
SHORTAGES ACROSS THE BOARD.
THE MOST CHRONIC AREAS CONTINUE
TO BE STEM IN SPECIAL EDUCATION.
OF THE LARGEST GROWING SECTION
OF OUR SECTOR OF CREDENTIALS ARE
PERMITS THAT WERE ISSUE IN OUR
TROOPS ARE EMERGENCY PERMITS AND
WE ISSUED AS MANY AS TWELVE
THOUSAND OF THEM LAST YEAR.
THERE WERE ON TRACK THIS YEAR TO
MEET THAT NUMBER IF NOT
EXCEEDED.
OF SUPPLY IS NOT KEEPING PACE
WITH DEMAND THAT'S NOT A NEW
STORY HERE IN THE STABLE AT THIS
TABLE.
WE HAVE BEEN PLEASED THAT THE
COMMISSION TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
ISSUANCE OF SEVENTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN GRANT FUNDS OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS. FIVE MILLION
TO READ AND I READ STATE DATA
CENTER FOR TEACHING CAREERS THAT
HAS NOW GONE ONLINE THEY'RE
DOING JOB FAIRS ARE DOING PSAS
THEY ARE. A FUNCTIONING FULLY
FUNCTIONING NOW AT A FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT TEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO BUILD
UNDERGRADUATE TEACHER
PREPARATION PROGRAMS. FORTY ONE
INSTITUTIONS PARTICIPATED IN
THOSE GRANDSON ARE STARTING
PROGRAMS THIS FALL TWENTY ONE OF
THOSE ARE IN SPECIAL EDUCATION.
EIGHTEEN OF THE GRANTEES ARE IN
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
AND THERE ARE WE'RE GETTING
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHETHER THERE
MIGHT BE OPPORTUNITY FOR FUTURE
DEVELOPMENT OF ADDITIONAL
PROGRAMS AT THE UNDERGRADUATE
LEVEL SO THAT'S AN IDEA THAT HAS
TAKEN SOME ROUTE AND WE'RE
EXCITED TO SEE WHAT IT WILL
PRODUCE. THE CLASSIFIED A GRANT
PROGRAM HAS ALSO BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL WE'VE ISSUED TWO
ROUNDS OF GRANTS TO SUPPORT DID
A TWENTY TWO HUNDRED.
CANDIDATES IN THAT PROGRAM IN
THE LAST ROUND THAT WE JUST RAN
WE HAD PROBABLY TWO TO THREE
TIMES THE NUMBER OF APPLICATIONS
AS COULD BE FUNDED. ALSO SOME
SOME SIGNIFICANT OUR RESOURCES
HAVE BEEN INVESTED WE'RE HOPING
THAT ALL OF THEM TOGETHER WILL
PRODUCE SOMEWHERE BETWEEN FOUR
AND FIVE THOUSAND TEACHERS OVER
THE NEXT THREE YEARS.
THE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
PROPOSAL TO REALLY FOCUS IN ON
SPECIAL EDUCATION WE BELIEVE IS
AN ESSENTIAL NEXT STEP.
THE FIFTY MILLION FOCUSED ON
TEACHER RESIDENCIES WILL BUILD
INFRASTRUCTURE AND BUILD
CAPACITY FOR LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. IN TERMS OF THE
MENTOR TEACHERS THAT THEY BRING
ON BOARD TO SUPPORT SPECIAL ED
TEACHERS IN TRAINING AND IN
TERMS OF THE NEW TEACHERS THAT
THEY BRING IN. THAT PROGRAM.
IN AND OF ITSELF THAT FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR PROGRAM COULD
RESULT IN TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
TEACHERS OVER THE NEXT THREE TO
FIVE YEARS.
THE LOCAL ASSISTANCE OUR LOCAL
SOLUTIONS GRANT ALSO WHAT WE
FOUND FROM DISTRICTS WHEN HE RAN
THE CAL ED OF GRANT PROGRAM WITH
THE TULARE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION THAT WAS A NINE
BILLION DOLLAR PROGRAM. AGAIN.
THE NEED FOR TEACHER
DEVELOPMENT A TEACHER
RECRUITMENT FAR EXCEEDED THE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE IN THAT
CROWD PROGRAM BUT THE KINDS OF
THINGS THEY ASK FOR RAN. ACROSS
A RANGE OF INCENTIVES FROM LOAN
FORGIVENESS WHICH IS ONE OF THE
PRIMARY THINGS WE HEAR FROM
TEACHERS. OF THAT DISCOURAGES
THEM OR FOR.
AT THAT THEY'RE GONNA WALK AWAY
WITH A COMPARED TO THE SALARY
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO EARN AND
THAT'S NOT DID DID DID DOESN'T
APPEAL TO. A WIDE SWATH OF OF
POTENTIAL CANDIDATES SO
PROVIDING LOCAL SOLUTIONS OF THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR AN ALLEY A TO
SAY WELL WE WILL FORGIVE YOUR
LOUNGE ROOM REPAY YOUR LOANS IF
YOU COME TO WORK FOR US. OR A
HIRING INCENTIVE FOR A HOUSING
INCENTIVE OR SOME OTHER THING
THAT IS THE PARTICULAR ISSUE
THAT THEY THINK WILL BRING THE
SPECIAL EDUCATORS INTO THEIR
DISTRICT. BASED ON LOCAL LEADS
THAT'S THE THAT DRIVING THEME OF
THE LOCAL SOLUTIONS GRANT WE
THINK BOTH OF THESE THINGS ARE
VERY TIMELY FOR THE REASONS
THAT.
FINANCES HAS MENTIONED TO YOU
FINALLY WITH RESPECT TO SPECIAL
EDUCATION IN CHANGES IN BACK
CREDENTIALING WE HAVE OVERHAULED
THAT CREDENTIAL WE SPENT THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS WORKING WITH
THE STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. A RE
CONCEPTUALIZING.
WHAT WE NEED TO DO IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION SOUP TO NUTS?
WHAT WE'VE DONE AT THE
COMMISSION TABLE IS VERY
RECENTLY RESTRUCTURED THAT
CREDENTIAL IN WAYS THAT WE THINK
YOU'RE GOING TO BE POWERFULLY?
?
IMPORTANT FOR THE QUALITY OF
THAT WORKFORCE MOVING FORWARD WE
CONSIDERED THE COMMISSION
CONSIDERED WHETHER WE SHOULD
HAVE ONE SINGLE SPECIAL
EDUCATION CREDENTIAL OR CONTINUE
TO HAVE AREAS OF SPECIALIZATION
AND WE'VE VETTED THAT IDEA
WIDELY. WITH TEACHERS WITH
ADMINISTRATORS WITH EMPLOYERS
ARE AND WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT
THERE'S A SMALL MINORITY WHO
THINK A SINGLE CREDENTIAL WOULD
BE WOULD MAKE FOR UTILITY HITTER
THAT YOU COULD PLACE ANYWHERE.
BUT THE LARGER CONCERN IN THE
REASON THE COMMISSION MAINTAINED
TWO DISTINCT.
ACTUALLY FIVE DISTINCT BUT
THREE OF THEM ARE AREAS OF
SPECIALIZATION IN TWO OR FOR THE
MORE GENERAL POPULATION OF
SPECIAL EDUCATION STUDENTS. IS
THAT THEY ARE THEY ARE VERY
DIFFERENT.
KINDS OF NEEDS THAT NEED TO BE
MET AND IF WE PUT ALL OF THAT
TOGETHER IN ONE SINGLE PROGRAM
WE WILL LENGTHEN THE TIME THAT
IT TAKES TO GET CREDENTIALS IN
THIS AREA. AND WE MAY LIMIT THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO ARE WILLING
TO COME IN AND DO IT SO THE NEW
STRUCTURE MAINTAINS A MILD TO
MODERATE SUPPORT NEEDS
CREDENTIAL AND A SIGNIFICANT
SUPPORT NEEDS CREDENTIAL. BUT
ONE OF THE COMMISSION'S
INTENTIONS HERE'S TO MAKE
BRIDGING BETWEEN THESE
CREDENTIAL AREAS READILY
AVAILABLE AND ACCESSIBLE FOR
CANDIDATES WOULD LIKE TO ADD.
THAT THE SECOND CREDENTIAL SO WE
ARE DOING OF WHAT WE THINK THE
FIELD NEEDS US TO DO TO GET THE
CREDENTIAL IN ORDER. SO THAT WE
HAVE TEACHERS WHO ARE WELL
PREPARED TO WORK WITH THAT
WITHOUT POPULATION.
IN THE IN THE SCHOOLS SO I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE.
OKAY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR IT LAYING IT OUT
PRESS THIS CONTINUES TO BE.
A THORNY ISSUE THAT WE NEED TO
ADDRESS CAN YOU SAY THE NUMBER I
KNOW YOU SAID I MEAN.
INDIVIDUALS ARE APPLYING EVERY
YEAR FOR EMERGENCY BUT WHAT'S
THE NUMBER OF CURRENT.
PEOPLE WHO ARE TEACHING WITH
EMERGENCY CREDENTIAL
SO THIS YEAR I AM NOT I DON'T
HAVE THE DATA FOR THE EIGHTEEN
THE SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN YEAR THAT
WE'RE IN RIGHT NOW. BUT I CAN
TELL YOU THAT WE HAD TWELVE
THOUSAND LAST YEAR AND SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN APPLY THAT WORD THAT
WILL THEY LET'S THEY HAVE WE
PRESUME THEY'RE TEACHING ONCE I
HAVE IT IT'S WHEN YOUR DOCUMENT.
AND THAT'S THAT'S GROWING THAT
DOES. MORE THAN THE LIKE SIX
THOUSANDS LESS.
AND THAT WOULD BE IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION SO LAST YEAR THAT THE
WHOLE POPULATION OF.
YOU SPECIAL WELL I THINK THERE
MIGHT INCLUDE INTERNS AS WELL AS
OF THE EMERGENCY PERMITS AND AND
WAIVERS ON BUT TAKEN TOGETHER
THOSE ARE. THAT'S THE POPULATION
THAT IS EITHER IN TRAINING OR
RECEIVING SUPPORT WHILE THEY ARE
PROVIDING TEACHING SERVICES BUT
NOT TO GET IN TRAINING.
OKAY.
IF I MIGHT JUST LAND JUST A
SECOND OF HISTORICAL CONTEXT AND
BECAUSE MANY STATE INITIATIVES
WERE MENTIONED THE STATE HAS
TRIED LOTS OF THINGS ON THE
MARGIN FOR A LONG TIME YET SO
THEY'VE TRIED. COVERING THE COST
OF THE TRAINING INITIALLY
WHETHER IT THROUGH THE THROUGH
EIGHT OR LOAN FORGIVENESS
THEY'VE TRIED RECRUITMENT
CENTERS THEY'VE TRIED
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS. MANY THINGS AND I
THINK WHAT WE'RE HEARING THIS
YEAR IS A LOT OF THE SAME THINGS
ON A ONE TIME BASIS.
SO.
EAT IT.
YOU CAN DO THAT BUT IF IT'S NOT
GOING TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM REYES
SO I THINK IF THE STATE WANTS TO
BE FIVE YEARS DOWN THE ROAD AND
BE IN A FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT
POSITION AND HOUSE TO THINK
ABOUT FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT
WAY TO GO ABOUT DEALING WITH THE
ISSUE.
OKAY. AND THEN AS FAR AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I KNOW THE
BUDGET IS WHAT IS TODAY BUT IT
IF THERE WAS.
AN OPPORTUNITY. IN THAT MAY
REVISION ARE THERE OTHER ISSUES
THAT YOU THINK WARRANT
INVESTMENT TO ROUTE YOU FOCUS ON
THE IN INCREASING THAT.
ALLOCATION FOR THE EXISTING ONES
I KNOW THE PRIOR YEARS WE'VE
WE'VE LOOKED AT OTHER IDEAS.
DO YOU HAVE ANY.
YOU MEAN SOMETHING NEW FOR MAY
REVISIONS CRORES OKAY WELL FOR.
I I CAN'T SPEAK TO THE MAY
REVISION AT THIS TIME HOWEVER.
THE PROPOSAL THAT WE HAVE
BEFORE US TODAY THESE TWO.
.
TWO ALLOTMENTS FOR TEACHER
INVESTMENTS I'M WE STILL WOULD
WANT TO FOCUS ON SPECIAL
EDUCATION FOR THOSE TWO
INVESTMENTS BUT I GUESS IF THERE
WAS MORE IF THERE'S ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY TO INVEST MORE IN
THE. WORKFORCE ISSUES WOULD
WOULD YOU PUT MORE MONEY FOR IT
SPECIAL ADD OR.
OR MORE.
OR BROUGHT IT MAYBE HAVE THE
RESIDENCY OPEN UP FOR IT YOU
KNOW WE DID THE CLASSIFIED
PROGRAM LAST YEAR'S FINALLY GLAD
THERE'S. AS THE LA I JUST
MENTION THERE'S THERE OTHER
IDEAS WE'VE BEEN. DABBLING IN.
AND I WOULD I WOULD I WOULD
BASICALLY HAVE TO TAKE THESE
IDEAS BACK TO MANAGEMENT AND
OKAY WHO WE COULD CONSIDER THEM.
FAIR ENOUGH THANK YOU.
MR DOT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
JUST A COMMENT FOR SO I THINK
FIVE CREDENTIALS JUST TO ME
SEEMS LIKE AN AWFUL LOT SEEM
LIKE AN AWFUL LOT.
BUT.
I A I GET YOUR PERSPECTIVE I
JUST THINK FIVE SEEMS LIKE AN
AWFUL LOT. BUT WITH REGARD TO
THE MONEY JUST FOR SPECIAL ED I
THE PROBLEM.
THAT THEY'RE TRYING TO DRESS AS
A UNIQUE WE HAVE A TEACHER
CRISIS THAT SPREADS BEYOND.
SPECIAL EDUCATION SO I THINK WE
NEED TO THINK ABOUT THAT GOING
MUCH BROADER THAN JUST SPECIAL
EDUCATION.
WE KNOW THAT SPECIAL EDUCATION
ASSIST SITUATION HAS BEEN
PERSISTENT FOR SURE. BUT AGAIN
I%
IN THE THEY THE CHALLENGES MUCH
BROADER AND GROWING DAILY. AND
MAYBE ONE OF YOU CAN RESPOND AS
IT MIGHT OF BEEN ANSWERED
ALREADY. WITH REGARD TO
SPECIALIST THE SPECIAL EDUCATION
A CREDENTIAL.
THE.
COULDN'T A ANY. A COLLEGE NOW
OFFER A SPECIAL EDUCATION
DEGREE.
SO THEY COULD GET. YOU KNOW THEY
COULD GET THAT CREDENTIAL HIM IN
A MORE EXPEDITED FASHION THEY
COULD HAVE IN THE PAST WHERE
THEY HAD A STANDALONE EXPERIENCE
THE FOR YOUR DEGREE. AND THEN
HAD TO GO TO WORK ON THE. ON THE
ON THE CREDENTIAL LATER IS THERE
ANY COLLEGES THAT ARE BLENDING
THESE THAT THAT. YOU CAN GET IT
DONE ENOUGH FOR YOUR MODEL YES
IN POINT OF FACT THE INTEGRATED
GRANT PROGRAM BECAUSE THE
SUPPORT OF JUST EXACTLY THAT THE
COMPLETION OF A CREDENTIAL IN A
DEGREE WITHIN FOUR YEARS. TWENTY
ONE INSTITUTIONS HAVE BUILT
THOSE PROGRAMS IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION THEIR OPENING IN THIS
FALL.
SO THEY HAVE A SPECIAL EDUCATION
DEGREE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEIR DEGREES
WILL BE AND THEY COULD TO IT
THAT THEY HAD.
DISCRETION AROUND THAT I AND I
KNOW THAT THERE WAS RECENT
LEGISLATION A COUPLE YEARS AGO
TO ALLOW THE EDUCATION MAJOR
AGAIN FOR LAST YEAR AND LIKE
THOSE LAST JUST LAST YEAR. UP I
DON'T GROUP I DON'T RECALL
WHETHER THAT ENCOMPASS SPECIAL
EDUCATION OR NOT AND I DON'T I
DON'T THINK I'LL I THOUGHT IT
WAS MY BILL AND I DON'T RECALL
I.
DON'T REMEMBER UT I ALL FIND
OUT AND GET BACK TO YOU ON THAT
LET YOU KNOW I NEED TO FIND THAT
OUT YEAH.
THERE MAY BE SOMEONE BUT IT
JUST SEEMS TO ME THAT MAYBE WE
NEED TO INCENTIVIZE.
IT WAS RATHER WE NEED TO DO
THINGS ALL DIFFERENTLY.
I BECAUSE THIS PROBLEM THAT IS
PERSISTENT AND I GREW THAT
MAYBE.
FROM SACRAMENTO LEVEL WE NEED TO
INCENTIVIZE RCS YEARS RIGHT
BECAUSE THOSE OWNS THOSE THE
WORKHORSE OF THE TEACHER
CREDENTIALING SYSTEM AYE AYE
EVEN AYE YAY WONDER WHY YOU SEE
OFFERS A TEACHING CREDENTIAL
QUITE FRANKLY BECAUSE I JUST
DON'T THINK IT'S.
I THINK IT ALSO REFOCUSED AND
HOUSED IN THE CSU OR HAVE ONE
PLACE YOU KNOW
WITH THE EXPERTISE
YOU KNOW ONE ONE STOP SHOP IF
YOU WILL. BUT I WONDER IF
THERE'S SOMETHING WE SHOULD DO
FROM AND IF SOMEONE STICK.
YEAH COMING ON THE SOMETHING WE
SHOULD HAVE A SACRAMENTO OF TO
INCENTIVIZE.
OF THE CSU SYSTEM TO CREATE SUCH
A PROGRAM FIRST WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE IT'S LEGAL. SECOND WE NEED
TO SEE HOW WE GET IT DUCTS OF
ANYONE WANTS TO COMMENT ON WE
HAVE BEEN TRYING TO TRACK JUST
THE RECENT DEVELOPMENTS THE
LEGISLATION TO CREATE INTEGRATED
PROGRAMS BUT WHAT WE'VE HEARD
WHEN WE'VE HOUSES THAT.
INTEGRATED SORT OF TOOK OFF FOUR
YEAR BACHELOR'S PROGRAM AND TOP
DON WHO ONE YOU'RE PREGNANT
WE ASK THE COMPANY CREDITS DO
YOU NEED. TO GO THROUGH IT
SOUNDS LIKE THE OLD CREDITS IT
SOUNDS LIKE YOU CAN'T REASONABLY
DO THAT I'M FOR YEARS AND IT'S
STILL I THINK LIMITED TELAMON
TREE SCHOOLS.
SO IT AND MOST VIRTUALLY ALL
OTHER STATES ALLOW STUDENTS TO
GO THROUGH THIS IN A MUCH MORE
SEAMLESSLY WAY MUCH MORE QUICKLY
EFFECTIVELY GETTING SPECIAL AT
WORK SPECIAL A TEACHER TRAINING
IN THE SPECIAL ED CREDENTIAL
SIMULTANEOUSLY. IN BITS YOU TALK
ABOUT THE GRINCH ON TALK ABOUT
AGREE WHAT IF YOU HAD.
ESPECIALLY DEGREE.
RIGHT THAT'S WHY I THINK WE WERE
GOING SO THE ANSWER IS NO
SPECIAL EDUCATION WAS NOT
INCLUDED IN THAT BILL. WILL
BELIEVE THAT SOMETHING TO GO
BACK AND CLEAN UP.
POTENTIALLY SOME WILL HAVE A
CONVERSATION THANK YOU.
BUT I'D COULD I JUST ANSWER ONE
OF THE QUESTION TERMS OF THE
FIVE CREDENTIALS THREE OF THEM
ARE FOR LOW INCIDENCE SO ONE OF
THE SPECIAL AYE CREDENTIALS FOR
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION.
A SECOND IS FOR VISUALLY
IMPAIRED STUDENTS A THIRTIES FOR
DEAF AND HARD OF HEARING. THOSE
THREE CREDENTIALS ARE SO
SPECIALIZED THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
MAINTAIN THE OTHER TWO HAVE BEEN
THAT'S A REDUCTION FROM.
WE ELIMINATED TO AND
CONSOLIDATED THEM INTO JUST TO
WE USED TO HAVE FOR ADDITIONAL
AND THERE WERE SEVEN OTHER FIVE
IN ON IT AND THOSE TWO ONE IS
FOCUSED ON SUPPORTING STUDENTS
WITH MILD TO MODERATE SPORT
NEEDS. IS COULD BE STUDENTS WITH
AUTISM THESE COULD BE STUDENTS
WITH BEHAVIORAL ISSUES THAT
COULD BE SO IT'S THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION. OF THAT IS CONSIDERED
MILD TO MODERATE THIS THE OTHER
BRANCH DEAD THE COMMISSION
DECIDED TO MAINTAIN WAS FOCUSED
ON SIGNIFICANT.
MORE SIGNIFICANT SUPPORT NEEDS
THAT COULD INVOLVE.
PARAPLEGIC STUDENTS STUDENTS
WHO HAVE PHYSICAL HANDICAPS THAT
INTERFERE WITH THEIR LEARNING IN
THEIR TEACHERS NEED TO KNOW
DIFFERENT THINGS TO HELP THEM
ACCESS LEARNING SO THE
COMMISSION REALLY JUST
DETERMINED. THAT IN ORDER TO
HAVE TEACHERS WHO WERE WELL
PREPARED FOR THE POPULATION OF
STUDENTS WE NEEDED TO MAINTAIN
THESE DISTINCTIONS. ARE AND NOT
TRY AND BLEND IT ALL INTO ONE
LONGER. A COMPREHENSIVE PROGRAM
RIGHT SO I THESE FIVE
CREDENTIALS ARE THEY.
SILOS.
OR IS IT YOU GET YOUR SPECIAL ED
CREDENTIAL THAT COVERS GENERAL
SPECIAL AND EVERYONE A LABEL
THAT. AND THEN YOU GET AN
AUTHORIZATION.
TWO TO TO TO TO TO WORKING CLASS
OR TOWARD CHILDREN MIGHT HAVE
UNIQUE NEEDS I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE QUESTION BECAUSE THE AT THE
HEART AND SOUL OF THE CHANGE
WE'VE MADE IN THE SPECIAL A
CREDENTIAL. IS TO REMOVE IT FROM
ITS SILO.
TO CREATE A COMMON CORE
PREPARATION THAT ALL GEN ED AND
ALL SPECIALIST TEACHERS COMPLETE
TOGETHER.
A WHERE THEY LEARN ABOUT
TEACHING AND LEARNING IN LEANING
TO DIE LEARNING TO TEACH A
DIVERSE THE FULL DIVERSE.
STUDENT POPULATION THAT WE HAVE
AND THEN SPECIALIZATIONS ARE
ADDED ON THAT COMMON CENTRAL
CORE OF PREPARATION OR TRUNK
PREPARATION I HAVE A PICTURE OF
A TRIO OF HAPPY THAT WE SHARE
WITH YOU IT'S BEEN A METAPHOR
FOR IT. BUT THAT COMMON TRUNK IS
THAT THAT'S THE NEW CHANGE IN
THAT WHAT'S PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT ABOUT THAT IS THAT IS
THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION HAS BEEN FUNDED AND IS
EXPANDING MULTI TIERED SYSTEMS
OF SUPPORT. AS A FRAMEWORK FOR
DELIVERY OF STUDENT I SERVICES
TO ALL STUDENTS THIS MODEL
MATCHES THAT FRAME FOR HOW WE
THINK ABOUT TEACHING OUR
STUDENTS WERE ALL STUDENTS ARE
JANET STUDENTS FIRST. AND WHEN
THEY NEED AN INTERVENTION THEY
HAVE SOMEONE WITH THE TRAINING
TO PROVIDE THAT INTERVENTION BUT
THEY ARE SILENT THAT I THINK IS
THE VISION OF ANTI SS BUT
RECOGNIZING THAT MTS THIS IS LOW
LIVES IN A STATE WHERE WE STILL
HAVE A WIDER WAY. OF WAYS IN
WHICH WE SERVE STUDENTS WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS SOMETIMES IN A
SILO ROAD. CLASSROOMS SOMETIMES
IN INTEGRATED CLASSROOMS FULLY I
INCLUDED ON BUT THE CREDENTIAL
IS INTENDED TO SERVE THAT
MULTIPLICITY OF WAYS WE DELIVER
SERVICES BUT REALLY DRIVE TO
WORK THIS CALM AND.
UNDERSTANDING THAT ALL STUDENTS
ARE ALL BELONG TO ALL TEACHERS
SO QUICKLY THEY LET ME HELP ME
UNDERSTAND THAT IS SO DO I GET A
CREDENTIAL.
TO WORK WITH CHILDREN WHO ARE
VISUALLY IMPAIRED ESPECIALLY
CREDENTIAL OR CHILDREN ARE
VISUALLY IMPAIRED OR DOING
ESPECIALLY CREDENTIAL THEN I GET
AN AUTHORIZATION.
TO WORK WITH CHILDREN OR
VISUALLY IMPAIRED.
SO THE CREDENTIAL ITSELF WOULD
CARRY THAT AUTHORIZATION SO IT'S
NOT DO ONE AND THEN DO THE
OTHER.
SO ESSENTIALLY WHAT WE VIEW WHAT
WE VISUALIZE FOR THE AYE
TEACHERS WHO WILL TEACH VISUALLY
IMPAIRED STUDENTS SAID THEY
ENGAGE IN THAT COMMON TRUCK
PREPARATION WITH GEN ED AND ALL
OTHER SPECIAL ED TEACHERS.
ARE AND THEN THEY BEGIN TO
SPECIALIZE ON WHAT ARE THE
PARTICULAR NEEDS THAT VISUALLY
IMPAIRED STUDENTS NEED AND HOW
DO YOU DELIVER THOSE.
AND THEY WILL LEARN ONE
CREDENTIAL THAT AUTHORIZATION
WILL BE WITHIN IT IF THEY WANT
TO ADD DEAF AND HARD OF HEARING
THEY DON'T HAVE TO GO BACK TO
THE BEGINNING TO COMPLETE THE
SAME TRUNK AGAIN. THEY HAVE TO
AT THE SPECIALIZED KNOWLEDGE TO
ADD AN AUTHORIZATION A DEAF AND
HARD HEARING THEY WANT TO ADD.
ANY OTHER IT WE'RE LOOKING AT
HAVING MORE FOCUSED BRIDGES AND
ELIMINATING DUPLICATION.
WHERE WHERE A CANDIDATE WHO
WANTED TO ADD SOMETHING WOULD
HAVE TO START OVER AND DO A
WHOLE CONFERENCE PROGRAM
SINCE UP I'M STILL NOT? SO TO IF
I IF I GET A SPECIAL EDUCATION
CREDENTIAL.
FOR IS A SPECIAL EDUCATION
CREDENTIAL FOR THE VISUALLY
IMPAIRED OR AS A SPECIAL
EDUCATION CREDENTIAL WHAT I'D BE
ABLE TO TO.
TO WORK IN A STE IN A.
SPECIAL EDUCATION CLASSROOM
SETTING WHERE THERE MIGHT NOT BE
STUDENTS WHO ARE VISUALLY
IMPAIRED TO HAVE THAT BASE.
NO.
YEAH THAT BASS OCCURS I EACH
EACH OF THE BRANCHES WILL HAVE A
BASE THAT IS PART OF THEIR AREA
OF SPECIALIZATION SO IF YOU GO
FOR INTERNATIONAL ENGLISH AT
SEATTLE'S I'M SORRY.
IS YOUR JOB.
YOU KNOW WE'VE BEEN HAVING THIS
DISCUSSION FOR SOME LONG AND I
WAS.
LISTENING VERY INTENTLY.
BUT I'M CONCERNED ONE.
STATEMENTS ARE BEING MADE BY
THE DEPARTMENT EDUCATION SAYS.
THIS IS NOT GOING TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM.
AND WE'RE SPENDING A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS SHARE.
SO.
BUT WE'RE NOT SOLVING THE
PROBLEM WE IN THE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS.
YOU KNOW THAT DOESN'T GIVE ME A
LOT OF COMFORT.
NOW I KNOW BECAUSE I ATTENDED A
FEW OF THEM.
WE HAD THE STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS
AROUND THE STATE ON ON THIS
ISSUE.
.
SO I GUESS FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION. THE STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS THAT WE CONDUCTED.
ARE THEY BEING CONSIDERED IN AND
TRYING TO SOLVE.
EFFORT AND ON BEHALF OF.
WRITTEN IT TOOK TO DO THINGS SO
WHEN IT WE DO THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT START TO SOLVING THE
PROBLEM WE THINK THERE ARE OTHER
THINGS. THAT WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
TIME SO IT'S IN ITS INITIAL
INVESTMENTS WE ALSO NEED TO LOOK
AT MENTORSHIPS COMMUNITIES OF
PRACTICE OTHER WAYS TO SUPPORT
TEACHERS TO STAY AND SO. I WENT
THAT WE THINK IT'S A GOOD START
TO GETTING TO THE PROBLEM.
AND THEN TAKE IT I WOULD
DEFERRED TO TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ON THE STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS SINCE THEY WERE THE
ONES THAT. I'M AT THOSE
MEETINGS.
BUT THOSE AYE INPUT SESSIONS.
WELL THE PART OF FINANCE TALKED
EARLIER SAID THAT SHE HAD GONE
BACK SO OVER TO THE DOCTOR THEN.
.
DOCTOR SANDY THE.
YOU.
YOU OUTLINED HIS TRUNK CONCEPT
BUREAU MULTI TIERED SUPPORT
SYSTEM.
VERY WELL.
DOES THEM HUNDRED MILLION WE'RE
PUTTING IN SUPPORT THAT NEW
VISION YOU HAVE YES
IT ABSOLUTELY DOES.
ABSOLUTELY SO WE'VE CHANGED THE
CREDENTIAL WHERE ADOPTING NEW
STANDARDS WE EXPECT AS EARLY AS
A FEW WEEKS FROM NOW OF FOR THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION CREDENTIAL. IF
THE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
ARRIVES IN THE BUDGET JULY ONE
WILL HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
STIMULATE THE DEVELOPMENT OF
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS.
THAT MEET THIS NEW.
CREDENTIALS STRUCTURE
AT THE SAME TIME AS WE ARE
WORKING WITH ALL OF THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION PROGRAMS IN THE STATE
TO UPDATE TO NEW STANDARDS. THIS
WILL BE A STIMULUS IT'LL BE.
AN INCENTIVE REALLY IF YOU WILL
FOR LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES
THIS A SCHOOL DISTRICT BASED
FUNDING AND THE DISTRICT WILL BE
THE HOME OF THESE RESIDENCIES.
SO THE OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD
THEIR CAPACITY TO TRAIN THEIR
OWN TEACHERS.
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH VOTE WITH A
TEACHER EDUCATION PROGRAM IS
THAT'S A SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT
HERE I TERMS OF JUST BUILDING
THE CAPACITY OF THE SYSTEM.
AT AND WE'RE VERY EXCITED TO
BUILD THAT AND IT WILL BE WE SEE
THESE THINGS MERGING WE HAVE
THREE THINGS THAT ARE MERGING AT
THE SAME TIME. THE EXPANSION OF
MULTI TIERED SYSTEMS OF SUPPORT
WHICH IS A NEW VISION FOR HOW WE
DELIVER SERVICES TO ALL
STUDENTS.
THE CHANGE IN THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION CREDENTIAL WHICH FEEDS
INTO THAT IDEA THAT ALL TEACHERS
ARE TEACHERS OF ALL STUDENTS AND
THEY ALL HAVE SOME WORK TO DO IN
A GEN ED INCLUDED SPACE.
AND THEN THIRDLY AT THE
EXCELLENT THAT FUNDING WILL
PROVIDE TO RECRUIT TEACHERS INTO
THESE NEW PATHWAYS OF
PREPARATION ND TO ENABLE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO TO PROVIDE SOME
INCENTIVE TO HIRE THEM. KNOW
THAT LEGEND LIST IS RAISE SOME
OTHER QUESTIONS ABOUT WHETHER
COMPENSATION IS THE BIGGER ISSUE
THAT'S NOT A PROBLEM THAT WE CAN
SOLVE.
A THAT'S A MUCH BIGGER
CONVERSATION THAN THAN THIS IS
ABOUT WHAT THIS WILL DO IS BRING
FIVE THOUSAND SPECIAL EDUCATION
TEACHERS IN. TO HOPEFULLY
REPLACE THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
SERVING ON ON EMERGENCY PERMITS
IN THOSE SETTINGS
AND THAT'S AN IMPORTANT THING
FOR US TO DO I I WOULD JUST
ARGUE THAT THAT THAT IT'S IT'S A
VERY IMPORTANT TIMELY.
MERGE OF THREE VERY IMPORTANT
IDEAS.
THAT I THINK AREGOING TO BE
TRANSFORMATIVE FOR THE SCHOOLS.
NOW FOR THE LA ELKS I WOULD GET
IT IS TO WAY USERS THE.
THE ISSUE OF MONEY THAT WE'RE
PUTTING IN.
BUT THERE'S ALSO THE ISSUE AND I
THINK THE LA A BROUGHT IT UP AS
FAR AS THE.
THE STRUCTURE OR HOW WE DEVELOP.
PEOPLE GOING INTO THIS THIS
AREA.
AND ALSO I'VE READ REPORT
BELIEVE YOU KNOW LOOKING AT THE
WORLD TO SEE ISSUES ARE GOING TO
PLAY THIS ROLE THANK.
SO.
FROM AN ALLEY  PERSPECTIVE.
DO YOU AGREE THAT WAS JUST
PRESENTED BY.
DOCTOR SANDY TO WE MISSING
SOMETHING.
THEY SHE SHE OUTLINED IT THIS
THIS SYSTEMIC OF THE PROBLEM
SHE SAYS SHE'S GOT A PLAN TO
TRANSITION TO GO THERE AND
YOU'RE SAYING. NO WE'RE NOT WE
NEED TO PAY MORE BUT ALSO THE
SYSTEM AND I WE COULD ACTUALIZED
PROBLEM SO.
THIS YOU HAVE THE PATHWAY TO
SOLUTION OR YOU THINK NOT.
I THINK WHAT I HEARD IS THAT THE
COMMISSION AS AN INSTITUTION US
WORKING WITH AND AT STATUTORY
FRAMEWORK TO.
DO SOME THINGS TO SIMPLIFY THE
CREDENTIAL PROCESS
I THINK MANY LAYMAN'S REACTION
LIKE MINE AS WELL IT'S STILL
SOME COMPLICATED WELL I STILL
NEED TO DO THAT IF I WANT TO
LEARN THAT'S. IF I WANT TO SOME
DAY WORK WITH.
VISUALLY IMPAIRED STUDENTS I DO
NEED EXTRA WORK EVEN IF IT'S NOT
STARTING OVER I NEED TO DO
SOMETHING EXTRA.
AND. I THINK OUR PERSPECTIVE IS
ALSO THE LEGISLATURE HAS TRIED
MANY THINGS ARE MORE THAN FORTY
YEARS DOWN THE ROAD AND WE STILL
HAVE PROBLEMS AND I THINK SOME
PEOPLE THINK THE PROBLEM IS JUST
A SERIOUS TODAY HASN'T SUFFERED
BAN.
SUCH THAT.
WHAT WOULD IT TAKE AND I THINK
AGAIN TO PRODUCE MORE SPECIAL ED
TEACHERS TIRED AND THEY KNOW
THEY CAN
GET
THE SAME AMOUNT OF MONEY BY
SHUFFLING CLASSROOMS TWO DOORS
DOWN? OR LEAVE THE PROFESSION
BECAUSE THEY WERE WELL SUPPORTED
TO BEGUN WENT OFF AND THEY'RE
TIRED AND THEY CAN GET PAID
SUBSTANTIALLY MORE DOING
SOMETHING ELSE.
SO I THINK IF THE STATE WANTS TO
BE IN A DIFFERENT POSITION YEARS
FROM NOW AND HOW SO I I WOULD
SUGGEST CONSIDER.
WHAT DOES IT TAKE TO GET SPECIAL
ED TEACHERS NOT JUST TO BE WELL
PREPARED TO BEGIN WITH BUT TO
STAY IN THEIR JOBS?
TO GET BETTER AND BETTER AT
DOING THEIR JOBS.
AND I THINK THAT'S A DIFFICULT
CONVERSATION BUT I DON'T THINK
AN IMPOSSIBLE CONVERSATION I
THINK THAT TEACHERS AND
ADMINISTRATORS AND YOU CAN SHARE
THE SAME PERSPECTIVE OF NOT
WANTING TO BE IN THE SAME PLACE
FIFTEEN YEARS FROM NOW FIVE
YEARS.
BECAUSE I'M HERE IN THIS DAY AND
THE IN.
WELL IF YOU'RE GOING TO DIRECT
THIS QUESTION TO.
WE KNOW IT'S A PROBLEM.
FORTY YEARS.
I.
SOFTLY UNDERSTANDING THE TRUNK
METHOD YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
FOR
CREDENTIALING YOUR AND YOUR
DRESSING THIS
IS THAT MIX OF IT.
BUT ALSO READING THE REPORTS AND
HAVING GONE TO THE MEETINGS.
ONE OF THE TWO BIG AREAS THAT I
DON'T THINK DISCOVERS HOW MUCH
IN CRACKING FROM WRONG
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
WE'RE GOING TO DEAL WITH THE
ROOT ISSUE OF HOW YOU GET
CREDENTIALING TRAIN PEOPLE WITH
THIS EMPTY SS.
BUT WE ALSO NEED TO COMPENSATE.
PEOPLE IN THIS AREA.
AND ADDITIONALLY WE NEED TO.
DEVELOP SOME SUPPORT APPRENTICE
MENTORSHIP PROGRAM.
SO THAT WHEN YOUNG PEOPLE GO
INTO THIS.
YOU KNOW THE SUCCESSFUL.
DOES.
YOUR PROPOSAL OF A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS MEET ALL THREE
OF THOSE.
ARE ONLY ONE OF THEM OR.
WHAT IS IT DO?
BECAUSE THEY LAID OUT THE
SOLUTION SO.
WHEN LIKE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINE.
SO REGARDING BUILDING CAPACITY.
TO ACTUALLY TRAIN
SPECIAL ED TEACHERS.
PROPOSALS ADDRESS THE
OKAY THAT'S THE CREDIT THAT'S.
DOCTOR CHENEY'S POSITIONAL KIND
OF ANYONE PRESENT THE
RESIDENCIES OR EVEN THE LOCAL
SOLUTIONS IF THEY DID GROW YOUR
OWN PROGRAMS WITH WITH THAT
PARTICULAR INVESTMENT.
WOULD ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF THE
THE PREPARATION AND RETENTION.
I'M FROM A PREPARATION
STANDPOINT. BUT WHEN IT COMES TO
SALARY.
THAT IS A LOCAL DECISION IN
CALIFORNIA
STATUTE WHILE IT DOES SPECIFY A
CERTAIN TYPE OF SALARY SCHEDULE
FOR TEACHERS IT ALSO PROVIDES.
THE AUTHORITY FOR LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES TO IDENTIFY
ANY GROUP OF TEACHERS OR.
A TYPE OF TEACHER AND PAY THEM
MORE BASED ON THE WORK THAT THEY
DO.
AND SO.
UNDER CURRENT STATUE.
LOCALS HAVE AUTHORITY TO PAY
SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHERS WHAT
THEY FEEL THEY NEED TO IN ORDER
TO.
COMPENSATE THEM FOR THE.
THE ONEROUS NESS OF THE.
POSITION.
NOT THE STATE AT THIS TIME
DOESN'T DICTATE.
SALARIES FOR TEACHERS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL THAT IS SO
UNDERSTAND EVIDENCE WHICH.
POLYGAMIST A WHERE PERSPECTIVE
OF PEOPLE GOING IN THIS CASE IF
WE PUT HIM INTO THE PIPELINE.
BUT IT WOULD PUT HIM UP TO VALUE
BECAUSE THEY THEY DON'T HAVE THE
SUPPORT STRUCTURE BE THEY'RE NOT
BEING COMPENSATED. ASSUME WHY AM
I DOING THIS WHEN I CAN GO. BACK
TO TEACH ENGLISH AND NOT EVEN
DEAL WITH THIS.
DOCTORS AND IS THAT A LITTLE
MORE PERSPECTIVE ON THIS I THINK
THAT THIS HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
PROPOSAL COMPLIMENTS OTHER
INVESTMENTS THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE'S MAY. INVESTMENT TO
GROW AND ACCELERATE M. TSS.
ACROSS THE STATE IS A
SIGNIFICANT FOUNDATIONAL PART OF
THIS.
SO WE ARE CHANGING THE WAY WE
DELIVER SERVICES TO KIDS WHEN
WE'RE IN WITH SCHOOLS THAT ARE
USING ON TSS IN WAYS THAT ARE
VERY POSITIVE I'VE HEARD FROM
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT ARE
IMPLEMENTING IT. WHERE THEIR
PARENTS WERE SAYING CAN I TAKE
MY KID OUT ESPECIALLY BECAUSE I
WANT THEM TO BE IN M. T. SS WHAT
THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND THIS THAT
MTS ES IS STILL INCLUDE SPECIAL
ED? BUT IT'S BEEN IT'S BEEN RE
CONCEPTUALIZE AS MULTI TIERED
SYSTEMS OF SUPPORT IT EVERY KID
IS GOING TO NEED SOME ASPECT OF
SUPPORT THAT IT AND THEN THEY
THEY ALL MOVE WITHIN THAT
SYSTEM.
IN A WAY THAT DOESN'T FEEL SILO
THAT DOESN'T FEEL.
LIKE THEY ARE LESS THAN THE
OTHER STUDENTS AROUND THEM
EVERYBODY'S AGENDA AT STUDENT
AND THEY GET THE SERVICES THEY
NEED THAT'S A CRITICAL
FOUNDATION. WHAT THIS WILL DO IS
BRING MORE TEACHERS AND NOW I'VE
BEEN OUT VISITING SCHOOLS?
IN TALKING TO TEACHERS IN
TRAINING WENT TO THE LONG BEACH
A TO A SCHOOL IN LONG BEACH.
WHERE WE SAW ABOUT THIRTY
DIFFERENT CANDIDATES WHO ARE
SPONSORED BY CAL STATE LONG
BEACH? THEY'RE EARNING BOTH
THEIR GENERAL ED AND THEIR
SPECIAL ED CREDENTIAL IN THERE
DOING THEIR TRADE THEIR STUDENT
TEACHING HERE AT THE SCHOOL IN
AN INCLUDED MODEL. ALL WHEN
ASKED
WHETHER IF THEY'RE OFFERED A
GENEROUS SPECIAL A JOB WHICH
WHEN THEY WOULD TAKE. ALL OF
THEM SAID THEY WOULD TAKE A
SPECIAL A JOB THEY ARE HUNGRY
FOR IT THEY KNOW WHAT IT IS THEY
KNOW WHO THE STUDENTS ARE AND
THEY WANT TO SERVE THEM AND THEY
KNOW THAT THEY CAN THEY'RE
GETTING WELL TRAINED. TO DO SO
AND GIVEN THE CHOICE THAT'S WHAT
THEY'RE CHOOSING SO WHEN I HEAR
FROM TEACHERS SPECIAL ED
TEACHERS WHO ARE WEARY. AND TWO
THINGS THAT THEY RAISE ALL THE
TIME BUT I AND I DON'T HEAR
COMPENSATION MAYBE BECAUSE THEY
THINK THAT'S AN INSOLUBLE
PROBLEM BUT I HEAR CASELOAD. IS
SIGNIFICANT THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS THAT THEY HAVE TO
MANAGE TE IT PIECE FOR IS
SIGNIFICANT FOR THEM. AND THAT'S
A FUNCTION OF SHORTAGE
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH TEACHERS TO
SHARE THE CASELOAD OUT THERE.
AND WE NEED MORE AND THIS IS A
SOLUTION STRATEGY FOR THAT THE
OTHER THING I HEAR IS PAPERWORK.
OF THE AMOUNT OF PAPERWORK THAT
SPECIAL EDUCATION CREATOR HAS TO
DO THE TAKES AWAY FROM THE
SERVICES TO KIDS.
IT IT MAKES THEM WEARY AND IT'S
NOT THE WORK THEY SIGNED UP TO
DO THEY WANT TO WORK WITH YOUNG
PEOPLE SO THAT'S A SOLUTION
WE'RE LOOKING FOR IT IS POSSIBLE
TO LOOK AT DIFFERENT WAYS OF
MANAGING. THE PAPERWORK
ASSOCIATED WITH SPECIAL
EDUCATION BY HAVING OTHER
INDIVIDUALS WERE TRAINED TO DO
SO WE THINK THAT'S A THAT'S A
BAY AREA WE NEED TO EXPLORE MORE
FULLY.
.
BUT ALL OF THIS WILL BE AIDED BY
HAVING MORE FULLY PREPARED
SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHERS IN
THE SYSTEM TO SHARE THE LOAD.
AND YOU WERE TRAINED IN THE WAY
OF THINKING ABOUT AND DELIVERING
SERVICES THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATIONALIST LATER HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON AN EMPTY SS.
YEAH WELL THIS IS IMPORTANT TO
ME YOU KNOW I I THINK PETE
TEACHERS WHO GO INTO THIS AREA
SPECIAL ED.
OUR OUR SPECIAL AND THEY DO IT
FOR A REASON.
I USE MY DAUGHTER'S AN EXAMPLE
SHE'S ONE. AND I ASK YOU KNOW
WHAT IN SHE TOTALLY DIFFERENT
AND MADE SHE JUST.
VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT SEEN
SUCCESSES FOR THESE CHILDREN SO.
.
I GUESS I'LL TAKE YOUR WORD DOCS
ANY I'VE KNOWN KENTUCKY FOR
YEARS BUT THE.
YOU THINK THIS IS A.
RIGHT PATH AGO I DO.
THANK YOU AYE IM'S AYE A FINAL
COMMENT SURE BUT I'M AND SOME OF
THE THINGS AGAIN MANY OF THE
THINGS ARE CARRYING PAPERWORK
CASELOAD PAID. ONGOING ISSUES
AND I THINK.
THE COMMISSION MIGHT BE TRYING
TO PUT SOME OF THE BEST LIGHT
WHAT COULD A DISTRICT
REALISTICALLY DO WITH THESE
FUNDS BUT IF YOU LISTEN TO
FINANCES PROPOSAL THERE
REQUIRING DISTRICTS TO DO THOSE
THINGS WORRY DISTRICT TO DO THEN
YOU MIGHT GET A LITTLE BIT MORE
THAN YOU OTHERWISE WOULD. BUT
UNDER THE LOCAL SOLUTIONS
THEY'RE NOT REQUIRED TO DO
SOMETHING WITH MULTI STEERED TO
SYSTEMS OF SUPPORT THEY'RE NOT
REQUIRED TO IMPROVE THEIR HR
THEY'RE NOT REQUIRED TO GO TO
THE TABLE ON THINK ABOUT
SIMPLIFYING OUR PAPERWORK
PROCESS IS.
SO IF YOU WANNA IF SOMETHING
YOU'RE IT IS RESONATING WITH YOU
YOU MIGHT WANT TO DO THAT THING
AS OPPOSED TO JUST LETTING LOCAL
SUBMIT PLANS TO DO. THINGS I
THINK IMPORTANT WILL DEPART
FINANCE YOU BE WILLING TO PUT
THOSE.
COMPONENTS.
AND THE NEW REVISED.
I THINK SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
THE ALEJO HAS JUST MENTIONED.
ARE ACTUALLY BEING IMPLEMENTED
THROUGH.
OTHER PROPOSALS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
SO FOR EXAMPLE.
THE MTS SAYS THAT'S
DOES THE DUSTBIN FUNDED.
.
FOR SEVERAL YEARS NOW AND THERE
ADDITIONAL PROPOSALS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
SO THAT'S JUST ONE EXAMPLE. OF
THIS WOULD JUST YOU KNOW I'M NOT
TRYING TO PLAY DEBT FOR DEBT AND
WAS DRYING ST WE.
AFFIRMATIVE BUT THIS HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN THERE
STATEMENT FROM THE PARTRIDGE
CATIONS SAYS SOCCER SOLVE
PROBLEM WHAT'S GOING TO BE ON
THE WAY TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM. IS
ALL THE PROBLEM THEN BUT DIDN'T
WE HAVE ARE POTENTIALLY AN
EXPERT JOHN LEWIS.
WE HAVE MTS ASSN WE HAVE A PLAN
TO GO FORWARD.
JUST THIS NEEDS TO BE ADDED INTO
A COOLEY WINDOWS FOR A LONG TIME
SO PLEASE THINK ABOUT IT. WEEK
HAVE TWENTY FIVE REPUBLICAN
VOTES TO BE WILLING TO SOLVE
THIS PROBLEM.
IF YOU WILL NEED TO MOVE IT LET
ME GET TO GET BACK YOUR SETS OF
THIS IS THAT A GRANT PROGRAM
RIGHTS ARE NOT EVERYONE'S GOING
TO PARTICIPATES I THINK WHAT THE
LA A MATCHING. WHAT SEE THIS
WITH EVERY DISTRICT AND?
?
THAT'S ONE OF THE LIMITATIONS
BUT MAYBE I'LL GO BACK TO YOU
MISKIN AT AND I I APPRECIATE
THAT THOUGHTFULNESS OF WHAT
YOU'RE. TALKING ABOUT THIS IS.
A LINGERING ISSUE. AND.
BUT THE MONEY WE HAVE AVAILABLE
IS IS ONE TIME SO YOU'RE YOU'RE
SOLUTIONS DOING THINGS
DIFFERENTLY AND THEY BEAT
DIFFERENTIAL PAY AND HOW WE TAKE
A LOOK AT.
OUT HOW DO YOU DO THAT WITH ONE
TIME MONEY IS NEED ONGOING.
COMMITMENT AND SO THE GOVERNOR
FOR WRONG OR RIGHT BASED UPON
THE REVENUE PROJECTIONS THAT
THIS IS A PROBLEM WE HAVE. POT
OF HUNDRED MILLION ONE TIME TO
TACKLE IT IN SO.
I THINK THAT'S WHERE WE'RE
DEALING WITH BUT THIS WELL.
SO.
THAT WOULD WE HEAR HEAR THIS.
WE HEAR THE KIDDIES ISSUES.
OUT HIS MINISTER MURATSUCHI.
TOM.
I'M MAY NOT BE AWARE OF THE FULL
HISTORY OF THE ISSUE OF
DIFFERENCE DIFFERENTIAL PAY BUT
TO. ME THE ALEJO MADE IT CLEAR
WHAT YOU'RE HEARING IS.
THE COURT NUMBER ONE ISSUE FOR
THE SHORTAGE.
BOTH FOR SPECIAL LED AN FOR STEM
TEACHERS IS PAY. ARE GOOD CAN
YOU SUMMARIZE THE.
THE ATTEMPTS AND THE.
SUCCESS OR FAILURES OF OF PASS
ATTEMPTS TO.
TO PROVIDE MORE PAY FOR.
SPECIAL ED AND STEM TEACHERS.
AND.
.
I THINK DISTRICTS TRY IN SOME
INSTANCES SO I THINK THAT
SOMEONE COMMON FOR DISTRICTS TO
BE ABLE TO NEGOTIATE. A A
SIGNING BONUS OR AND AN ANNUAL
STIPEND OF SAY SEVEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS WHICH IS A SMALL BOOST.
SO I THINK THERE ARE TRYING TO
WORK WITH THEIR UNIONS TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO DO SOME COMPENSATION.
BUT IT HASN'T BEEN RUNOFF.
.
AND I THINK THERE'S A CULTURE A
BED OF RESISTANCE BECAUSE OF.
WANTING TO BE TREATED THE SAME
AS YOUR NEIGHBOR WHO WAS IN THE
THIRD GRADE CLASSROOM AND YOU'RE
RIGHT NEXT DOOR IN THE FOURTH
GRADE GRADE CLASSROOM. I THINK
SOME OF THAT AGAIN WE CAN
APPRECIATE BUT SOME IS THAT THE
PERSON IN THE ROOM NEXT YOU
MIGHT BE DOING OF FUNDAMENTALLY
DIFFERENT KINDS OF THINGS FOR A
GOOD CHUNK OF THE DAY AND ARE
WORKING MORE OVERTIME AND OR
HAVING A CASELOAD. THAT EVEN THE
TEACHER NEXT DOOR WOULD CONSIDER
I DON'T WANT THAT CASE LOAD
RIGHT AND WE DON'T HAVE RULES
LIKE LET'S JUST SHUFFLE STUDENTS
TO READ TEACHERS AROUND SO
THOUGH MOVE FROM SPECIAL ED INTO
GENERAL AND.
SO I THINK IT JUST STONE MAYBE
AS.
CONTINUING TO HAVE THE
CONVERSATION WHAT DO UNIONS FIND
REASONABLE WHAT KIND DISTRICTS
AND UNIONS IN MORE CREATIVE OR
DIFFERENT WAYS THINK ABOUT. A
LONGER TERM MORE SUBSTANTIAL
CHANGES TO HOW THEY.
DO THESE NEGOTIATIONS AND I
REALIZE WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS
MODEST BUT I THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT SIGNAL RIGHT NOW THE
STATE SETS THE DEFAULT. AND I
THINK THAT DEFAULT CREATES A
CLIMATE AND NOT COULD AGAIN IN A
SMALL WAY BE CHANGED AND MAYBE
OVER THE COURSE OF A NUMBER OF
YEARS DISTRICT CONVERSATIONS BUT
START CHANGING I THINK THEIR
SONS.
PERCOLATING YOU HEAR ABOUT
DISTRICTS EVERY SO OFTEN TRYING
MORE SUBSTANTIAL THINGS THE
STATE IN THE PROCESS TRIED ONE
TIME THREE MILLION DOLLAR
ALTERNATIVE COMPENSATION COME TO
THE STATE WILL GIVE YOU SOME
PLANNING MONEY TO SIT DOWN WITH
YOUR. UNION AND TALK ABOUT THESE
THINGS WHICH AGAIN SEEMS SO
REASONABLE THAT HASN'T WE DON'T
WE GOT VIRTUALLY NO TAKERS THE
LAST TIME STATE TRIED THIS SO I
THINK IT GIVES YOU AN INDICATION
ABOUT THE THE CULTURE.
AND MAKING IT BUT AGAIN I DON'T
THINK IT'S INSURMOUNTABLE I
THINK PEOPLE CAN GET ON THE SAME
PAGE IN YOUR PRIORITY YOU CAN
SING SIGNAL PRIORITIES THAT
MIGHT BE VERY SIMILAR TO THE
PRIORITIES IN THE FIELD AND IT
JUST TAKES A LITTLE BIT OF
PERSISTENCE CREATIVITY IT FIGURE
OUT. HOW TO DO IT WHEN WAS THE
LAST TIME THAT WHICH RIGHTS?
I'M AND IT WAS BEFORE THE
RECESSION SO I'M I'M GOING TO
GET THE YEAR I SUSPECT WRONG BUT
IT WAS LIKE FIVE SIX TWO
THOUSAND FIVE SIX.
OKAY.
SEEING NO FURTHER QUESTIONS WILL
HOLD THIS ISSUE OFTEN.
WE'RE GONNA GO BACK NOW AND THAT
WILL FIRST WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
ROLE.
ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
IT'S MCCARTY HERE HAVE IT HERE.
LIMON HERE MEDINA.
MERCY JETER.
O'DONNELL. VOEPEL.
WELL CHAIR IT'S ABOUT FELT TELL.
YOU AREAS OKAY WE HAVE A QUORUM
AND WITH THAT WE'RE GONNA. LOOK
FOR A MOTION ON THE VOTE ONLY
ITEMS
THESE ARE ISSUES ONE AND TWO.
THE CTC AIRPORT FINANCE LETTERS
AND ISSUE NUMBER TWO STUDENT
FAMILY SERVICE.
TAKE A MODEL ONE MUCH.
I MOVED.
OR IF YOU WANTED TO OKAY.
RIGHT NOW THE MOTION A SECOND
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON AND THAT
COMBINED MOTION FOR ISSUES ONE
AND TWO.
I.
MCCARTY.
I CHVEZ I. LIMON.
MEDINA.
PURSUE CHIANG MAI. O'DONNELL
VOEPEL. LIKE.
OKAY.
THIS YEAR.
PASSES
WHAT WE'RE GONNA BOUNCE AROUND
AGAIN WE'RE GONNA GO NOW TO
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE.
I'M SORRY YEAH ISSUE NUMBER FIVE
THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION.
TO HAVE REPRESENTATIVES HERE.
YEAH.
THIS IS A FOLLOW UP.
FROM LAST YEAR THERE IS THERE IS
NO.
ROGER PUT NEW PROPOSAL THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THAT WE
APPROPRIATE IN MY LAST YEAR WE
HAD A MAJOR CORRECTION.
WHAT INDIA?
AND THE AND THE BUDGET.
THE BILL UPDATE THAT WE.
PASSED IN MARCH.
AND WHEN I HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
HERE FROM THE STATE COMMISSION
ON THAT EVERY KID COUNTS ACT.
IMPLEMENTATION AS WELL WE HAVE A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM. CITY OF
WEST SACRAMENTO.
KNOWING IT WE'RE LOOKING FOR
PARTNERS ACROSS THE STATE TO
PARTICIPATE SO. AB PLEASE BEGIN
MISTER BRIAN.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING TURN
MEMBERS I'M DAVID O'BRIEN
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
FOR THE CALIFORNIA'S TO NAY
COMMISSION. WHICH ONE EXPRESS
OUR APPRECIATION OF THE
LEGISLATURE FOR REACHING OUT TO
US ABOUT THE ADMINISTRATION OF
THE EVERY KID COUNTS PROGRAM.
RECORDS HAPPY TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE ADMINISTRATION OF SUCH AN
IMPACTFUL PROGRAM BECAUSE.
AS YOUR CHEN DIMENSIONS.
THE RESEARCH SHOWS THE COLLEGE
SAVINGS IS LINKED TO COLLEGE
ATTENDANCE.
SOUTH AND TO REDUCE RELIANCE ON
STUDENT DEBT.
SO WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
SEEING THE OUTCOMES OF THIS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING AND SUPPORT
FOR LOCAL PROGRAMS AND HOPE TO
THE EVALUATIONS THAT THIS BILL
REQUIRES WILL PROVIDE SOME
INSIGHT. ON THE BEST WAY TO
EXTEND OR EXPAND COLLEGE SAVINGS
PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT THE STATE OR
IF WE WANTED TO GO TO A
STATEWIDE PROGRAM AT SOME POINT.
WE HAVE PROVIDED YOU TODAY WITH
A TENTATIVE IMPLEMENTATION
TIMELINE IT'S THIS ONE PAGE I
BELIEVE THE SERGEANT JUST PASSED
OUT WITH THE.
THE LOVELY PURPLE GRAPHICS ON
IT.
I WANT TO STRESS THAT THIS IS A
TENTATIVE IT WERE SO ABILITY
RELATIVELY EARLY IN THE STAGES
OF OUR.
ADMINISTRATION HERE BUT WE PLAN
ON UTILIZING WHAT DOES THEIR
QUEST FOR APPLICATION OR RFA
PROCESS
TO ENCOURAGE APPLICATIONS FROM
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND ELIGIBLE
ORGANIZATIONS FOR THESE
COMPETITIVE GRANTS. A THROUGHOUT
THE RFA PROCESS WE HOPE TO WORK
WITH A NONPROFIT ARTS
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE
EXPERIENCE IN THESE COLLEGE
SAVINGS PROGRAMS. SUCH AS
PROSPERITY NOW WITH WHOM WE'VE
BEEN IN CONTACT TO HELP GET THE
WORD OUT ABOUT THIS.
EXCITING ONE TIME OPPORTUNITY
SO THE FIRST STAGES JUST ESOS
SOCIAL MEDIA CAMPAIGN IN A PRESS
RELEASE THIS SUMMER TO GET THE
WORD OUT. WE HAVE TO RELEASE THE
RFA NOVEMBER TWENTY EIGHTEEN
HAVE ALL APPLICATIONS DUE TO THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION OF BY
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WHICH IS THE STATUTORY
DEADLINE PROVIDED BY THE BILL.
ARE SAMPLING CAREFULLY SCORE
EACH APPLICATION RECEIVED AND
DEVELOP STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS ON
GRANT RECIPIENTS AND AWARD
AMOUNTS FOR THE COMMISSION'S
CONSIDERATION AND OUR GOAL IS TO
HAVE THE COMMISSION VOTE TO WORK
THESE GRANTS ARE MARCH TWENTY
NINETEEN MEETING. THE FUNDS OF
THEREFORE BE DISPERSIBLE LOCAL
ORTIZ IN OR AROUND THE SPRING OF
TWENTY NINETEEN.
SO AGAIN WE JUST WANT TO
REITERATE THE WERE EXCITED TO
SEE HOW THIS PROGRAM HELP
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES IN
CALIFORNIA AFFORD TO PURSUE
HIGHER EDUCATION.
WE BELIEVE THERE'S CLEARLY
AMERICA PROGRAM OF THIS NATURE
AND WE MAY ACTUALLY CONSIDER A
BUDGET REQUEST THIS FALL TO
CONTINUE AND MAKE PERMANENT THIS
PROGRAM AND THE STAFFING
ASSOCIATED WITH IT. I JUST WANT
TO KNOW THAT ENCOURAGING COLLEGE
SAVINGS IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE RECENT
CENTURY FOUNDATION REPORT THAT
WE'VE DISCUSSED BEFORE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. EXPANDING
OPPORTUNITY REDUCING DEBT.
THIS GROUNDBREAKING REPORT.
RECOMMENDS THAT SEE SACK
PARTNER WITH LOCAL EFFORTS TO
PROVIDE USEFUL INFORMATION ABOUT
COLLEGE COSTS IN EIGHT AND TO
IDENTIFY INTENSE WAYS TO INFORM
COLLEGE PLANS IN THE YEARS
BETWEEN KINDERGARTEN SENIOR YEAR
OF HIGH SCHOOL.
SO IF YOU MAKE COMMISSION DOES
HOPE TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION OF FURTHER FUNDING
IN EXTENDING A PROGRAM BEYOND
THIS ONE THIS ONE YEAR.
WE JUST WANT TO THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR TRUSTING US IN THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THIS PROGRAM
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE. I'M I DO
WANNA GIVE A SHOUT OUT FOR
SACRAMENTO SEMESTER INTERN AARON
HUDDLESTON FOR HELPING US GET
THIS PROCESS ARE OFF THE GROUND
SHE'S DONE A LOT OF WORK ON THIS
AND.
WERE ALREADY FOR BECAUSE HE'S
ACTUALLY OFFERING ASSEMBLY
FELLOWSHIP FOR THE COMING YEAR.
AND I HAVE IAN WENT RIGHT HERE
WITH ME THAT I'M ARE SPENT FOR.
IT I THINK SHE HAS THE OFFICIALS
THE SECOND HORSEMAN YES I CAN
SAY THAT.
SO I HAVE THEM EVEN WHEN ROCKY
WITH A FROM THE CITY OF WEST
SACRAMENTO WHOSE PROGRAM MANAGER
FOR WEST SACRAMENTO HOME RUN.
OUT COLLEGE SAVINGS PROGRAM
THAT.
HE CAN DISCUSS.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING SHARON
MEMBERS MY NAME IS IAN WHEN
BROUGHT AND THE PROGRAM MANAGER
OF THE WEST SACRAMENTO HOME RUN
INITIATIVE.
THE CITY OF WEST SACRAMENTO.
HOME RUN INITIATIVE IS AN
EDUCATIONAL AND JOBS PROGRAM
THAT PROVIDES A SERIES OF
PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT A CHILD'S
LIFE INCLUDING A CITY SPONSORED
COLLEGE SAVINGS ACCOUNT. FOR
YOUTH AGES FOUR TO EIGHTEEN
DESIGNED TO DRASTICALLY INCREASE
COLLEGE COMPLETION RATES.
WHILE PREPARING OUR RESIDENTS
FOR HIGH WAGE HIGH GROWTH
CAREERS WITH THE GOAL OF WE CAN
MAKING THE CITY OF WEST
SACRAMENTO. HAVE THE MOST
ECONOMICALLY COMPETITIVE
WORKFORCE IN THE REGION.
AS THE SUBCOMMITTEE HAS HEARD
THROUGH DISCUSSIONS LAST YEAR
THERE ARE VARIOUS EFFORTS
CURRENTLY UNDERWAY ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. DESIGNED TO
INCREASE COLLEGE ENROLLMENT AN
EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT IN
ANTICIPATION OF THE PROJECTED
SIXTY FIVE PERCENT OF THE
WORKFORCE OR CRIER A POST
SECONDARY DEGREE BY TWENTY
TWENTY.
WHAT SACRAMENTO WHICH IS FOR
STORK WE EXPERIENCED PERSISTENT
HIGH UNDER EMPLOYMENT AND
UNEMPLOYMENT RATES?
WHILE REMAINING.
EMPLOYMENT HUB FOR THE
SACRAMENTO REGION.
HAS HAD VOTER SUPPORT TO CREATE
THE WEST ACKERMAN A HOME RUN.
IN ORDER TO INCREASE COLLEGE
COMPLETION AND CREATE AN
EXPECTATION FROM PRESCHOOL ON
WORK THAT EVERY RESIDENT IS
GOING TO ATTENDED COMPLETE SOME
FORM OF POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION.
THE HOME RUN INITIATIVE IS
FUNDED BY MEASURE E.. A BALLOT
INITIATIVE WHICH WAS PASSED
NOVEMBER OF TWENTY SIXTEEN BY
SIXTY FIVE PERCENT OF OUR
ELECTORATE.
PROVIDING MORE THAN ONE MILLION
DOLLARS IN NON SENDING.
NONSENSE SETTING ANNUAL FUNDS
FROM A QUARTER ENDS PERCENT
INCREASE IN OUR WORLD LOCAL
TRANSACTION AXES MEET OUR LOCAL
TRANSACTIONS AND USE TAX.
THE HOME INITIATIVE HAS THREE
BASED PROGRAMS.
FOR SPACES UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL
FOR ALL FOUR YEAR OLDS ARE
NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED UNIVERSAL
PRESCHOOL FOR WEST SACRAMENTO
PROGRAM.
AS WELL AS A CITY FUNDED CALLED
SINGS ACCOUNT OF AT LEAST FIFTY
DOLLARS FOR EVERY CHILD FROM A
RECOGNIZE UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL.
ENTERING INTO A LOCAL
KINDERGARTEN.
SECOND BASE ARE GUARANTEED
INTERNSHIPS FOR STUDENTS AND
INTEGRATED COLLEGE AND CAREER
CTE PATHWAYS.
AS WELL AS DIGITAL BADGES THE
COMPARE STUDENTS FOR CAREER
SUCCESS
AND FINALLY THIRD BASE.
THE WEST SACRAMENTO COLLEGE
PROMISE WHICH ALLOWS WAS
SACRAMENTO STUDENTS TO HAVE THE
FIRST TWO SEMESTERS OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FEE FREE.
AND OUR FIRST YEAR WE PROVIDED
SIX TURN SEVENTY HIGH QUALITY
PRESCHOOL SLOTS FOR CITIES FOUR
YEAR OLDS TWO DOZEN PAID
INTERNSHIPS FOR
WITH LOCAL EMPLOYERS FROM WITHIN
OUR INTEGRATED CULTURE CHRISSIE
T. PATHWAY SYSTEM.
AS WELL CENTS SIXTY SIX OF OUR
LOCAL HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS TO
COMMUTER COLLEGE FEE FREE. THERE
WAS SACRAMENTO COLLEGE PROMISE.
THIS SUMMER WAS SACRAMENTO WAS
PREPARING TO EXECUTES
THE NECESSARY AGREEMENTS TO
LAUNCH THE CITY SPONSORED
COLLEGE SAVINGS ACCOUNT PROGRAM.
OF THE WEST ACKERMAN A HOME RUN.
IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
FIRST SERIES OF FAMILIES HAVE
ACCESS TO.
THE SINGS ACCOUNTS THEY NEED TO
REPAIR THEIR USED TO GO TO
COLLEGE.
WITH A FIFTY DOLLARS IN C.
DEPOSIT MONEY PROVIDED BY THE
CITY THROUGH OUR LOCAL SALES TAX
MEASURE WILL BE SETTING THE
EXPECTATION EARLY ON THAT ALL
FAMILIES WILL BE ABLE TO SEND
THEIR CHILD TO SOME FORM OF POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION.
IT IS THE CITY'S GOAL TO BUILD
UPON THAT INITIAL DEPOSIT SO
THAT EVERYONE SACRAMENTO STUDENT
HAS SUFFICIENT RESOURCES TO
PURSUE THEIR POST SECONDARY
EDUCATIONAL GOALS. WHILE SETTING
THE STAGE FOR SOME FORM OF
INCENTIVE MATCH.
THE EVERY KID COUNTS PROGRAM
WILL PROVIDE CRITICAL ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO SUPPORT THE OPERATION
AND EXPANSION OF COLLEGE
STUDENTS ACCOUNT PROGRAMS ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THE CITY OF WAS SACRAMENTO
SUPPORTIVE THE INCLUSION OF A
VARIETY OF ELIGIBLE EXPENDITURES
FOR LOCAL PROGRAMS. THAT ARE
AWARDED MONEY FROM THE EVERY KID
COUNTS PROGRAM AS LAWSUIT LOCAL
INITIATIVES SUCH AS OURS.
HAVE A DIVERSE SET OF PRIORITIES
THAT ARE ESSENTIAL FOR
PROGRAMMATIC SUCCESS AND GROWTH
INCLUDING INCENTIVE GRANTS
OUTREACH AND ONE TIME
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS SUCH AS
LOCAL DATA SYSTEMS CREATION FOR
LONGITUDINAL EVALUATION.
WHILE LARGER LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
SUCH AS LOS ANGELES SAN
FRANCISCO AND OAKLAND HAVE
CREATED OR AND THE PROCESS OF
CREATING COSTUMES ACCOUNT
PROGRAMS.
SELECT A STRESSED THE
SUBCOMMITTEE THE CAPACITY OF
SMALLER MUNICIPALITIES SUCH AS
THE CITY OF WEST SACRAMENTO WITH
A POPULATION OF FIFTY THOUSAND.
A TO DELIVER ON CULTS IN HIS
ACCOUNT PROGRAMS.
AND I I WOULD SUGGEST THAT THE
EVERY KID COUNTS ARE IF INCLUDE
LANGUAGE THAT PRIORITIZES
FUNDING PROGRAMS IN
MUNICIPALITIES OF VARIOUS SIZES
ACROSS
STATE.
I WOULD PARTICULARLY LIKE TO
THANK CHAIRMAN CARI.
FOR HIS ROLE IN ADVANCING THE
EVERY KID COUNTS ACT AS WELL AS
HIS LEADERSHIP AND ADVANCING
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION CT
IN AB NINETEEN.
IT'S BECAUSE OF INVESTMENTS IN
THOSE AREAS THAT WERE SACRAMENTO
CAN EFFECTIVELY LEVERAGE OUR
LOCAL SALES TAX REVENUE
PROVIDING INNER AN ARRAY OF
PROGRAMS TO PREPARE LOCAL WORK
FORCE FOR COLLEGE AND CAREER.
WHAT'S ACKERMAN A STRONGLY
SUPPORTS THE ONGOING WORK OF THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT A COMMISSION
TO LOOK FOR TO THE RELEASE OF
THE RFA. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
AND OTHERS NO ACTION ITEM ON
THIS BUT WE JUST WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THE SUBCOMMITTEE HAD IT HAD
A REPORT BACK SINCE WE DID.
CUT IT SHIP WITH OUR PLAN FROM
LAST YEAR.
GOING TO THE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE
THE TREASURER'S OFFICE AND OUT
STUDENT COMMISSION. AND DIE I'LL
JUST REITERATE WHAT WHAT YOU ALL
SAID THIS IS ON THE THINK
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT IF ONE
FOCUS ON EDUCATION.
OUTCOMES IN HIGHER EDUCATION THE
COST OF CALLS SHE'S IS ISLAM ON
EVERYONE'S MIND IN.
AND RESEARCH IS CRYSTAL CLEAR
GAS MILEAGE DOLLARS IN YOUR
NAME.
THERE ARE FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
MEANING YOU STILL.
THE ODDS ARE ARE ARE EQUAL THAT
YOU WILL GO ON TO COLLEGE IF YOU
HAVE SOMETHING IN YOUR NAME
FOCUSING ON YOUR HIGHER
EDUCATION FUTURE AND SO.
I THINK CALIFORNIA TO BE LOOKING
AT HOW WE CAN DO THIS ALL
ACROSS.
OUR STATE WE HAVE YOU KNOW
THOUSAND CITIES ARE SO BUT WE
NEED TO START SOMEWHERE AND SO I
THINK IT'S IT'S A IT'S A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK AT THE
CITIES THAT ARE DOING IT. MEAN
BRING IN MORE UP TO SCALE AND
HAVE A HAVE A.
.
THE A ROADMAP FOR OTHER
JURISDICTIONS AS WELL.
SO I AND I I DO HAVE MAYBE A
COUPLE LOGISTICS QUESTIONS AND
SO.
YOU
WAS SACRAMENTO'S IS LAUNCHING
THEIR SOUND.
CITY SACRAMENTO WE HAVE A
SMALLER ONE HERE THAT AND
NONPROFIT NOT DESTROY THE CITY
IS PARTICIPATING SO.
IF YOU THINK SO HAVE HOW WE'RE
GONNA MAKE SURE THAT. THAT THAT
SMALL CITIES IN LARGE CITIES AS
AS AS WE DID NOT NOTICE KNOWS
HERE. ARE OUT CAN THERE ARE
OTHER GROUPS WHO ARE DOING IT IN
A CITY ARE THEY ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE YEARS IT JUST THAT
THE CITY GOVERNMENT OR THE
COUNTY.
AND THEN.
THIRDLY.
WHAT TYPE OF THE OF MATCH ARE
GONNA REQUIRE FOR THE
JURISDICTION
IF ANY AT ALL?
SURE I'D TO YOUR FIRST QUESTION.
I THINK IT'S KEY THAT BEFORE
THE RELEASE OF THE RFA.
THIS TO NAY COMMISSION LEVERAGE
SOME PARTNERSHIPS WITH
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS LEAVE
CALIFORNIA CITIES THAT COUNTY
SUPERVISOR ASSOCIATION SO FORTH
TO GET THE WORD OUT SO THAT ALL.
CITIES OR COUNTIES.
THAT THAT OPERATE OR ARE IN
DEVELOPMENT OF SUCH A PROGRAM
ARE AWARE OF IT SO I GUESS
THAT'S REALLY KEY IN AND WE
LOOK%
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THEM.
APART IS THE LEGISLATURE ON THAT
AS WELL.
WITH REGARDS TO YOUR SECOND
QUESTION I'M I BELIEVE THE
LANGUAGE THE BILL DOES PROVIDE
THAN ELIGIBLE NONPROFIT THAT
OPERATES A PROGRAM ON BEHALF OF
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT OR REGION.
IS ELIGIBLE TO APPLY.
AND AS I MENTIONED A VERY BEEN
A TOUCH OF ONE OF THEM BUT I'M
OF COURSE WILL CONTINUE WORK
WITH COMMITTEE STAFF AND. AND.
ANY OTHER ORGANIZATIONS WERE
AWARE OF TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE ALSO AWARE OF IT AND
THEN I AM I DON'T BELIEVE.
IF MEMORY SERVES I'M SORRY I
DON'T HAVE A LANGUAGE OF THE
BILL IN FRONT OF ME I DON'T
BELIEVE IT BAIT REQUIRED IN THAT
SPECIFICALLY IN THE STATUTE.
STANDARD PRACTICE THINK FOCUSES
ON THERE MUST BE RESOURCES
COMING CORRECT THEN THEY CAN'T
ALL BE THE STATE COMING IN AND
THAT ANGER ACTORS PROGRAM YES
SO.
AYE IF IT IT ENDORSES THE
GENERAL CONCEPT OF THE MATCH.
IN CONTRACTS OF THIS NATURE
THAT THE COMMISSION HAS ENGAGED
IN WE'VE TYPICALLY ASK FOR
EITHER A ONE TO ONE OR SOMETIMES
A ONE ONE AND A HALF TO ONE
MATCH SUCH AS WITH OUR. CALVET
SOAP OUR CONSORTIA BUT THAT'S
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT AS WE
DEVELOP THE RFA WE WANT TO LOOK
FOR SOMETHING THAT.
CAN HAVE AN IMPACT IT WILL BE
OVERTLY BURDENSOME
SURE ON CITY SO I DON'T THINK
WE'VE COME TO A DECISION ON THAT
YET WE'D WE'D DO I ABSOLUTELY
AGREE THAT YOU KNOW THE INTENT
OF THE BILL THERE'D BE SOME
FUNDS ALREADY. NOT THE LOCAL BUT
I DON'T THINK THAT WE WANT TO
MAKE IT SO STRENUOUS ON THEM
THAT.
THAT IT'S NOT WORTH THEIR TIME
BRIDGES TO APPLY YES. AND AGAIN
OF COURSE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
IS AN IDEA FACTORY AND.
WE'LL HAVE LARGE IDEAS.
IT'S AND SOMETIMES IT THERE ARE
HARD TO DEFERRED JUST LOGISTICS
PURPOSES AND FOR MONEY IT RIGHT
AWAY AND SO. STARTING SMALL I
THINK IT IS IT IS AN IMPORTANT
ONE AND. WE'RE NOT ALONE HIS
OTHER STATES HAVE DONE THIS
OTHER COUNTRIES AROUND THE GLOBE
SO.
I THINK THIS IS A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO FOCUS ON OUR OUR
YOUTH AND OUR FUTURE AS FAR AS
HIGHER EDUCATION.
OUTCOMES I I WANNA MAYBE ASK I
WEST SACRAMENTO SO IF IF YOU
WERE ABLE TO RECEIVE THIS THAT.
THIS THAT THIS AWARD THIS GRANT.
WOULD WOULD YOU.
.
IN IT EXPAND THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS THAT YOU'RE ABLE TO
GIVE THAT THE.
THE.
SAVINGS ACCOUNT TO KINDA YOU
MENTIONED ONLY STUDENTS WHO GO
THROUGH YOUR. CITY OF SACK
UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL PROGRAM. AND
THAT'S A FINITE NUMBER OR DO
YOU.
GIVE UP THE HIGHER AMOUNTS IN
THE STARTER ACCOUNT.
OR R. OR OTHER THINGS THAT THAT
YOU'D LIKE TO DO.
WE WOULD NEED TOUGH FIRST GIVE A
PROPOSAL FOR COUNCIL
CONSIDERATION BEFORE WE WENT TO
EXPANSION BUT COUNSEL HAS
ALREADY STATED THERE.
INTERESTS
AND.
POLICY DIRECTION ON BEING ABLE
TO HAVE ACCURATE EVALUATION.
WE THINK THE INCLUSION OF ONE
TIME ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS SUCH
AS CREATING A ROBUST DATA
SYSTEMS INTEGRATION TO BE ABLE
TO TRACK OF STUDENTS SUCCESS
OVER TIME.
THE INITIATIVE IS DESIGNED AS
SUCH.
BECAUSE WE REALLY WANT TO
PRESCHOOL AND KINDERGARTEN
BETWEEN.
CD  PATHWAYS AND
INTERNSHIPS SO COUNCIL'S BEEN
FIRM ON.
MAINTAINING THAT ONE WOULD ONLY
BE ELIGIBLE FOR THE COLLEGE
SAVINGS ACCOUNT IF YOU'VE
COMPLETED A.
CITY GUARANTEED HIGH QUALITY
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM WITHIN THE
CITY.
BUT. COUNCIL IS VERY INTERESTED
IN.
INCENTIVE MATCH PROGRAMS
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT INCREASES
PARENT INVOLVEMENT AND.
LIKELIHOOD OF.
USING THEIR CULT SAVINGS
ACCOUNT.
IN IN COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SPECIFICALLY.
BUT WE ARE KEENLY INTERESTED.
IN.
USING POTENTIAL.
LEVERED RIPPLE I GRANT FUNDS ON
THE DATA SYSTEMS EVALUATION
PIECE WAS.
SURE I THINK THAT RAISES A GOOD
POINT BECAUSE IF THIS WORKS
LONGITUDINALLY.
IF YOU LOOK TEN YEARS DOWN THE
ROAD LIKE THAT KINDERGARTENERS
AND ARE ISSUE JUST LIKE TO WANT
PEOPLE TO SAVE FOR THEIR
RETIREMENT IS TODAY START TODAY
WE WANNA GET MASS. THE AMOUNT OF
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA WERE
THINKING ABOUT THIS KNOWING.
THAT THAT THAT THAT THAT THE
COSTS ARE JUST TREMENDOUS AND
JUST THE STICKER SHOCK FOR SO
MANY PEOPLE TODAY. IT ALONE A
DECADE FROM NOW SO. I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING WE NEED TO TO
FIGURE OUT YOU KNOW WHAT ARE
WHAT ARE OUR OUR GOAL THIS IS IT
IMMEDIATE. A SATURATION THE
PEOPLE PARTICIPATING OR BUILDING
IT FOR LONG TERM SUCCESS SO BUT
THOSE ARE ISSUES THAT WILL BE A
SORT OUT THAT AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH WITH YOU AND
OTHER. GRANTEES THREAT
CALIFORNIA NEAR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU THIS IS INFORMATIONAL
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
DISCUSSES TODAY.
OKAY WE WILL GO BACK TO ISSUE
NUMBER.
THREE.
THE OFFICE OF PUBLIC SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION.
SCHOOL FACILITIES
.
AND SO I ED JENNIFER CAN AGAIN
LEDGE ANALYST'S OFFICE IS GOING
TO PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT OF
BACKGROUND ON WHAT'S HAPPENED TO
DATE. SO YOU KNOW PROP FIFTY ONE
WAS APPROVED NOVEMBER TWENTY
SIXTEEN INCLUDED SEVEN BILLION
FOR SCHOOL FACILITIES. LAST YEAR
WAS THE FIRST AUTHORIZATION OF
BOND SALES THE STATE APPROVED
FIVE HUNDRED AND NINETY FOUR
MILLION AND PROP FIFTY ONE
FUNDING FOR SCHOOLS. IS UP
ACTIVELY ON A TWELVE YEAR
EXPENDITURE PLAN.
THE STATE HAD GONE AGAIN FROM
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND SIX TO TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN WITHOUT A STATE
BONDS SO THERE ARE SUBSTANTIAL
ON NUMBER OF SCHOOL FACILITY
PROJECTS IN THE PIPELINE.
IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSES ANOTHER FIVE
HUNDRED AND NINETY FOUR MILLION
IN BONDS THEY ALSO CAN STAIN ON
THE TWELVE YEAR PLAN
EFFECTIVELY.
AND I THINK YOU COULD TAKE ONE
OF TO APPROACH US OR ONE OF TWO
VIEWS OF THE SITUATION AND SO ON
THE ONE HAND MOST SCHOOLS THEY
GO AHEAD AND UNDERTAKE THEIR
PROJECTS EVEN IF THEY DON'T HAVE
THE STATE CASH IN HAND.
NOT EVERY SCHOOL DISTRICT CAN
BUT MOST MED ON LARGE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS CAN THEY JUST GO AHEAD
AND DO THE PROJECT USED THEIR
LOCAL DEAL BOND MONEY TO FUND
THE CASH WAIT FOR THE STATE CASH
REIMBURSED THEIR LOCAL COFFERS.
SO IF YOU'RE NOT CONCERNED WITH
THE AMOUNT OF TIME AND STICKING
AT THE STATE LEVEL THE PROCESS
APPLICATIONS ARE DISTRICTS
WAITING. MONTHS YEARS TO GET THE
STATE REIMBURSEMENT THEN YOU
COULD JUST GO AHEAD AND ADOPT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
IF YOU'RE CONCERNED NOT SCHOOLS
WE'VE GOT A LOT OF PROJECTS IN
THE PIPELINE AT THE STATE LEVEL
THE STATE'S BEING ESPECIALLY
SLOW TO FUND THEM. UNDER THE
BOND MEASURE IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE
CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATED SO IF
YOU'RE CONCERNED IN THIS REGARD
IF THIS IS YOUR VIEW OF THE
SITUATION. YOU COULD FIND MANY
MORE PROJECTS OF THIS YEAR.
SO YOU MIGHT WANT TO ADOPT THE
FIVE YEAR PLAN AS OPPOSED TO THE
TWELVE YEAR EXPENDITURE PLAN IF
YOU DID THAT YOU WOULD BE GIVING
OUT MORE LIKE ONE AND A HALF
BILLION A YEAR AS OPPOSED TO A
FIVE HUNDRED SIX HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR.
SO WE CHAT WE LOOKED INTO OPSEU
STAFF IN THERE ARE THE ONES THAT
LOOK AT THE APPLICATIONS AND
STAFF THEM AND WE THINK IF YOU
WANTED TO TAKE THIS LATTER
APPROACH BE ON A FIVE YEAR PLAN
ONE AND A HALF BILLION A YEAR.
OPSEU HOW STAFF TO DO IT.
THEY'VE GOT FIFTY TWO FULL TIME
POSITIONS NOW.
THEY USE SEVEN OF THESE IN THE
COURT THEY USE SEVEN OF THESE IN
THE CURRENT YEAR TO PROCESS
APPLICATIONS AND THEY HAVE BEEN
TAUGHT TO GO UP TO TIME
POSITIONS. IN THE BUDGET YEAR.
SO THE FORTY TWO OTHER POSITIONS
ARE DOING APPEALS WORK SOMEHOW
REACH CLOSING OUT SOME AUDIT
WORK
AS YOU MIGHT RECALL LAST YEAR
YOU MADE A DECISION TO TAKE
STATE AUDITING OF PROJECTS AND
DEVOLVE IT SO THE AUDITING
FUNCTIONS NOW AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
AND WHEN YOU DID THAT YOU.
DIDN'T REDUCE OPSEU STAFF I'M IN
A TANDEM ACTION.
WHAT WE ALSO KNOW IS THAT THE ON
AVERAGE PERSON I'M A FULL TIME
PERSON OVER IT OPS THE IS
PROCESSING ONE POINT FOUR
APPLICATIONS PER MONTH?
SO WE SAT DOWN WITH OPSEU TO SAY
WHAT'S ENTAILED IN AN
APPLICATION REVEAL AND WE THINK
THAT COULD RECENTLY DONE BE DONE
MORE QUICKLY.
SO WE RAN AN ESTIMATE FOR YOU WE
SAID WELL WHAT IF THEY WERE TO
USE TWELVE PEOPLE ON THE BUDGET
YEAR RATHER THAN PAN. AND WHAT
IF THEY WERE TO PROCESS TO
APPLICATIONS PER MONTH RATHER
THAN ONE POINT FOUR SO I WOULD
ARGUE A VERY MODEST THAT OF
ASSUMPTIONS BUT IF THAT'S ALL
YOU ASSUME TWELVE FULL TIME
POSITIONS DURING TWO
APPLICATIONS A MONTH. THEY WOULD
ON AVERAGE PROCESS ONE AND HALF
BILLION I MEAN NOT ON AVERAGE
BUT THEY WERE PROCESS ONE AND A
HALF BILLION NEXT YEAR.
SO WE THINK IT'S NOT A STAFFING
ISSUE.
THAT YOU COULD AGAIN RECENTLY
PROCESS.
SUBSTANTIALLY MORE IF YOU WANTED
TO DO MORE THAN ONE POINTFIVE
BUT ONE POINT FIVE WOULD PUT YOU
ON THE FIVE YEAR.
GOOD MORNING SURELY DOUBT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PERCEIVE
ME THE BUDGET AFTER TWENTY
SEVENTEEN INCLUDED ADDITIONAL
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES FOR THE
SCHOOL FACILITIES PROGRAM AS A
CONDITION OF RELEASING BOND
FUNDING FOR THE PROGRAM.
SINCE ENACTMENT THE STATE
ALLOCATION OR DISAPPROVE GRANT
AGREEMENTS AND AUDIT STRUCTURES
WERE DEVELOPED FOR LOCAL
AUDITOR'S TO COMPLETE
INDEPENDENT PERFORMANCE AUDITS
TO ENSURE THE PROGRAM
COMPLIANCE.
THIS YEAR'S GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES APPROXIMATELY SIX
HUNDRED FIFTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR SCHOOL FACILITIES
CONSTRUCTION. AND PROGRAM
CONTINUES TO FOCUS ON PROCESSING
APPLICATION AS WELL AS PROVIDING
OUTREACH ASSISTANCE SMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
WITHOUT HAPPY TAKING QUESTIONS.
A PRIVATE EDUCATION.
THEN. STEP AROUND THE OFFICE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TOM GULLIKSON AND
THIS THE SUPERINTENDENT STRONGLY
SUPPORTED THAT THE BOND PROPOSAL
I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT. REALLY
AS WE THINK ABOUT FACILITIES
IT'S MORE THAN JUST THE PHYSICAL
FOOTPRINT THAT IT REALLY IS IS.
CRITICAL TO THE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT AND TO A STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT AND SO WE WOULD THAT
THE SUPERINTENDENT SPORTS
ACCELERATING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL GETTING MORE BOND BOND
FUNDS OUT FASTER.
OUT OF THE OFFICE THAT PUBLIC
SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION.
THIS ASSORTMENT. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR AND AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ADDS LISA SO READ UP
ON WE OPERATE THE PROGRAM FOR
THE SCHOOL FACILITIES PROGRAM ON
BEHALF OF THE.
DEPARTMENT JAIL SERVICES AND
STILL OCCASION BOARD SO WE OUR
MAIN GOAL IS TO PROCESS GRANT
APPLICATIONS THAT'S THAT'S TRUE
THAT'S ONE OF OUR MISSIONS BUT
THERE'S ALSO OTHER MISSIONS AND.
IS A COMPLIANCE ROLL THERE'S
ALSO A COUNTY ROLL-ON AND ALSO
PROCESS REGULATIONS AS WELL. AS
WELL AS APPEALS.
AND THE VOTERS HAVE BEEN
GRACIOUS TO PROVIDE FIVE.
VOTER APPROVED INITIATIVES
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT THAT
HE CREATED TO FORTY TWO BILLION
DOLLARS.
AND WE HAVE DISPERSED OVER
THIRTY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS.
IN PROGRAM FUNDS OF THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS.
SO OUR PRIMARY GOAL AS I
MENTIONED ON MY TWENTY GIVE YOU
A RECENT UPDATE AS FAR AS THE.
PROPOSITION FIFTY ONE WAS A
RECENT VOTER INITIATIVE THAT WAS
APPROVED IN NOVEMBER TWENTY.
STEEN AND THAT PROVIDED SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS FOR THE PROGRAM
ON THREE BILLION IN NEW
CONSTRUCTION THREE BILLION A
MODERNIZATION.
AND FIVE HUNDRED MILLION IN
CHARTERS.
.
SCHOOL FACILITIES PROGRAM AND
ALSO INCUR TECH EDUCATION
PROGRAM.
OUT OF THAT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS IT WAS APPROVED BY THE
VOTERS.
.
WE ACTUALLY HAVE TAKEN ACTION.
CLIENT AND WE HAVE ABOUT FIVE
POINT NINE BILLION DOLLARS
LAUGHED.
IN THE PROGRAM AND THAT ALSO
INCLUDES.
SOME RESIDUAL FUNDS AND PRIOR
PROGRAMS AS WELL.
SO I DON'T PROPOSITION FIFTY ONE
WE HAVE FIVE POINT EIGHT BILLION
LAUGHED OUT OF FOUR POINT TWO
MILLION IN SEISMIC MITIGATION
PROGRAM FUNDS. SIXTY FOUR AND A
HALF MILLION ENTERED SCHOOL
FUNDS A LITTLE POINT FOR AN
OVERCROWDED RELIEF GRANT PROGRAM
FUNDS TO OVER TWO POINT SIX.
MILLET BILLION DOLLARS AND NEW
CONSTRUCTION AND TWO POINT SIX
BILLIONIN MODERNIZATION AND
LIKEWISE CAREER TACK WE HAVE
FIVE HUNDRED NINE MILLION.
AVAILABLE IN PROGRAM FUNDS AND
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND AND.
HARDSHIP FUNDS.
WE HAVE BEEN ACTIVE IN THE
PROGRAM.
STALE OCCASION BOARD AND I
ALONG WITH THE MEMBERS OF THE
BOARD WE WANTED TO PUT SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES IN
PLACE.
THERE'S A DISLODGED ESPECIALLY
HOW WE START THE PROGRAM UP
AGAIN.
SO THE BOARD TOOK SOME
SIGNIFICANT ACTION IN JUNE. OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND THOSE
ACTIONS HASN'T NOW LET THROUGH
PATHWAY A PROCESSING PROJECT
APPLICATIONS.
SO IN TOTAL IN JUNE FIFTH OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN REPROCESSED
THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS.
IN PROJECT APPROVALS AND THESE
ARE APPLICATIONS FOR NEW
CONSTRUCTION MODERNIZATION ON
HIS PART OF TECH CAME IN THROUGH
THE DOOR IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE
IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN EVEN
THOUGH WE DIDN'T HAVE BOND
AUTHORITY. AND THE BOARD HAD
AUTHORIZED AT THAT POINT IN TIME
TO PROCESSES APPLICATIONS.
SO.
THOSE PROJECTS WERE EFFECTIVELY
FUNDED ON JUNE FIFTH A TWENTY
SEVENTEEN BY THE BOARD AND AGAIN
THAT'S A HUNDRED TWENTY NINE
APPLICATIONS AT MOVED FORWARD.
I ALSO WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU
THERE'S PROCESS IN OUR.
OUR PROGRAM IS CALLED FACILITY
HARDSHIP IN THIS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY PROJECTS WE HAVE PROCESS
TWENTY FOR PROJECTS FROM JUST
JULY FIRST TO DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN. THAT
A CREATURE TWENTY POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS.
AND THAT ALSO INCLUDED SEISMIC
MITIGATION PROGRAM FUNDS
SO THOSE PROJECTS ARE PROCESS IN
AN ACCELERATED MANNER AND SO
THEY JUMPED INTO THE FRONT OF
THE LIST. AND NOT PROCESS IN A
DATE ORDER RECEIVE AND IN THE
NORMAL PROGRAM SO THOSE ARE
ADDITIONAL APPLICATIONS THAT WE
ALSO PROCESS.
IN OUR HOUSE.
I ALSO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT TO THE
CHARTER SCHOOL FACILITY PROGRAM
THERE WAS FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ALLOCATED. FOR A PROGRAM
FUNDS.
THE FINALLY AROUND OPEN IN
FEBRUARY TWENTY SEVENTEEN. WE
HAD WITH BEEN OVERSUBSCRIBED IN
THAT PROGRAM SO THERE WAS OVER
THREE POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS
IN REQUEST THAT CAME IN FOR THAT
FIVE AND A MILLIONS WHO IS VERY
COMPETITIVE. PROCESS AND THOSE
WORDS HAVE PROVIDED.
A PRELIMINARY RESERVATION OF
FUNDS FOR THIS PROGRAM FUNDS AND
THAT'S ACTUALLY. OF DISPERSED
OVER PRETTY CLOSE TO FOUR
HUNDRED NINETY MILLION DOLLARS
IN THE CHARTER SCHOOL FACILITY
PROGRAM FUNDS.
AND THAT WAS EFFECTIVE JANUARY
AND FEBRUARY.
THERE IS ALSO SOME RESIDUAL
FUNDS AND THE PRIOR PROGRAMS AND
THOSE ARE ACTUALLY.
APPROVED AS WELL.
AND WE ACTUALLY HAVE A CURRENT
CAREER CHECK EDUCATION FILING
AROUND IT'S OPEN AND WILL BE
PRESENTING SOME ITEMS TO THE
BOARD AND THAT WILL CONSUME A
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILLION. AND
THAT WILL BE COMING UP MATTER A
FEW WEEKS.
SO DISAPPEAR PERSPECTIVE OF HOW
MANY SHOVEL READY PROJECTS WE
HAVE PROCESS SINCE THE OF THE
BEGINNING OF THE PROGRAM UMPS
HAVE SUPPORTED ACTION. WE HAVE
PROCESS OVER EIGHT HUNDRED
EIGHTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN
PROGRAM GRANTS
IT'S PRETTY SIGNIFICANT.
AND ALSO WANT TO SHARE THAT
OVER FIVE HUNDRED MILLION OF
THAT.
.
THAT THOSE PROJECTS.
COMMITTED FLOOR FOR CHARTER
PROGRAM.
FOR THE PRELIMINARY RESERVATION
OF THOSE PROGRAM FUNDS.
AS I MENTIONED BEFORE THIS DATE
ORDER RECEIVED AS HOW WE PROCESS
APPLICATIONS FOR CIVILITY
HARDSHIP. ON WE PROCESS THOSE ON
ACCELERATING MATTER USED AS OUR
HEALTH AND SAFETY PROJECTS.
I'M I ALSO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT TO
THERE'S.
FILING ROUNDS FOR A CAREER TECH
EDUCATION SO THOSE ARE OUR.
VERY ROUND SPECIFIC AND SO WE
MANAGE ALL THAT WORKLOAD
INCLUDING THE APPEALS PROCESS AS
WELL.
AND I ALSO WANTED A HIGHLIGHT TO
VERY QUICKLY.
THAT THE BOARD.
ALTHOUGH TAKING ACTION ON THESE
PROJECTS.
THERE WAS ACTUALLY A SPRING ON
AND A FALL BOND SALE.
THAT OCCURRED AND SO
PROPOSITION FIFTY ONE DID HAVE
SOME BOND PROCEEDS ALLOCATED.
AS A RESULT OF THOSE PROGRAM
GRANTS BEING AWARDED SO IN THE
FALL TWENTY SEVENTEEN HUNDRED
THIRTY ONE PROJECTS HAVE WERE
APPROVED IN BOND PROCEEDS WERE
SOLD ON THE OPEN MARKET SO THAT
REPRESENTED OVER FOUR HUNDRED
THIRTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS.
GOING OUT TO PROJECTS AND THOSE
OF THE PROJECTS THAT ALREADY
HAD.
THE WORD STE.
APPROVED BY THE BOARD IN JUNE.
AND I ALSO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT IN
SPRING OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN JUST
TWO MONTHS AGO.
WE HAD NINETY PROJECTS APPROVED
AND THAT WAS A HUNDRED NINETY
ONE MILLION DOLLARS. AND AGAIN
THESE ARE THE PROJECTS THAT HAD
A BOARD APPROVAL PRIOR.
FROM JULY FIRST THROUGH UP
UNTIL THE EARLY PART IN DECEMBER
SO I BOND PROCEEDS HAVE BEEN
SOLD FOR THE PROGRAM I JUST WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT THAT TO YOU.
SO AS A RESULT WE I JUST WANT
TO SHARE THAT WE HAVE I THINK
YOU GIVE YOU THE STATISTICS
EARLIER WE HAVE ADDITIONAL
PROJECTS THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
PRESENTING.
IN MARCH
AND ALSO.
THROUGH THOSE PROJECTS ARE ALSO
ELIGIBLE FOR. SOME BOND PROCEEDS
TO AS COME TO FALL NAY AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER WE HAD OVER
TWO HUNDRED NINETEEN MILLION
DOLLARS OF. NEW CONSTRUCTION
MODERNIZATION PROGRAM PROJECTS
THAT ARE READY FOR THE APPROVAL.
AND STARS HAVE A MATCH CASH
PROCEEDS AVAILABLE.
A BUT I ALSO WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT
IMPORTANT NOTE I KNOW THERE IS A
MENTION ABOUT OUR WORKLOAD WE DO
HAVE ARE PROJECTS THAT ARE GOING
WORK LOAD. AND THEY HAVE BEEN
THE WORKLOAD SINCE WE WEREN'T WE
DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO
PROCESS THE PROGRAM GRANTS
BECAUSE THERE WAS NO. BOND
AUTHORITY AVAILABLE
SO SENSE AND.
THERE HAD BEEN ACCUMULATION OF
PROJECTS ON THAT WORKLOAD WE
HAVE IN PROCESSING THOSE.
PROJECTS THAT WERE REPRESENT
NEW CONSTRUCTION MODERNIZATIONON
A DATE ORDER RECEIVE.
BASES.
AND SO CURRENTLY WE HAVE AS OF
APRIL THIRTIETH OVER THREE POINT
SIX BILLION DOLLARS.
AND PROJECTS IN OUR WORKLOAD
LIST CURRENTLY.
AND THAT REPRESENTS THREE
HUNDRED CITY SEVERAL PROJECTS IN
THE CONSTRUCTION AND SIX HUNDRED
CITY FOR PROJECTS.
AND MODERNIZATION.
AND SO THAT EQUATES TO OVER A
THOUSAND FIFTY ONE GRANTS ARE
AWAITING I'M ON OUR CURRENT
WORKLOAD RIGHT NOW.
WITH THAT I WANTED TO HAND OVER
THE MIKE TO. MY COLLEAGUE
BERNARD CAN'T MINOR AND SHE CAN
TALK ABOUT A CURRENT STUFF.
THANK YOU.
IF I RECANT MINOR THE OFFICE OF
PUBLIC SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION.
AND JUST WANTED TO BREAK DOWN
OUR STAFFING ALLOCATIONS FOR YOU
JUST TO GET A SENSE OF THE
POTENTIAL FOR. EXISTENCE OFTEN
WHO IS ABLE TO PROCESS
APPLICATIONS BUT. I'M AS WAS
MENTIONED WE HAVE FIFTY TWO
STAFF THAT SHOW ON OUR ORG CHART
RIGHT NOW. AND IF YOU EXCLUDE
OUR EXECUTIVE POSITIONS ARE
AUDIT FOLKS ARE IN A DIFFERENT
CLASSIFICATION THAT IS GEARED
TOWARDS AUDITING PROJECTS.
AND OUR ACCOUNTING STAFF THAT
ARE COVERING AND
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR FORTY TWO
BILLION DOLLAR PROGRAM AND
HUNDRED FIFTY NINE FUNDS AND SUB
FUNDS AND. WE ACTUALLY HAVE A AT
MAXIMUM TWENTY ONE.
ANALYSTS THAT WOULD BE IN A
CLASSIFICATION APPROPRIATE FOR
PROCESSING APPLICATIONS.
AND A THAT ARE COUNT RIGHT NOW.
WE HAVE THIRTEEN OF THE TWENTY
ONE OR SIXTY TWO PERCENT BETTER.
AIMS OUT PROCESSING APPLICATIONS
WITH THAT THAT.
APPLICATIONS BEING BOTH NEW
CONSTRUCTION AND MODERNIZATION
OUR FACILITY HARDSHIP HEALTH AND
SAFETY PROGRAM CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION.
THE CHARTER SCHOOL FACILITIES
THE INTAKE PROCESS FOR ALL THE
APPLICATIONS THAT CAN MEN. AS
WELL AS APPEALS AND WE COUNT
APPEALS AS APPLICATION
PROCESSING BECAUSE WITHOUT THE
APPEAL COMPONENT THAT ITEM
CANNOT ACTUALLY GO FORWARD FOR
BOARD APPROVAL SO WE NEED
SOMEBODY TO PROCESS THE APPEAL.
IN ORDER FOR THE FUNDING TO
ACTUALLY GO OUT.
SO THAT LEAVES US WITH AIDS AND
AND JUST WANTED TO BREAK DOWN
THAT THOSE OTHER EIGHT POSITIONS
ARE USED FOR GRAND AGREEMENTS
WHICH I COULD MAKE A CASE. AS
PART OF THE APPLICATION PROCESS
AND IN A CRITICAL FUNCTION.
AND.
TWO POSITIONS FOR A POLICY ITEMS
FROM THE STATE ALLOCATION BOARD
IN THE SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN FISCAL
YEAR IS A VERY HEAVY YEAR FOR
POLICY AND INCLUDE ALL THE
CHANGES THAT. ARE HAPPENING IN
THE PROGRAM.
AND.
THREE FOLKS THAT SERVE IN OUR
ADMINISTRATIVE BUSINESS SERVICES
SPECIAL PROJECTS FROM THOSE
FOLKS HANDLE THE REGULATION
PACKAGES THAT WE DO PROCESS ONCE
THE BOARD TAKES POLICY ACTION.
OUR ENTIRE COMMUNICATIONS
FUNCTION WHICH INCLUDES THE
MAINTENANCE OF OUR WEBSITE
MAKING SURE THINGS ARE
ACCEPTABLE TO STAKEHOLDERS.
OTHER STATE ALLOCATION BOARD
AGENDA AND OR FILE ROOM MAILROOM
BUDGETS HR AT SIGGRAPH. AND THEN
WE DO HAVE TWO POSITIONS THE
EQUIVALENT OF TWO POSITIONS THAT
WORK TOWARDS THE OUT REACH AND
SERVICES WITH OUR SMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
SO THAT AND IS THE BREAKDOWN OF
OUR CURRENT STAFFING SO WE WE DO
FEEL THAT WE ARE TRYING TO FOCUS
ON. ALL OF OUR CORE FUNCTIONS
AND PROCESSING THE APPLICATIONS
AND MEETING THE NEEDS OF THE
STATE ALLOCATION BURDEN KEEPING
THE PROGRAM RUNNING.
M..
HINTS THAT THAT'S WHERE WE'RE AT
RIGHT NOW. THANK YOU.
THAT. I BELIEVE COMPLETES THE
PRESENTATION.
QUESTION.
I DO HAVE A A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS FIRST TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
A I BELIEVE IT WAS LAST YEAR WE
WERE HERE ASKING.
THE GOVERNOR ABOUT THE.
NUMBER PROJECTS FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
MY CORRECT.
ON PROP FIFTY ONE.
MY.
I THAT MY COLLEAGUE EL THE FOR
HER FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
OKAY YEAH DEPARTMENT IF YOU
COULD. COME FORWARD.
I.
SO SO MY QUESTION THAT I THINK
LAST YEAR WHEN WE WERE. LOOKING
AT PROP FIFTY ONE IN THE RELEASE
IN OF OF THAT THE SALE OF THE
BONDS IN THE NUMBER PROJECTS.
IT WAS MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
THERE WERE LIKE TWENTY.
PROJECTS THAT HAD BEEN APPROVED.
BUT THE BUT THE GOVERNOR WAS
SLOW AND ALLOCATING OR LEADING
THAT. DOES GO OUT TO THE OTHER
PROJECTS THAT THERE WERE ONLY
LIKED WELL. MY MEMORY SERVES ME
CORRECTLY UPWARDS OF HE SAID
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THAT
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE OF
FACILITIES. THOSE ARE PROCESS AT
THOSE APPLICATIONS ARE REVIEWED
BY OUR CAPITAL OUTLAY ANALYSTS
AND THE.
OFFICE OF PUBLIC SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION SHEPHERD SO
SEPARATE ISSUES OKAY BUT THEY
ARE BOTH PROP FIFTY ONE.
THAT THE TWO BILLIONS COMING OUT
OF THERE YES WELL.
SO CAN YOU ADDRESS I UNDERSTAND
THAT THEY ARE NOT THE FOLKS THAT
ARE DOING IT I GET A.
CAN WE CAN YOU DRESS
HOW WE'RE DOING IN MAKING
PROGRESS. IN THAT IN ALLOCATING
THE TWO BILLION DOLLARS AND I
WOULD DEFER TO OUR AYE CAPITAL
OUTLAY ANALYSTS THAT ARE NOT
PRESENT WHO. ARE LEADING THE
PACK SOMEBODY CAN ATTRACTED ME
ON THAT AYE I AM DIDN'T COULDN'T
BUDGET ANALYST I DO THINK YOU'LL
HEAR MUCH MORE AT ANOTHER
HEARING BUT THERE WERE I THINK
YOUR MEMORY IF I RECALL SERVE
YOU CORRECTLY LAST YEAR VIC
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE APPROVED
TWENTY NINE PROJECTS.
THE GOVERNOR GAVE YOU FIVE IN
JANUARY LEGISLATURE EXPRESSED
SOME FRUSTRATION GAVE YOU MORE
AND THE MAY REVISION AND I THINK
THAT LANDED ON SOMETHING LIKE
TWELVE SO THOSE TWELVE HAVE
MOVED FORWARD. THE GOVERNOR CAME
BACK THIS YEAR. LARGELY WHAT YOU
FUNDED BLASTER WAS PULMONARY
PLANS SO YOU FUNDED THE WORKING
DRAWINGS ON THOSE TWELVE TO
CONTINUE ADVANCING THROUGH THE
PIPELINE AND THEN YOU ADDED.
.
I I THINK ANOTHER FIVE SOME FOUR
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
SAID IT'S STILL A BIT OF A
MODEST PLAN SO JUST AS HE HAS
WHEN I ADMIRE CHARACTERIZE AS A
MODEST PLAN ON THE KEY TWELVE
SIDE TO JUST DO.
SIX HUNDRED MILLION OF SEVEN
BILLION IT'S THE SAME SORT OF
MODEST PLAN ON THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
HE'S ACTUALLY TRICKLING OUT THE
MONEY A LITTLE BIT MORE SLOWLY
ON THE COLLEGE SIDE BECAUSE HE'S
DOING IT IN PHASES WHICH IS WHAT
WE CHURCH TRADITIONALLY
RECOMMEND YOU DO YOU FIND THE
PLANNER PLANS GET A GOOD
ESTIMATE DO WORKING TRYING TO
GET AN EVEN BETTER ESTIMATE OF
CONSTRUCTION. THEN FONG
CONSTRUCTION ONCE THEY GET THERE
THAT'S THE APPROACH THAT
FINANCING YOU HAVE BEEN TAKING
ON THAT COLLEGE SIDE BUT YACHTS
ALL COMING OUT OF PROP FIFTY
ONE.
SO ORIGINALLY THERE WERE.
AROUND TWENTY APPROVED.
AND NOW.
SOMEWHERE IN THERE THE GOVERNOR
IS NOW MOVED TO.
HOW MANY THAT ARE BEING FUNDED
YEAH SO HIS ADVANCING ALL THE
PROJECTS LAST YEAR AND I I'M
FORGETTING BUT HE ADDED AT LEAST
FIVE THAT MIGHT OF BEEN MORE
THIS YEAR OF? TOTALLY NEW
PROJECTS WHERE HE'S FUNDING THE
FIRST DAY DEPLOYMENT PLANS TO
GET AS TO WHAT NUMBER.
I YOU KNOW THE DOLLAR AMOUNTS IN
THIS LOS I WAS A NUMBER
PROJECTS.
I THINK ONLY BITS.
I DO THINK IT'S ONLY LIKE FIVE
PROJECTS.
GOOD SO FAR A YACHT AND THOSE
FIVE PROJECTS BECAUSE IT'S ONLY
PRELIMINARY PLANS THAT WOULD BE
NEWLY ADDED IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
THEY THEY TOTAL LIKE TONS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IT'S A LOW
PRICE TAG BECAUSE THE PLANNER
PLANS IS OBVIOUSLY. A NOT AN
EXPENSIVE COMPONENT OF THE
ENTIRE PROCESS EXTENSIVE
COMPONENT ITS CONSTRUCTION AND
AND THE BONDS WOULD WOULD.
HAVE TO BE THE NEW CONSTRUCTION
FOR SAY THAT STAY ON COMMUNITY
COLLEGE WOULD HAVE TO BE USED BY
WHEN.
I DON'T THINK THAT THERE IS ANY
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS THE STATE
CAN BE ON THE FIVE YEAR PLAN THE
TWELVE YEAR PLAN THE TWENTY YEAR
PLAN. AYE WE DIDN'T EMPHASIZE
THAT TODAY BUT THERE ARE STILL
SOME BONDS WAY BACK FROM THE FOR
TWO THOUSAND SIX WHERE MONEY AS.
AND IN THESE CASES WHERE MONEY
IS VERY OLD MORE THAN TEN YEARS
OLD THAT'S BECAUSE IT WAS
GRANTED FOR PROJECT THAT
SOMEWHERE IN THE PROCESS GOT
RESCINDED. FLOWED BACK TO THE
STATE AND OUR REPURPOSE XENA.
I'M THIS IS JUST A SECOND TAKE A
VERY LONG TIME BUT THERE'S NO
LEGAL DEADLINE UPON WIN ALL THE
BONDS MUST BE SOLD.
AND THEN TO THE OFFICE OF PUBLIC
SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION.
I HEARD YOU MENTION THE.
SAFETY AND HOW.
THAT KINDA GET EXPIATE IT.
CORRECT THAT'S CORRECT
NOW IF OTHER PROJECTS ARE IN THE
QUEUE IN THE LINE.
TO BE FUNDED.
AND THE OTHER PROJECTS.
THAT HAVE THE.
EXPEDIA ADDED SAFETY OUT.
I GET FUNDED AHEAD OF THEM.
COULD SOME OF THE PROJECTS THAT
WERE IN LINE FALAH.
NOT WERE NOT GETTING FUNDED NOT
CURRENTLY AND RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
ENOUGH ON THE THIRTY TWO PROCESS
IS HEALTH AND SAFETY PROJECTS.
AND EVEN WHEN WE DIDN'T HAVE
PROGRAM FUNDS BEFORE PROP FIFTY
ONE WAS PASSED.
OUT THERE IS RESIDUAL FUNDS EVER
COMING BACK IN THE PROGRAM AS A
RESULT OF COMPLIANCE REVIEWS
RECISIONS AND CLOSEOUTS.
I AM SO AND ACTUALLY PAYMENTS AS
WELL BECAUSE OF SOME COMPONENTS
OF OUR PROGRAM THAT ACTUALLY HAS
A REPAYMENT PROCESS.
AND SO AS PROGRAM FUNDS ARE
COMING IN.
WE WERE ABLE TO.
STILL PROCESS OF HEALTH AND
SAFETY PROJECTS ON A FIRST COME
FIRST.
ORDER BASIS BUT THEY WERE
XCELERATED THAT'S TRUE AND
THAT'S A REGULATION THAT THE
BOARD HAS ADOPTED.
SEVERAL YEARS AGO SO THAT WAS
THAT THE MANNER IN WHICH THEY
WANT TO APPROACH.
PROCESSING ARE PROJECTS.
I I I DID HEAR CONCERN FROM A
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN MY AREA.
THAT HAD BEEN IN LINE.
AND AND THEN WAS NOT.
THE FEAR WAS THAT THEY WOULDN'T.
BE FUNDED BECAUSE OTHER PROJECTS
WOULD TAKE
THE PRESIDENT'S AND SO THEY
WOULD BE. IN LINE ONE YEAR BUT
MAY HAVE DROPPED OFF FOR
FOLLOWING YEARS.
YEAH CURRENTLY WE HAVE
SUFFICIENT BOND AUTHORITY TO
COVER PROJECTS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY IN LINE.
MAYBE AT THAT SCHOOL DISTRICT
MAY BE IN THE AUDIENCE THERE AND
I'M SURE I'M GONNA BE HEARING
FROM THEM. THAT WE HAVE A
MEETING LATER THIS AFTERNOON TO
TALK ABOUT JUST THAT.
.
SO I I HOPE GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PASS.
.
THAT.
NOT SURE IF.
.
YOU KNOW I AND AND I BELIEVE IT
SENATE SAID NO CORRECT.
NO.
VAL VERDE.
HAD EXPRESSED CONCERNS.
.
ON THOSE LINES.
BUT THANK YOU ANDA AND IF THEY
HAVE MORE QUESTIONS WE CAN GET
BACK WITH YOU CRACKS ILLEGALLY.
AND I GUESS THAT'S IT.
ALRIGHT WELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
X. ISSUE IS.
ISSUE FOR
.
WELCOME AND.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
ACTIVE MORNING AGAIN SURELY DIE
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
TWENTY POINT THREE MILLION FOR
THE CHARTER SCHOOL FACILITY
GRANT PROGRAM. PROPOSE
ADDITIONAL TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
THAT WILL CAP THE LEAST GROWTH
AT THE RATE OF COLA FOR THE
PROGRAM. IT ALSO REQUIRES
INDEPENDENT APPRAISAL SPRING YOU
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND SCHOOLS ARE
EXISTING BUT EXPANDING
FACILITIES. WHILE ALSO PRIOR TO
RAISING.
LEASE COSTS FOR OTHER MEANS
OVER OTHER MAINTENANCE COSTS
WHEN THE PROGRAM IS
OVERSUBSCRIBED.
IT ALSO ELIMINATES THE BACK THE
REQUIREMENT TO FIND PRIOR COSTS
WITH THE CURRENT YEAR
APPROPRIATION. ANY PROPOSED
INTEND TO ALIGN FUNDING WITH A
PROJECTED PROGRAMMATIC
PARTICIPATION WHILE ALSO
ENSURING THAT LIMITED FUNDING IS
SUPPORTED BY ACTUAL COSTS THAT
REFLECT CURRENT MARKET RATES.
WITHOUT OF HAPPY TAKING
QUESTIONS.
THEY COULD.
WE'RE GONNA IT JUST DOESN'T STOP
FOR A MINUTE TO TAKE A VOTE.
VOTING ON AND ISSUES ONE INTO
THE VOTE ON THE CALENDAR.
MEDINA AYE.
O'DONNELL.
WHEN MORE.
THEY LIKE IT.
IF YOU'D LIKE TO LEPROSY.
YEAH GOOD MORNING BRIAN ANDERSON
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE SOON. AS AS FINANCES
NOTED THE SEXUALLY.
.
THE SOMEWHAT OF A COMPLICATED
PROPOSAL THERE'S A LOT OF PIECES
TO IT BAKING THEY SORT OF BREAK
DOWN INTO TWO.
AREAS ONE IS WHAT DO YOU WANT
THIS PROGRAM TO LOOK LIKE GOING
FORWARD IN AND TO IS HOW MUCH
WILL THAT COST.
I'D SAY DEAL WITH THE ODD COST
ISSUE FIRST
OF THE KIDS THAT THE BIG TICKET
ITEM HERE. O. WE DO THINK THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
OF.
TWENTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR
AUGMENTATION A UNDERSTATES THE
LIKELY COST A PRESSURES IN THIS
PROGRAM WE THINK.
IT AGAIN IT DEPENDS ON EXACTLY
HOW YOU STRUCTURE THE PROGRAM
HOW MUCH IT WILL COST.
BUT UNDER THE EXISTING RULES FOR
THE PROGRAM WE EXPRESSED A MATE
THEN.
I LOVE SOMEWHERE AROUND A FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR AUGMENTATION
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO FULLY FUND
THE PROGRAM IN THE NEXT YEAR.
NOW IN PART THAT'S DUE TO A
CHANGE THAT THIS BODY MADE VERY
LATE IN THE PROCESS DURING LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET.
WHERE WE INCREASE THE MAXIMUM
AWARD ALLOCATION THAT GRANTEES
COULD RECEIVE SO IT USED TO BE
THAT UNDER THIS PROGRAM?
CHARTER SCHOOLS COULD RECEIVE UP
EITHER SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT OF
THEIR LEASE ANOTHER FACILITY
COSTS OR A MAXIMUM OF AND FIFTY
DOLLARS. PER STUDENT
MAXIMUM HAD BEEN SET IN LOSS
SINCE TWO THOUSAND ONE HAD NOT
BEEN UPDATED IT IT INITIALLY
PAN.
AYE CAP ON REALLY
EXTRAORDINARILY EXPENSIVE.
PLACEMENTS BUT OVER TIME WITH
INFLATION AND GONE TO THE POINT
WHERE EVEN CHARTER SCHOOLS THAT
HAD BELOW AVERAGE FACILITY COSTS
WERE CAPPED AT THAT SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY LEVEL WERE NOT
RECEIVING THE SEVENTY FIVE
PERCENT. IN SO THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSED AND LAST
YEAR'S MAY REVISE AND THE
LEGISLATURE ENDED UP ADOPTING
THIS PROPOSAL. THAT WE
RETROACTIVELY ADJUSTED UPWARDS
FOR THE COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT AND K. TWELVE
PROGRAMS AND APPLIED THAT COLA
GOING FORWARD. THAT INCREASES
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY CAP TO A
LITTLE LESS THAN TWELVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER EIGHTY AIM.
AND THAT RESULTED AND A PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN THE COST
OF THIS PROGRAM AND WE THINK
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
THIS PROGRAM WILL BE MORE
EXPENSIVE THAN THE
ADMINISTRATION.
UGH PROJECTS GOING FORWARD.
HOWEVER EVEN IF.
THE LEGISLATURE WERE TO RESEND
THAT MAXIMUM A.
THE EGGMAN GRANT AWARD INCREASE
THAT AND ADOPTED LAST YEAR GO
BACK TO THE HISTORICAL SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS.
PER STUDENT CAP WE THINK THIS
PROGRAM WOULD STILL REQUIRE AN
EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR
AUGMENTATION JUST TO FULLY FUND
AND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
BUT NOW TO DEAL WITH THE OTHER
ASPECTS OF THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL THEY MAKE SEVERAL.
ADJUSTMENTS TO THE PROGRAM IN
PART TO ADDRESS SOME OF THESE
COST PRESSURES.
A AM ONE OF THEIR PROPOSALS WE
THINK IS IS REASONABLE AND WE WE
RECOMMEND APPROVING IT IT IT
WOULD REMOVE THIS LANGUAGE THAT.
PROVIDES AN AUTOMATIC BACK FILL
FOR PRIOR YEAR AWARD SO. WHAT
HAPPENS UNDER CURRENT A LOT
RIGHT NOW WITH THIS PROGRAM IS
THAT WHEN IT'S OVER SUBSCRIBED
THE AD AS IS THE CASE AND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN?
ALL RECIPIENTS RECEIVE A PRO
RATED AWARDS OF RIGHT NOW.
RECIPIENTS ARE EXPECTED TO
RECEIVE ABOUT EIGHTY PERCENT OF
THEIR ELIGIBLE AWARD AMOUNT.
UNDER CURRENT LAW.
ANY ALLOCATION THAT WAS GIVEN TO
THIS PROGRAM NEXT YEAR WOULD
FIRST BE USED
TO GET ALL OF THOSE RECIPIENTS
UP TO ONE HUNDRED PERCENT SO.
SAY IF THERE'S A TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS SHORTFALL THE
FIRST TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT YOU ALLOCATE TO
THIS PROGRAM EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
WILL GO TO THAT PROGRAM.
THAT LANGUAGE IS UNUSUAL WE
DON'T TREAT ANY OTHER K. TWELVE
CATEGORICAL PROGRAM IN THIS FAT.
FASHION AND IT EXISTS FOR A VERY
SPECIFIC HISTORICAL REASON WHICH
WAS A TRANSITION THAT THE
PROGRAM WENT THROUGH SEVERAL
YEARS AGO AND HAS SINCE BEEN.
PLEADED WENT WE THINK IT'S OUT
OF DATE AND RECOMMEND.
APPROVING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO REMOVE IT. ON WE DO
KNOW THAT IF THE LEGISLATURE'S
CONCERNED.
ABOUT.
THE PROBATION IN THE CURRENT
YEAR AWARD CA CAN FOLLOW THE
PRACTICE THAT OCCASIONALLY
FOLLOWS WITH OTHER CATEGORICAL
PROGRAMS OF PROVIDING A
DISCRETIONARY ONE TIME BACKFILL.
AND THE OTHER THREE.
CHANGES THAT THE ADMINISTRATION.
RECOMMENDS MAKING TO THE PROGRAM
O. WE IT WE JUST DON'T THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROVIDED A
COMPELLING JUSTIFICATION FOR SO
AND THIS INCLUDES. A CAPPING A
THE.
GROWTH AND REDUCE COSTS THAT CAN
BE CLAIMED FOR THE AWARD AT THE
K. TWELVE COLA LEVEL. OF WHEN WE
THINK THIS IS UNNECESSARY
ALREADY APPLICANTS HAVE TO PAY
AT LEAST TWENTY FIVE PERCENT OF
THEIR LEASE COSTS A UNDER THIS
PROGRAM WE THINK THAT'S.
A POWERFUL INCENTIVE IN MOST
CASES TO KEEP THOSE THESE COSTS
LOW. THAT BIG CONCERN HERE AS WE
UNDERSTAND IT IS SPECIFIC TO
CHARTER SCHOOLS THAT HAVE. A
CONFLICT OF INTEREST WHERE THEIR
LANDLORD ALSO SERVES ON THE
CHARTER SCHOOLS BOARD MAKE SOME
FACILITY DECISIONS IN THOSE
CASES PERHAPS THE CHARTER SCHOOL
HAS AN INCENTIVE TO OVERSTATE
THEIR FACILITY COSTS MUST GET A
MORE GENEROUS GRANT FROM THE
STATE. OF IT WE THINK THAT THAT
CAN BE ADDRESSED JUST BY GIVING
THE SCHOOL FINANCE AUTHORITY
SOME OF BROADER DISCRETION TO
REQUIRE INDEPENDENT LEASE
APPRAISALS WHEN THEY CREDIBLY
SUSPECT THAT A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST EXISTS.
THE OTHER. THE PROPOSAL HERE
WOULD BE.
.
DIFFERENTIAL TREATMENT OF LEASE
COSTS IN OTHER FACILITY BECAUSE
SOME OF THE PROGRAM AND BE.
PRIORITIZING LEASE BECAUSE
OVER MAINTENANCE COSTS OF OR
BUILDING IMPROVEMENT COSTS IN
YEARS IN WHICH THE PROGRAM IS
OVERSUBSCRIBED WE WE DO THINK
THAT THERE'S A LOGIC HERE THAT
THE INTENT OF THE PROGRAM WAS
PRIMARILY TO HELP. CHARTER
SCHOOLS WITH THEIR LEASE COSTS.
AND YOU KNOW ALL SCHOOLS DEAL
WITH COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
MAINTENANCE AND BUILDING
IMPROVEMENTS IN MOST CASES THIS
IS.
PROVIDED OUT THERE GENERAL
PURPOSE FUNDING WE THINK IDEALLY
CHARTER SCHOOLS WOULD DO THE
SAME. BUT IN PRACTICE WE THINK
IT'S GOING TO BE DIFFICULT TO
DISENTANGLE THAT FROM THESE
COSTS BECAUSE OFTENTIMES. LEASES
AND INCLUDE A LANDLORD PROVIDED
MAINTENANCE OR BUILDING
IMPROVEMENTS SO AND SO FOR THAT
REASON WE PROJECT THAT WE
RECOMMEND REJECTING THAT
PROPOSALS WITH.
THANK YOU CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
FINANCE AUTHORITY.
YEAH HERE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS MY
NAME'S KATRINA JOE HANSHIN ON
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL FINANCE
AUTHORITY AND WITH ME TODAY IS
IAN DAVIS HE'S THE.
CO PROGRAM LEAD OVER THE SB
SEVEN FORTY PROGRAM. THANK YOU.
.
I DON'T BELIEVE THERE ARE ANY
QUESTIONS SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
IF YOU.
WE ARE GOING TO SKIP ITEM SIX.
SPECIAL EDUCATION.
AND.
REFERRED TO IT IN YOUR AGENDA.
AND WE ARE GOING TO GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT.
TYPE.
NO DRAMATICALLY.
IT.
SO IF YOU WOULD PLEASE A KEEP IT
TO.
ONE MINUTE THAT UP THAT I'LL BE
OF A QUICK JOHN WHEN YOU'RE OF
THE OF THE CALIFORNIA CHARTER
SCHOOL ASSOCIATION.
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE TWENTY
POINT THREE MILLION.
IN ONGOING FUNDING WOULD ALSO.
SUPPORT AN ADDITIONAL ONE TIME
FUNDING OF OF TWENTY FIVE
MILLION THIS YEAR TO ENSURE THAT
THE PROGRAM IS FULLY FUNDED.
ALSO WOULD AGREE WITH THE LA O.
ON REJECTING.
SOME OF THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE
REGARDING THE AUTOMATIC BACK
FILL.
WE THINK IF THE LEGISLATURE DID
DECIDE TO ELIMINATE THE
AUTOMATIC RIFLE THAT IS QUITE A
NEXT YEAR NOT CURRENT YEAR.
SO THE SCHOOLS DON'T FACE A CUT.
INTO THIS YEAR THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MARY
SAMPLES ASSISTANT SUPERINTENDENT
FROM VENTURA COUNTY I WAS ALSO
THE CHAIR OF THE FISCAL
SUBCOMMITTEE OF THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION TASK FORCE.
THE TWENTY SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
VENTURA COUNTY SUPPORT THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION FISCAL
RECOMMENDATIONS OUTLINED IN THAT
TASK FORCE REPORT. WE SEE THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AS CRUCIAL AS A
CRUCIAL PRIORITY FOR VENTURA
COUNTIES EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES THEIR
FAMILIES AND OUR TWENTY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WE RISK RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTS FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS TO BEGIN PHASING IN A.
B.. THIRTY ONE THIRTY SIX WHICH
WOULD IMPLEMENT THE TASK FORCE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND I ALSO WANT
TO SAY ON BEHALF OF MARINE
BURNOUTS AND VICKI BARBER THE
TWO DIRECTORS WHO COULDN'T BE
HERE TODAY. THEY ARE IN FULL
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS INTERNET
PELLETIER IN THE SENIOR
ADMINISTRATOR FIRST I'M SAN
MATEO COUNTY SILVA AND I'M ALSO
THE ONE OF THE CO CHAIRS OF
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE FOR THE
STATE SELF ADMINISTRATORS OF
CALIFORNIA. THE THIRTY ELEAZAR
CEMETERY COUNTY ALONG WITH THE
STATE'S HEALTH ASSOCIATION VERY
MATURE IN SUPPORT OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE STATE BY
TASK FORCE FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION.
AND WERE VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY SIX AND WE
WOULD ALSO RECOMMEND A THREE
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION INITIAL
INVESTMENT IN SPECIAL EDUCATION
EQUALIZATION AS RECOMMENDED BY
THE LA O. INCLUDED IN THE BILL.
IT WOULD DEFINITELY HAVE A VAST
IMPACT ON THE MANY STUDENTS IN
BOTH MY COUNTY AND IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON NANCY LOW COST
AND I'M REPRESENTING THE
COALITION FOR ADEQUATE FUNDING
FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION AND WE'VE
BEEN DOING A LOT OF WORK IN THE
AREA OF SPECIAL EDUCATION WE
ALSO.
CALL TWO ON THE PROVIDING AT
LEAST A MINIMUM OF FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION AND ONGOING FUNDING TO
IMPLEMENT THE TASK FORCE REPORT
THANK YOU.
ERIC PREMAXILLA CHARTER SCHOOLS
DEVELOPMENT CENTER WE LIKE THE
LA US APPROACH TO THE BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE ON THE CHARTER
FACILITIES ITEM AND.
DOING WHATEVER IS POSSIBLE TO.
BACK FILL THE DEFICIT IN THAT
ITEM BOTH IN THE CURRENT YEAR
AND THEN THE BUDGET YEAR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS WILLIAM ME I'M THE
PRINCIPAL A COMMUNITY HIGH
SCHOOL I'M SPEAKING I'M I'M ITEM
FOR. WE'RE A SMALL COMMUNITY
SCHOOL LOCATED IN EAST OAKLAND
BE SERVING NINETY ONE PERCENT
FREE REDUCED LUNCH AND NINETY
FIVE PERCENT OF OUR STUDENTS ARE
FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE.
EDUCATION IS PUTTING TREMENDOUS
PRESSURE ON OUR COMMUNITY I HAVE
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES THAT ARE
STRUGGLING TO SURVIVE AND PAY
RENT. I GOT HOBBY WHO IS.
SLEEPING IN HIS FAMILY'S LIVING
ROOM BECAUSE HIS UNCLE'S FAMILY
HAS MOVED INTO HIS BEDROOM AND I
HAVE TEACHERS WHO ARE DRIVING IN
FROM THE A HELLO ANTIOCH TO COME
MY SCHOOL BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
AFFORD TO LIVE CLOSE TO OUR
SCHOOL. EVEN THOUGH WE SERVE
SOME THE MOST DISADVANTAGED
STUDENTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WE'VE BEEN OPERATING
FOR FOURTEEN YEARS AN OLD CHURCH
IN EAST OAKLAND WILL USE SB
SEVEN FORTY TO HELP PAY FOR
LEASE AND WE NEED THOSE
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT SUCCESS FOR
STUDENTS. AND A LIVING WAGE FOR
TEACHERS SO ON POLICE SUPPORT SB
SEVEN FORTY PLEASE CONTINUE
FUNDING. IF WE LOSE TEN PERCENT
OF THE FUNDING THAT'S ABOUT.
THE SALARY FOR SCHOOL SOCIAL
WORKER SO WILL HAVE A SEVERE
IMPACT ON A COMMUNITY THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
GOOD MORNING ANTHONY WILSON TO
SPEAK ON ITEM FOR.
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF AB
EXECUTING GET REFER KIT BAY AREA
SCHOOLS SPEAKING AND SUPPORT OF
A SB SEVEN FORTY.
FOR THOSE IT HAS BEEN A
CHALLENGE FOR US.
AND IT'S BEN THAT KIND OF
DEFINING INEQUITY OF FOR OUR
SCHOOLS THAT WE FACE.
WE SERVE ABOUT EIGHTY PERCENT
PRODUCED ON STUDENTS AND NINETY
SEVEN PERCENT OF OUR STUDENTS
ARE STUDENTS OF COLOR AYE SB
FORTY FUNDS.
HELPS US OFFSET THAT THE
FIFTEEN PERCENT
FIFTEEN PERCENT OF FUNDS THAT WE
HAVE TO ALLOCATE FROM OUR PUBLIC
REVENUE. TO SUSTAIN OUR
FACILITIES HAPPENS OVER TIME TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT IS A LONG TERM
OF THE STRATEGY AND WE DON'T
HAVE THAT IF WE DON'T HAVE THESE
FUNDS.
AND SO WHAT WHAT IT WILL LOOK
LIKE IF THERE'S A TWENTY PERCENT
CUT IN AS BEEF SEVEN FORTY FUNDS
ABOUT WHAT TWENTY INTO HER
DOLLARS PER PUPIL WHICH IS ABOUT
NINETY THOUSAND DOLLARS WHICH
IS.
A TEACHER AND AND SOME HARM SO
WE I AM POOR YOU TO SUPPORT A S.
B. SEVEN FORTY THANK YOU.
GIVE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK I'M PETER STONE THE.
CHIEF BUSINESS OFFICER FOR
RIVER CHARTER SCHOOL SPEAKING ON
ITEM NUMBER FOUR.
OF WE HAVE TO SCHOOLS THAT WE
OPERATE DELTA ELEMENTARY CHARTER
AND LIGHTHOUSE CHARTER SCHOOL IN
THIS AREA I'M HERE TO SUPPORT
THE INCREASE IN FUNDING FOR
CHARTER SCHOOLS.
FACILITY GRANT PROGRAM IN
PARTICULAR AND TO REQUEST FULLY
FUNDING THE CURRENT YEAR
SHORTFALL.
OUR SCHOOLS ARE IN LOS
SOCIOECONOMIC AREAS AND RELY ON
THIS PROGRAM AS WE HAVE HEARD
TIRES EXISTENCE TO PROVIDE
CRITICAL FINANCE THAT FACILITIES
FUNDING AND WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL
FOR THAT FUNDING THAT WE'VE
RECEIVED OVER THE YEARS.
OUR NEW SCHOOL LIGHTHOUSE
CHARTER SCHOOL IS THE LOWEST IN
IN THE LOWEST INCOME
NEIGHBORHOOD IN WEST SACRAMENTO.
WE APPLIED FOR STATE BOND
PROGRAM FUNDS AND WE'RE NOT
SELECTED.
AND SO WE HAD TO DO MORE COSTLY
TAX EXEMPT BUT BOND OFFERING IN
THE PUBLIC ARENA.
WHOSE REPAYMENT COUNTS HEAVILY
ON THE SB SEVEN FORTY PROGRAM.
AND WE'RE ASKING THE LEGISLATURE
TO FULLY FUND THE PROGRAM AND
WHERE REQUIRED USE LEFTOVER
FUNDS FROM PRIOR YEARS.
TO FIND ANY DEFICIT IN THE
CURRENT YEAR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JENNIFER BAKER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION I ACTUALLY WANTED TO
COMMENT ON A NUMBER OF BIDEN'S
VERY BRIEFLY I WE APPRECIATE THE
UMP RECOMMENDATIONS THAT THE
LEGISLATIVE. ANALYST'S OFFICE
MAKES IN REGARD TO
DIFFERENTIATED PAY FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION INSTRUCTORS ALTHOUGH
WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT THIS NEEDS
TO TAKE PLACE AT THE STATE LEVEL
BECAUSE IT CAN ALREADY BE
BARGAINED LOCALLY. WE THINK A
MORE ADEQUATE WAY TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE IS TO ADEQUATELY FUND
EDUCATION TO LC FF IN ADDITION
TO EQUALIZE SPECIAL ED PAGE.
ENSURING THAT WERE PROVIDING THE
NECESSARY FUNDS TO ADEQUATELY
SUPPORT OUR SPECIAL ED STUDENTS
FILE WE DO BELIEVE THAT
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES NEED TO
PROVIDE BE PROVIDED IN BOND
FUNDING AND WE.
WE APPRECIATE THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION TO INCREASE THE
FLOW OF THOSE BOND FUNDS AYE WE
DO BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO SEE
AN INCREASE TRANSPARENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY AND OVERSIGHT
PRIOR TO RELEASING FUNDS FOR
CHARTER FACILITY GRANT PROGRAM.
AND THE.
IN ADDITION OVERALL WE DO
SUPPORT A. B. THIRTY ONE THIRTY
SIX AND WE THINK THAT THAT'S
GOING TO BE ONE OF THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAYS TO ENSURE THAT WE
CAN ADDRESS OUR SPECIAL LATE
MEANS.
IN CONJUNCTION WITH.
IN NOT ONLY FULLY FUNDING LC FF
BUT INCREASE THE OVERALL AMOUNT
OF FUNDS THAT WE HAVE TO MAKE
SURE ALL OF OUR STUDENTS ARE
SUPPORTED.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BOB WAGNER ON BEHALF
OF NEWPORT MASON IRVINE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ORANGE COUNTY AND
SARAH AND OAK GROVE AND THE
THOMAS HERE IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY.
A IN SUPPORT OF THE STAFF'S
WONDERFUL RECOMMENDATIONS TO
EXPEDITE FUNDING FOR SCHOOL
FACILITIES. ON THE URGENCY
OBVIOUSLY ON A PERSONAL NOTE FOR
THOSE KIDS WHO WILL NEVER AGAIN
HAVE A CHANCE TO ACCESS THE
FACILITIES ONCE.
THE TIME IS GONE IN THEY'VE
MOVED ON THAT'S OBVIOUSLY
IMPORTANT BUT PRACTICALLY.
THINGS ARE NOT GETTING CHEAPER
AND CONSTRUCTION OF OF THE COST
OF MONEY IS GOING NOWHERE BUT UP
AND THE INFLATION ON BUILDING
THE SCHOOLS IS GOING CRAZY WITH
SOME OF THE UP EMBARGOES OF SOME
OF THE THINGS THAT WERE SEEN.
FINALLY AS FAR AS THE
PRACTICALITY OF OF EXPANDING OUR
CAPACITY
A PROCESS THESE THINGS YOU KNOW
THE MONEY COMES FROM THE BONDS
THEMSELVES.
SO IT'S IT'S NOT A ZERO SUM GAME
WE DO HAVE RESOURCES AND AS FAR
AS THE HUMAN ELEMENT.
BACK IN THE EARLY NINETIES WE
FACED SOMETHING LIKE THIS AND
OPSEC. CONTRACTED OUT WITH THE
SET UP WITH THE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE TO GET FIVE F. T. E. TO
HELP THEM OUT. SO YOU KNOW IF WE
BELIEVE AS WE DO THAT THIS IS A
CRISIS UP I THINK THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF WAYS THAT WE CAN
RESOLVE IT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IF.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS CHRIS WALKER ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SHEET METAL.
CONDITIONING CONTRACTORS WERE
HERE TO LEND OUR SUPPORT ON
ISSUE NUMBER THREE ON SCHOOL
FACILITIES. GETTING THE MONEY
OUT EARLY AS GOING TO BE A LOT.
MORE ECONOMICAL FOR THE STATE A
CALIFORNIA THESE ARE REAL JOBS.
AND CONTINUING TO DELAY THE
CELL OF THESE BONDS ONLY
INCREASES THE COST FOR THE
TAXPAYER. WE'RE ALSO VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT THAT WE NEED NEW
FACILITIES WE NEED RETROFIT.
FACILITIES WE NEED TO FOCUS ON
INDOOR AIR QUALITY. ON ALL THIS
CANNOT BE DONE UNTIL WE SELL
THOSE BONDS A START ADDRESSING
THE HUGE BACKLOG THAT WE'RE
CURRENTLY EXPERIENCING.
SO WE WOULD LEND OUR SUPPORT TO
GETTING THESE BONDS OUT SOONER
RATHER THAN LATER THANK YOU.
IS A CABINET MEMBERS.
J'AI SURPRISE SUIT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION WE REPRESENT TO AND
FORTY THOUSAND CLASSIFIES TO
EMPLOYEES IN OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS
AND COLLEGES.
AND I'M HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF MORE FUNDING FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION AB DID ONE THIRTY SIX.
IS A BILL THAT WOULD PROVIDE
SACHA INCREASE IN FUNDING.
AND WE CAN APPRECIATE THE FOCUS
ON TEACHERS ON TO STRUGGLE TO
TRY TO GET MORE BUT. PLEASE
RECOGNIZE DOCTOR CLASSIFIED
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ARE ARTISTS
ADULTS WHO ARE AT THE FRONTLINE
AND MANY CASES AND WE WOULD ASK
THAT. THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
BEYOND JUST IT'S TO ALLOW THE
ELIGIBLE ELIGIBILITY.
A PARA PROFESSIONAL IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION TO BE RECRUITED
RETRAIN.
AND WE WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
THE COMMITTEE AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF RECOGNIZING THAT CLASSIFY
STAFF. ARGUE FRONTLINE FOLKS WHO
WORK WITH THESE CHILDREN AND WE
WOULD SUGGEST THAT YOU KNOW AS
WE MAKE A FIFTEEN PERCENT OF
THOSE THEIR LOCAL BUDGET. THAT
UP TO FIFTEEN PERCENT BE SET
ASIDE FOR CLASSIFIED SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES PUT THOSE KINDS OF
RETENTION.
OUR AND RECRUITMENT EFFORT AND
FINALLY.
WE ALSO WOULD URGE YOU TO SET
ASIDE WE HAD SUGGESTED A HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS. IN ONE
TIME FUNDS IT'S A GOOD USE OF
ONE TIME FUND FOR PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND ALL THESE AREA.
IN SPECIAL EDUCATION WE HEALTH
OF STAFF AND MEMBERS WHO ARE A
LITTLE BE BITTEN OR SCRATCH AND
THEY NEED TO LEARN TO B TRAINED
ON HOW TO ADDRESS.
CRITICALLY WITH KIDS WHO WERE.
YOU KNOW HAVE ARTISTIC JOB.
A NEEDS AND CHALLENGES ARE AND
FINALLY A WE THINK THEY'RE
PROFESSIONAL DILEMMAS MUCH
NEEDED FOR SCHOOL SAFETY ISSUES.
I BELIEVE THAT.
MISSED ASSEMBLYMAN RODRIGUEZ
HAS A BILL SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN
DATA DRESSED DOES ISSUE IT'S A
GOOD USE OF ONE TIME FUNDS AND
WE THINK YOU CAN SET IT ASIDE
FOR MULTI YEAR TO BE ABLE TO DO
THAT. WE ALL SHOULD TO DO THOSE
THINGS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU.
THEY ARE ABACHA'S OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS IN SUPPORT OF
THE ALEJO'S RECOMMENDATION TO
ESTABLISH A FACILITIES BOND
EXPENDITURE PLAN AND DECREASE
THE BOND AUTHORITY FOR THAT THE
STATE.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
YEAR TO THREE BILLION DOLLARS TO
FUND PROJECTS ON UNFUNDED LESS
CASTLES ALSO A STRONG SUPPORTER
OF AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY SIX AS A
CO SPONSOR WE BELIEVE THAT IT'S
ONE OF OUR TOP PRIORITIES TO
ENSURE THAT OUR STUDENTS.
SPECIAL YOUR SPECIAL NEEDS
STUDENTS HAVE ALL THE SUPPORT
POSSIBLE THINK YOU.
GOOD MORNING REBEKAH CURLY ON
BEHALF OF THE COALITION FOR
ADEQUATE SCHOOL HOUSING AND THE
COUNTY SCHOOL FACILITIES
CONSTRUED CONSORTIUM. HERE TO
SPEAK TO ON THE SCHOOL
FACILITIES ITEM WE BELIEVE THAT
SIX HUNDRED FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS WHICH IS THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO SELL IN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN IS NOT IMPLEMENTING THE
WILL OF THE VOTERS.
TO DATE ONLY ABOUT EIGHT PERCENT
OF THE FUNDS THAT WERE
AUTHORIZED BY PROPOSITION FIFTY
ONE HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN PROVIDED
TO PROJECTS
WE CURRENTLY HAVE A BACKLOG OF
THREE POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS IN PROJECTS.
THESE ARE PROJECTS THAT HAVE HAD
THEIR PLANS APPROVED BY THE
DIVISION OF THE STATE ARCHITECT
THEY HAVE ALSO HAD THEIR PLANTS
REVIEWED. AND APPROVED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION FOR THEIR EDUCATIONAL
ADEQUACY ANOTHER WAITING FOR THE
FINAL APPROVAL AT THE OFFICE OF
PUBLIC SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION AND
THE FUNDING.
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH A
GROUP A LARGE COALITION AND WE
ARE ASKING TO INCREASE THE SIZE
OF THE PONDS ON OUT. IN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN TO THREE BILLION
DOLLARS AND TO ALSO FUND THREE
BILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
PROJECTS IN THE FISCAL YEAR. AS
FAR AS THE COSTS GO WE BELIEVE
THAT IT WOULD BE ABOUT A TWENTY
MILLION DOLLAR INCREASE ON DEBT
SERVICE BUT AS A PRIOR SPEAKER
MENTIONED MOST OF THE COSTS ARE
BOND FUNDS. SO WE THINK THAT THE
PRICE IS RELATIVELY SMALL
COMPARED TO THE PRICE OF DELAY
AND THE DECREASED PURCHASING
POWER THAT YOU ADOPT.
LASTLY WE AGREE WITH ALEJO AND
THEIR ANALYSIS THE YOU CAN
PROCESS MORE OF THESE
APPLICATIONS WITH THE EXISTING
STOPPED OPSEC. AND UP ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA I WILL FOLLOW UP
WITH YOU WITH ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION ON COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AS I REPRESENT THEM AS
WELL THINK THANK YOU.
ANA FERREIRA WITH THE SCHOOL
ENERGY COALITION ALIGNING
OURSELVES WITH THE COALITION FOR
ADEQUATE SCHOOL HOUSING IN
COSMOS COMMENTS TODAY. ENERGY
EFFICIENCY SCHOOLS ARE GOING TO
BE THE MOST ENERGY EFFICIENT AND
HISTORY WE NEED THIS MONEY TO GO
OUT.
IT'S IMPORTANT BECAUSE OF THE
COST INCREASES DUE TO SOME OF OF
THE LABOR AND ENERGY ISSUES THAT
ARE GOING ON RIGHT NOW SCHOOLS
WANT TO BE MORE RESILIENT. IN A
LIGHT OF RECENT NATURAL
DISASTERS THEY'RE BECOMING MORE
OF FREQUENT AND.
GOOD SCHOOL FACILITIES WILL HELP
US.
MAKE THEM SO SO WE APPRECIATE
THAT WE WANT TO SEE. THAT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS GO UP THIS YEAR.
GOOD MORNING DARYN WATERS DIPPY
SUPERINTENDENT ROBERT UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
MEDINA WILL ALL ADDRESS YOUR
QUESTION THAT YOU ASKED STAFF TO
DATE WERE UNABLE TO DO.
YES
BY NOT SELLING MORE PROFIT YOU
IN BONDS IT IS SLOWING DOWN. THE
FLOW OF FUNDS TO COMMITTEE
COLLEGES AS WELL AS KATE TWELVE.
THERE IS IT THAT SHE WAS TALK
ABOUT AUTHORIZATION WAS
AUTHORIZATION IS TO. DO THE
PROJECTS APPROVE THOSE PROJECTS
BUT THERE'S NO CASH.
TO BUILD IT INTO INTO FUNDED
THAT COMES FROM THE BOND SALE.
SO YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT IN THAT
MANNER ARE PROJECTS WILL BE
SLOWED DOWN AND PUSHED BACK
YEARS. IT GOES BACK TO WHAT
MISS.
KUN SAID ABOUT HOW HOW LONG YOU
WANT THE PROGRAM TO BE TWO ONE
FIVE YEAR PROGRAM AT TWELVE YOUR
PROGRAMMER TWENTY FIVE YEAR
PROGRAM.
FOR THIS THIS DIED THE NINE
BILLION DOLLARS FOR PROP FIFTY
ONE.
ADDITIONALLY ESCALATION IS
EATING INTO INTO THOSE COSTS IS
EXPLAINED BY ANOTHER.
SPEAKER BUT WHAT WE'RE SEEING
IS EIGHT TO TEN PERCENT ANNUALLY
COST INCREASE SO FOR HER HER
MILLION DOLLAR HEISTS HER
MILLION DOLLAR HIGH SCHOOL. AS
CAUSING AN ADDITIONAL EIGHT TO
TEN MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR
THAT WE WAIT FOR THIS MONEY TO
COME AND THAT IS A STAFFING
ISSUE OPSEC I CAN ASSURE YOU. I
GOTTA BELIEVE THEY'RE NOT MAKING
THAT MUCH MONEY WE'D SAVE
TREMENDOUS ON MONEY BY HIRING
STAFFING THEM UP.
SO WE'RE NOT PAYING THE COST IN
A CONSTRUCTION.
ANOTHER ITEM SIX EQUALIZATION
WERE IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY ONE THIRTY SIX.
EQUALIZATION IS THE THE THE
LEVELING THE PLAYING FIELD FOR
OUR SPECIAL ED. OF FUNDING AB
SIX OR TWO DOLLARS ANYTHING THAT
GOES IN AB SIX OF TO. A DOLLAR
FOR DOLLAR WILL HELP DISTRICTS
OF REDUCE DURING CROTCH MEANT.
THAT IT ALL DISTRICTS ARE FACING
WITH ADDITIONAL COSTS CONTINUE
TO ESCALATE THANKS FOR TIME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
THERE'S JEFF BACA REPRESENTING
THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS IN THE
TWENTY THREE SCHOOL DISTRICT
SUPERINTENDENTS IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY. ON SCHOOL FACILITIES I
WOULD SIMPLY ALIGN MYSELF WITH
THEIR PREVIOUS COMMENTS ABOUT
THE NEED TO ACCELERATE THE RATE
OF EXPENDITURE AND GETTING THE
BOND DOLLARS OUT.
AND THEN ON SPECIAL EDUCATION.
WE BELIEVE THAT THAT SPECIAL
EDUCATION FINANCE IS PROBABLY
THE LAST
MAYBE NOT THE LAST BUT THE
BIGGEST.
A IN GAP OF INEQUITY IN TERMS OF
FUNDING AYE IN EDUCATION IN
CALIFORNIA AND THAT GAP IS
GROWING. SO WE WOULD SUPPORT ANY
ALLOCATION ANY ACTION THAT THE
ASSEMBLY WOULD TAKE. UP WITH
RESPECT TO SPECIAL LOOK AT
EDUCATION EQUALIZATION THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MEDINA SOME OF
MATTER MURATSUCHI THANK YOU FOR
REMAINING.
ON I'M HERE TODAY MICHAEL HOLE
SIZE ON BEHALF OF THE FORTY
SEVEN SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN KERN
COUNTY WE SERVE ABOUT A HUNDRED
NINETY THOUSAND STUDENTS.
AND I LIKE TO SPEAK DIRECTLY TO
ITEM NUMBER SIX.
I'D LIKE TO PLACE ITEM NUMBER
SIX IN THE ISSUE OF EQUITY THAT
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
APPROPRIATELY IDENTIFIES IN THE
CONTEXT OF ACTION THAT YOU'VE
ALREADY SUPPORTED WHICH IS FULL
FUNDING OF LCF AFFAN ALL LCF OF
TARGETS.
AS MR MARKET JUST MENTIONED.
SPECIAL ED INEQUITY.
IS THE GREATEST SINGLE INEQUITY
THAT EXISTS IN OUR FUNDING IN
CALIFORNIA.
POSSIBLE EXCEPTION OF HOMESCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION FOR SOME
DISTRICTS.
OUR OUR DISTRICTS ARE VERY
GRATIFIED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION'S FULLY FUNDING
TWO YEARS EARLY OF LCF TARGETS.
THAT SUPPLEMENTAL INS AND
CONCENTRATION MONEY BRINGS ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS INTO KERN COUNTY.
WE HAVE TREMENDOUS NEEDS ARE OF
DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS AND KERN.
THE PROBLEM OF SPECIAL ED
INEQUITY.
COMES TO ABOUT TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN KERN COUNTY
THAT'S ABOUT TEN PERCENT OF
THEIR SUPPLEMENTAL IN
CONCENTRATION GRANT.
IN CURRENT.
SO THE FACT THAT THIS INEQUITY
EXISTS AND CONTINUES TO EXIST
IT DIMINISHES THAT UNDERMINES
THE ABILITY OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND KERN. REALLY TOOK TO TO MEET
THAT THAT THE GOALS AND THE
PROMISE OF LC FF SO AS MISTER
BLOCKAGES SAID WE WOULD
CERTAINLY SUPPORT ANYTHING THIS
COMMITTEE COULD DO.
ALONG THE LINES OF SUPPORTING
MR O'DONNELL SPILL IN PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR SPECIAL
ED EQUITY IN EQUALIZATION THANK
YOU.
MR MEMBERS MY DILLON REPRESENT
THE SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION ECHOING THE SENTIMENTS
OF OTHERS WE WOULD ALSO SUPPORT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
EQUALIZING SPECIAL EDUCATION AS
WELL AS THE SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
ONE THIRTY SIX.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING RICHARD LIONEL
BEHALF OF THE ESTATE RESIDENTIAL
BUILDERS AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPERS THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION ON
ITEM THREE. WERE HERE JUST.
ENCOURAGES. INCREASE THE SALE
OF PROPOSITION FIFTY ONE BONDS
OVER AND ABOVE WHAT THE GOVERNOR
HAS IN THE BUDGET. IN ADDITION
TO THE COMMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE HERE TODAY ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF MEETING THE
BACKLOG.
FOR ABOUT MODERNIZATION IN NEW
CONSTRUCTION
THE FAILURE TO.
ADEQUATELY PROVIDE FOR SCHOOL
FACILITIES HAS A HUGE IMPACT ON
THE ABILITY OF THE STATE TO MEET
ITS HOUSING GOALS AS WELL. AND
SO LET ME TELL YOU WHY IN AREAS
WHERE WE HAVE GROWTH AND WHERE
HOUSING IS BEING BUILT. IT IS
VERY COMMON FOR MASTER
MITIGATION AGREEMENTS TO BE IN
PLACE BETWEEN THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND DEVELOPERS AND
THOSE MASTER MITIGATION
AGREEMENTS REQUIRE. THE FUNDING
TO BE IN PLACE OFTEN AND THE
SCHOOLS TO BE BUILT BEFORE THOSE
PROJECTS CAN MOVE FORWARD OR
BEFORE THE NEXT PHASE OF THE
PROJECT CAN BE BUILT. SO BY SLOW
WALKING THE.
SAILOR PROPOSITION FIFTY ONE
BARNES
WE'RE NOT ONLY.
IMPACTING THE NEEDS THAT ARE
OUT THERE BUT WE ARE HAVING A
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON THE ABILITY
OF THE STATE COMMUTERS HOUSING
NEEDS.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MARTHA
SIRICO'S IDEAS AND I'M
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR BILINGUAL
EDUCATION AND CALIFORNIANS
TOGETHER. AND I AM HERE WITH OUR
PARTNERS EARLY EDGE ADVANCEMENT
PROJECT AND CHILDREN NOW I AM
SPEAKING I WILL BE SPEAKING ON
ITEM TO TEACHER SUPPORT. WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BUDGET
PROPOSALS WITH REGARDS TO
TEACHER SUPPORT BUT SPECIFICALLY
THE ONE TIME FUNDING OF FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS EACH FOR THE
BILINGUAL TEACHER PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM. AND TO THE
LICENSE CHILD DEVELOPMENT
TEACHER PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
IN ADDITION TO THE ONE TIME
TWELVE MILLION FUNDING FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE E. LA ELT
STANDARDS WITH THE FOCUS ON THE
FIELD THE STANDARDS. AND THE
ENGLISH LEARNER ROADMAP WE
APPRECIATE THE STATE'S CONTINUED
ATTENTION TO OUR NEEDS WITH
REGARDS TO A PREPARED TEACHER
WORKFORCE.
WE'VE HEARD FROM THE FIELD AND
THERE IS A CONTINUED NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR OUR
BILINGUAL TEACHERS FROM
PRESCHOOL. KINDERGARTEN THROUGH
GRADE TWELVE.
OF THESE REQUESTS ARE A MODEST
INVESTMENT BY THE STATE AND SETS
A CLEAR COMMITMENT.
TO CALIFORNIA'S NEW DIRECTION.
OF PROVIDING STUDENTS INCLUDING
OUR ENGLISH LEARNERS AND DUAL
LANGUAGE LEARNER STUDENTS.
OUR ACCESS TO SKILLED TEACHERS
SO THAT THEY CAN PROVIDE QUALITY
INSTRUCTION TO ALL STUDENTS
ESPECIALLY IN MULTI LINGUAL
BILINGUAL PROGRAMS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING AS AFTER MCCARTY
CHILDREN NOW LIKE TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM.
I'M FROM FROM KILEY MARTHA AND
ALSO SPECIFICALLY GOING TO THE
THAT DOUBTS THAT WE HAD AROUND
THE TWELVE MILLION DOLLARS AND
WENT FUNDS FOR THEIR PETITION
THE LA ELT FRAMEWORK IN THE
ENGLISH AND A ROADMAP. AND TO
DATE ELADIO THE IS THE ONLY COR
CONTENT AREA HAS NOT HAD STATE
LEVEL INVESTMENT I'D EITHER FROM
THE STATE OR FROM PHILANTHROPY.
AND WE FELT THIS IS A BIG NEED
THAT'S COMING THROUGH AND WITH
THAT.
THE CURRENT. EARLY HEAD STATUS
OF SIXTY PERCENT OF OF THE
STUDENTS COMING AND WILL WILL
LIKELY BE ENGLISH LEARNERS ME
PREPARE THE STATE STRUCTURE TO
BE TO BE READY FOR THOSE. FOR
THOSE KIDS AND CITIZENS SUPPORT
EDUCATORS ACROSS THE STATE AS
WELL AS SUPPORTING LISTENERS
FOR FUTURE REPORT THANK YOU.
IF YOU.
MORNING I WAS FEW NANOMETERS
SPOTS NOW WITH.
HERE REPRESENTING THE COMPANY
STEM NETWORK.
TO SPEAK ON ISSUED TO.
THAT FOR THE RETENTION OF STEM
EDUCATORS.
CALIFORNIA STEM NETWORK IS.
SPONSORING AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY%
SIX ASSEMBLYMANTHURMAN'S. AND
TO PROVIDE TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS TO SUPPORT PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT STEM SUBJECTS AND TO
EXPAND THE PIPELINE OF TEACHERS.
I'M SO WANTED TO MENTION THAT I
ALSO WANTED TO SAY HERE ON
BEHALF OF CHILDREN NOW SO.
WE SUPPORT THE RESTRICTIONS
PROPOSED ON SPECIAL EDUCATION
THANK YOU.
BUT YOUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS THAT
MY NAME IS RICHARD MCNEIL ON THE
DIRECTOR OF STRATEGIC FINANCE AT
EDUCATION FOR CHANGE. CHARTER
MANAGEMENT ORGANIZATION IN
OAKLAND APPROXIMATELY THREE
THOUSAND STUDENTS.
RANGING FROM GRADE SAID.
T. K. THROUGH EIGHT.
AT SIX DIFFERENT SITES WERE
FOUND IN TWO THOUSAND FIVE HERE
TODAY BECAUSE TO SPEAK
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT.
ISSUE NUMBER FOUR.
WE SUPPORT.
THE INCREASE IN FUNDING FOR
CHARTER SCHOOL FACILITIES GRANT
PROGRAM.
ADDITIONALLY I'M HERE BECAUSE WE
OPPOSE ANY ANY POTENTIAL NEW
RESTRICTIONS. BEING PLACED ON
THE PROGRAM OR THE ELIMINATION
OF THE REQUIREMENT TO BACK FILL
ANY FUNDING BECAUSE WE ARE.
WE NEED OF THE FUNDING ALTHOUGH
MOST OF OUR SCHOOL SITES BENEFIT
FROM A PROP THIRTY NINE
GUARANTEED SPECIFICALLY ONE OF
OUR SITES.
EPIC CHARTER SCHOOL AT RECESS
IS SLATED TO RECEIVE UP TO THREE
HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS OF THAT.
THIS PARTICULAR. SB SEVEN FORTY
MONEY AT AND IF THERE'S A
SHORTFALL LAST PROJECTED WE WILL
LOSE APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS AT THAT SITE.
THAT EQUATES TO ONE FULL TIME
AVERAGE TEACHING POSITION.
ALSO.
WE HAD MAKES A REALLY DIFFICULT
STAFFING DECISIONS FOR FY
NINETEEN BECAUSE OF ALL THE
PERSON STIRS INCREASES AND
HEALTH BENEFIT CONTRIBUTIONS SO.
I WERE FUNDING IS GETTING VERY
DIFFICULT OR HAVING TO START TO
MAKE RISK CUTS TO THE CORE
PROGRAM.
SO ADDITIONALLY I WAS WANTED TO
SAY ONE OTHER THING WHICH IS S.
ISSUE NUMBER THREE WE
SPECIFICALLY ALSO HAVE DEALT
WITH A SCHOOL FACILITIES.
WE RECEIVE PROP WENDY AND
THEY'RE NOW RECIPIENTS OF PROP
FIFTY ONE. AND IT IS THAT THE
DELAY AS OTHERS HAVE MENTIONED
DOES CAUSE US TO HAVE TO GO SEEK
EITHER BRIDGE.
FUND YOU KNOW BRIDGE LOANS TO
CLOSE THE GAP OR WE HAVE TO
DELAY OUR PROGRAM WHERE.
IT IN THE DELAY ITSELF YOU MAY
ACTUALLY BE PAYING MORE THAN
YOU'D PAY FOR THE.
BRIDGE LOAN BECAUSE OF THE COST
INCREASES BECAUSE OF THE DELAY
AND THEN FINALLY A SPECIAL
EDUCATION WE ARE ALL IN. A DIRE
NEED OF ADDITIONAL EDUCATION. OF
FUNDS WE.
WE'D PREFER WE IT'S ROUGHLY
SEVENTEEN PERCENT OF OUR BUDGET
AND A SPECIAL EDUCATION MONEY
THAT RECEIVES ABOUT FIVE PERCENT
OF OUR BUDGET SO WE'RE HAVING TO
COVER A LIVING PERSON OF OUR.
OPERATING BUDGET WITH SPECIAL
EDUCATION.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MR TERM MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE RUN RAMPANT BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS ON A SPEAK SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT THE SPECIAL EDUCATION
PROPOSALS. WE DO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO FUND
EIGHTEEN TO RESIDENCY PROGRAM. A
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS.
HOWEVER WE DO BELIEVE THAT THAT
PROGRAM NEEDS TO BE EXPANDED THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS HAS BEEN A VERY ACTIVE
IN WORKING ON LEGISLATION AND
OTHER POLICIES TO.
NOT ONLY RECRUITMENT RETAIN
TEACHERS IN THE PROFESSION WE
THINK IT'S A CRITICAL ISSUE WE
WERE CO SPONSORS OF THE
CLASSIFIED SCHOOL EMPLOYEE
TEACHER CREDENTIALING PROGRAM.
IT'S PROVEN TO WORK WE WE THINK
THAT WE SHOULD CONTINUE TO
INVEST IN THAT PROGRAM. BUT IT'S
A SYSTEMIC ISSUE AND I THINK.
OUR RECOMMENDATION WOULD BE TO
CONVENE A TASK FORCE THAT
INCLUDES TEACHERS ARE PRACTICING
TEACHERS RETIRED TEACHERS
OTHERS.
A PROSPECTIVE TEACHERS TO TALK
ABOUT WHY IS IT THAT YOU DON'T
WANT TO GO INTO THE PROFESSIONAL
WHY IS IT THAT YOU LEAVE THE
PROFESSION. THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF REASONS LOW PAY CASELOAD WAS
MENTIONED EXCESSIVE PACE.
HOME OF PAPERWORK.
EXCESSIVE ACCOUNTABILITY
ECCENTRIC CENTER I THINK WE NEED
A SYSTEMIC APPROACH TO ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE.
ARE IN ADDITION FINALLY WE WOULD
SUPPORT THE A PROPOSAL TO
EQUALIZE SPECIAL EDUCATION
FUNDING THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
HOW LA MONEY I CANNOT ON BEHALF
OF THE SACRAMENTO CITY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT SPEAKING ON ITEM
SIX TODAY? AT SEXY UNIFIED ABOUT
TWELVE PERCENT OF OUR STUDENT
POPULATION OUR STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES AND YET ARTISTIC
GENERAL FUND CONTRIBUTES ABOUT
SIXTY TWO PERCENT TOWARD
SUPPORTING OUR SPECIAL EDUCATION
PROGRAMS. AND THIS IS BECAUSE.
OF THAT GREAT HISTORICAL
INEQUITIES AB SIX WHAT HE RATES
AS DESCRIBED IN THE ANALYSIS.
SEX CITY UNIFIED GETS ONLY ABOUT
FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHTY TWO
DOLLARS IN AB SUCCESS HE WRITES
ABOUT THE VERY BOTTOM OF THE
SCALE. SO NEEDLESS TO SAY WE
WOULD SUPPORT ANY STATE
INVESTMENTS AND EQUALIZING AB
SIX A TWO RATES ACROSS THE STATE
THANK YOU.
AND TO GET RIGHT WITH THE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN ON ITEM SIX SPECIAL EDUCATION
WE DO WOULD AGREE THAT SPECIAL
EDUCATION AS. UNDERFUNDED.
LA UNIFIED'S* THAT YOU
CONSIDERED DISTRIBUTING FUNDING
BASED ON STUDENT NEED INHERENT
IN THE GOVERNOR'S LCF EVER SEEK
KNOWLEDGE MEN THAT FUNDING TO
STUDENTS WITH DIFFERENT NEEDS.
I IT'S NOT EQUITABLE AND SO WE
WOULD I THINK YOU PRIORITIZE AYE
STUDENT NEED AND THE SEVERITY OF
THE DISABILITIES. ARE AND
FINALLY ON ITEM THREE I WOULD
ALIGN MY COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF
CASH AND CATS BONE SUPPORT OF
THE ELLIOTTS RECOMMENDATION.
OFFER INCREASES IN FUNDING FOR
FACILITIES THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS THERESA THOMAS I CAME ALL THE
WAY DOWN HERE FROM LOS ANGELES.
PORT R. SEIU LOCAL NINETY NINE
MEMBERS WHICH I'M REPRESENTING
AND HAPPY TO BE HERE IN GOOD
SPIRITS.
A I WANT YOU TO RECOGNIZE THE .
B. ISSUE TO SUMMER BILL.
WE DO NEED SUPPORT ON THIS BILL
WE'VE TRIED TO GET IT THROUGH
AND THE IT'S BEEN ALL THE WAY SO
FAR. AND WHAT IT IS IS THAT
DURING THE SUMMERTIME. OUR JULY
AND AUGUST WE FALL SHORT ON THE
BUDGET SO SOME OF US ALONE.
MEMBERS OF SEIU LOCAL NINETY
NINE AND THE REST OF THE.
.
WORKERS FALL SHORT IN MAKING
THEIR ENDS MEET DURING THE
SUMMER SOMETIME THEY OFFER US
TWO HOURS AND SOME MEADOW.
AND SO WHAT WE NEED IS.
OH. WE NEED TO. BE ABLE TO.
AFFORD DURING THE SUMMERTIME
WHEN WE'VE REALLY REALLY FALL
SHORT SOMETIMES I HAVE TO GO IN
MY POCKET.
GO TO THE BANK I HAVE TO GO FIND
ALONE I HAVE TO GO AND BORROW
MONEY FROM PEOPLE IN ORDER TO
MAKE ENDS MEET DURING THE
SUMMER.
SO IF YOU CAN SUPPORT US ON THIS
BILL SP ISSUE TO A LOT OF US ARE
FALLING SHORT. AND WE DO LOVE
OUR KIDS WE WANT TO BE THERE FOR
THEM WE WANT TO HELP THEM DURING
THE SUMMER.
BUT WHEN WE COME BACK TO REGULAR
SCHOOL WE HAVE TO CATCH UP TO
OUR BILLS AND IT'S REALLY
DIFFICULT AND WE HAVE BEEN
TRYING SO HARD. AND WE NEED THE
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL. IF YOU
CAN HELP US WE APPRECIATE IT FOR
LOCAL NINETY NINE YES YEAH YOU
THINK YOU.
IF YOU.
KIMBERLY ROSENBERG WAS SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION
ECHOING TERESA'S COMMENTS ON THE
SUMMER BRIDGE PROPOSAL WE THINK
THIS IS ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY FOR
A CLASSIFIED WORKERS. THEY'RE%
THE BACKBONE TO THE SCHOOLS ARE
OFTEN IN THE BACKGROUND WE'VE
APPROACH THIS ISSUE A NUMBER OF
TIMES WHETHER THROUGH BILLS ARE
BUDGET PROPOSALS IS THE FIRST
HIGH RANKING OF A PILOT PROGRAM.
ELEMENT TO FIVE YEARS TO SEE IF
THAT'S THE BEST WAY TO SOLVE
THIS ISSUE OUR MEMBERS OFF TO GO
HOME HUNGRY FACE HOMELESSNESS
AND RELY ON FOOD BANKS AND
SOCIAL SERVICES TO MAKE IT
THROUGH THE SUMMER MONTHS.
WE ECHO THE SENTIMENTS OF OUR
COLLEAGUES ALSO ON SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING PARA
PROFESSIONAL TRAINING BUT WE
WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT THESE
ISSUES SHOULD BE COMPLETED.
CLASSIFIEDS DESERVE TO NOT HAVE
TO FACE HUNGER IN THE SUMMER
MONTHS AS WELL AS RECEIVE
TRAINING SOME WERE SUPPORTIVE OF
BOTH THE CSEA ASK AS WELL AS I
URGE YOU SUPPORT OUR OWN ASKED
TO CREATE A SAFETY NET FOR
MEMBERS THINK YOU.
YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS PAMELA GIVES
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION I'D
LIKE TO ALIGN MYSELF WITH THE
COMMENTS OF SCHOOL ENERGY
COALITION. CALIFORNIA OF THE
COALITION FOR ADEQUATE SCHOOL
HOUSING AND THE COUNTY SCHOOL
FACILITIES CONSORTIUM ALL ON
ITEM THREE RELATED TO SCHOOL
FACILITIES. WE URGE YOU TO.
CONSIDER THE RECOMMENDATION FROM
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AND EXPEDITE THE FUNDING SO AS
TO AVOID THE DELAYS THAT WERE
MENTIONED TODAY. ALSO ON SPECIAL
EDUCATION WE DO HAVE A SUPPORT
POSITION ON.
AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY SIX AND WE
URGE YOU TO CONTINUE WITH THOSE
PROVISIONS IN THE BILL IN THE
BUDGET WE URGE YOU TO INCREASE
FUNDING FOR A. B. SIX SO TO WE
KNOW THIS IS AN EQUITY ISSUE. WE
ALSO SUPPORT THE VARIOUS OTHER
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL AND URGE
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING RIGHT A MESSIAH
WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATES WE SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS ARE ON
SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHERS OVER
SIXTY PERCENT OF NEW SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHERS ARE
UNDERPREPARED IN OUR STATE. AND
WITH ENGLISH MINERS AND AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS
OVERREPRESENTED IN SPECIALLY
COULD SPECIAL EDUCATION THIS IS
A CIVIL RIGHTS ISSUE. AND WE DO
HAVE SOME CONCERN AROUND THE
LOCAL SOLUTIONS GRANT AND WE
WANT.
THOSE INITIATIVES TO BE
SUSTAINABLE AND TO BE ON THE
RIGHT THE RIGHT SOLUTIONS WHICH
WE WOULD LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO REFINE
THAT PROPOSAL. A WE ALSO SUPPORT
THE.
PROPOSALS IN THE ASSEMBLY
AROUND A RESIDENCIES FOR STEM
AND BILINGUAL PROGRAMS.
AS WELL AS STATE FUNDED SERVICE
SCHOLARSHIPS STATEMENT OF
SERVICE SCHOLARSHIPS GO A LONG
WAY TO.
SUPPORTING LOW INCOME AND
TEACHERS OF COLOR TO ENTER THE
PROFESSION CRITICAL FOR
DIVERSIFYING OURS OUR TEACHER
WORKFORCE.
FINALLY WE.
WE WANT TO SAY THAT THE SHORTAGE
IMPACTS LOWER INCOME STUDENTS ON
DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBERS AND
EDUCATIONAL IMPACT SO ANY OF OUR
INITIATIVES REALLY SHOULD BE
TARGETED TOWARD OUR HIGHEST NEED
STUDENTS THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON ON KAI JACKSON SENDING
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
WE ECHO SOME OF THE COMMENTS OF
THE PREVIOUS SPEAKERS TO
EXPEDITE THE UP PROP FIFTY ONE
FUNDING. AND ALSO TO INCREASE
THE APPORTIONMENT TO.
THREE BILLION DOLLARS FOR
TWENTY EIGHTEEN TWENTY NINETEEN
I LIKE TO KNOW THAT SEND YOU
UNIFIED BECAME THE. FIRST
DISTRICT ARE COUNTY TO ADOPT A
HUNDRED PERCENT RENEWABLE ENERGY
CLIMATE ACTION GOAL BY TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE THAT NOT ONLY HELPS
OUR REGION BUT IT HELPS THE
STATE. MEET OUR MEET THEIR GOALS
TO THAT IN.
THE STATE IS ASKING SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO PROVIDE OUR
STUDENTS WITH A WORLD CLASS
EDUCATION SO THAT THEY CAN
COMPETE ON A GLOBAL ENVIRONMENT.
RIGHT WE WE WOULD REQUEST THAT
THE LEGISLATURE HELP US DO THAT
BY PROVIDING US FUNDS AND
RESOURCES TO PROVIDE WORLD CLASS
FACILITIES.
SOME CLASSROOMS COSTS IN IN THE
HIGH COST OF LIVING REGION LIKE
LIKE SAN DIEGO UP TO FIVE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLARS PER
SQUARE FOOT. IN CERTAIN TYPES OF
TECHNOLOGICALLY ADVANCED LABS
OVER TWELVE HUNDRED DOLLARS PER
SQUARE FOOT.
IT MATTERS.
FUNDING MATTERS WE APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT AND WE PREPARE
PRECIADO DIRECTING EXPEDITION
THOSE.
IF YOU.
GOOD MORNING ANDREA BALL I'M
HERE TO SPEAK ON TWO ISSUES
FIRST ON ITEM THREE ON BEHALF OF
THE ORANGE COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SUBURBAN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY
EDUCATION COALITION WE ASSOCIATE
OURSELVES WITH THE COMMENTS FROM
CASH AND CALLASPO WE'VE BEEN
PART OF THAT COALITION. WORKING
TO ACCELERATE THE.
ADMINISTRATION OF THE BOND
FUNDS
WE THINK THE LA OWES PROPOSAL TO
HAPPEN PLAN FOR FIVE YEARS AND
TO INCREASE STAFFING IS A GOOD
ONE. AND REALLY URGE YOU TO.
.
WORK WITH THE ADMINISTRATION TO
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
BECAUSE AS YOU HEARD THE LONGER
WE WAIT THE HIGHER THE COST.
ON ISSUE SIX ON SPECIAL ED
FUNDING ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGISTS.
PORT THE IT ATTEMPT IN THE
EFFORT TO EQUALIZE THE AB SIX OH
TO SPECIAL ED FUNDING.
ESPECIALLY APPRECIATE
ESTABLISHING A FORMULA OF TO
HELP OUT FUND PRESCHOOLERS WHO
ARE SPECIAL NEEDS THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MARTHA HOURS OF
ABSENT ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS THANK YOU
FOR STILL BEING HERE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT.
ON THREE ITEMS THAT I LIKE TO
SPEAK TO YOU TODAY ABOUT A NOT
ITEM NUMBER TWO REGARDING THE
FUTURE WORKFORCE PROPOSALS. THAT
WE APPRECIATE THE FOCUS ON
SPECIAL EDUCATION AND THE
TEACHER SHORTAGE THAT WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA. HOWEVER WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONTINUE TO LOOK
AT MORE COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTIONS
WE HAVE A LOT OF THE STOMACH Y.
PROBLEMS AND IF YOU HAVE
MENTIONED TO THEY CREDENTIALING
ISSUES. AND SO WE BELIEVE THAT
WE NEED TO COST THAT FURTHER NOT
JUST IN THE FUNDING BUT ALSO IN
IN THOSE SYSTEMIC ISSUES THAT
NEED TO BE RESOLVED.
ON ITEM NUMBER THREE REGARDING
THE SCHOOL FACILITIES AYE WE
ACQUIT THE COMMONS BUT EXPERTS
PRIOR SPEAKERS REGARDING THAT
NEED TO ISSUE MORE BONDS.
WE ALSO SUPPORT THE ISSUANCE OF
THREE BILLION DOLLARS LIKE IT'S
BEEN BROUGHT UP BY PICKUP BY
CASH ANOTHER COALITIONS. OUT WE
BELIEVE THERE'S URGENCY IN
GETTING THOSE FUNDS OUT THINGS
VOTERS DID APPROVED BY PROPERTY
ONE A TWO YEARS AGO. THAT WE
ALSO SUPPORT THE LA A
RECOMMENDATION TO DO A A FIVE
YEAR SCHEDULE OP OF HARDER
RELEASED ALSO FOUGHT IN A TIMELY
MANNER. AND LASTLY ON ISSUE
NUMBER SIX ON SPECIAL EDUCATION
WILL SUPPORT ON A. B. THIRTY ONE
THIRTY SIX WE BELIEVE IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO.
INCREASED FUNDING FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION REIMBRSEMENTS
EQUALIZATION FOR OUR SCHOOLS
ACROSS THE STATE GIVEN THAT IT'S
OF A MANDATE AND WE NEED A LOT
OF SUPPORT FOR STUDENTS IN
SPECIAL ED CLASSROOMS THANK YOU.
IF YOU.
GOOD MORNING MICHELLE MCANDREW
IT ON BEHALF OF THE TORRANCE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AS THE LAST SPEAKER HERE.
I WILL UNDERSCORE MANY OF THE
COMMENTS ON ITEM SIX.
AND THE NEED FOR ADDITIONAL AB
SIX OH TO FUNDS ON WHERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY
SIX.
AND SEE IF THE THE NEED IS
CRITICAL FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
BOTH ON EIGHTY SIX OH TO
EQUALIZATION AS WELL AS
PRESCHOOLERS WITH DISABILITIES
AND FOR HIGH COST HIGH NEED.
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY CAN ACCESS
THEIR EDUCATION FOR ALL THOSE
REASONS WE SUPPORT ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
SECOND TO THE LAST WEEK.
MISTER CHAIR OF MICHAEL YOUNG
WITH CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE
ITEM NUMBER TO. THE US SUMMER
BRIDGE FIND A WE THINK THIS IS A
CRITICAL MEASURE TO MAKE SURE
THAT ARE CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES
HAVE THE.
I HAD THE ECONOMIC.
TOOLS TO BE ABLE TO SURVIVE THE
MONTHS WITH THEIR JOB PLACEMENT
IT'S A LOT OF TIMES THEY HAVE TO
GO ON. IMAX OTHER CRITICAL
ARTICLE WITH TO FOOD BANKS RELY
ON PUBLIC SUBSIDIES AND WE THINK
THIS UP RESPOND WILL GIVE THEM
THE TOOLS TO BE ABLE TO. SAID TO
LIVE PROSPERS THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
STAY KNOW WHETHER.
PUBLIC COMMENTS WE ARE HEARING